e
call the uh Judiciary Committee to order
and I want to apologize to uh folks for
starting late I know we have a busy day
and uh uh we just couldn't be helped so
first um before we begin I'm going to
ask uh representative Andrew if she
Allegiance I PL aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
and
um
yes before you start could I ask you a
question of course thank you very much
um it's come to my attention that on
Monday um when we have a hearing on a
bill that um there is going to be an
amendment um that as of a I would call
non gerain but apparently the speaker
doesn't um that will go to the committee
and I wonder
if um you will be making that public
before the hearing so that people who
come to
testify will know what um is likely to
transpire uh yes the answer to that
question is yes um and um my
my understanding um was a little bit
different than than than yours and there
that um not that the speaker had
determined that the amendment was
Germain but that um it that uh we needed
that we would have a because it was non-
gerain we would have a hearing on on the
amendment as well as on the bill and we
will do both of those on Monday um but
but the answer
to your question is yes I think the the
rules require that there be that you
know if there's if there's a uh an
amendment that is non main that it' be
available um I think 24 hours in advance
and yes that will so yes it will be it
will be available and so that will
appear also in the calendar that comes
out tomorrow it will appear in the
calendar yes thank you very much I
appreciate that Mr chair thank you so
the first bill we're going to uh uh open
the hearing on is um House Bill 6 six
and since I'm the prime sponsor I'm
going to leave this seat and turn it
thank you I recognize representative
Lynn to introduce the bill on House Bill
66 thank you uh Mr chair members of the
committee um I
uh am the prime sponsor of this bill and
um as you will see this bill is
designed
um to accomplish a a a couple of things
the the
primary thing that it is designed to do
is to remove the word
citizen um where it appears uh in the in
the right to no law and to replace that
with the word with uh the term any
person um so that um it would permit
any it would permit any person to make a
request for uh
the any information that is subject to
um the right to no law um I should
note
that although the right to no law as it
has existed for a number of years in a
couple of
places um which are specifically you can
see that those places in the bill
because I replace citizen with any
person um in the in the proposed
legislation
but um although the word citizen is used
as a at a couple of places in the bill
um it's important to understand that
until an issue
arose couple of years ago I think
regarding um Rochester where where a um
uh the the municipality took the
position that someone was not entitled
to uh received certain records because
they were not a citizen of New Hampshire
um that
issue had never as far as I'm aware and
I I think there are other Witnesses who
may have done more research than on this
than I have but that it had never been
an issue about um who was entitled to uh
request
information um and as I understand it
and again I stand to be corrected on
this I but my understanding is that in
the past there have been requests made
particularly by business interests who
were out of state requested information
from some either from the state or some
municipality for some purpose you know
some legitimate business purpose but
they were out of state at anyway it had
not been a it had not been an issue so
this is designed to um remove the the uh
requirement of citizenship and and and
incidentally I should just point out
that the
where the where the current law uses the
term citizen it doesn't say what that
means is it a citizen of the
municipality which um uh you know that's
one possible interpretation is it a
citizen of the State of New Hampshire is
it a citizen of the United
States I mean IO or I suppose I suppose
some people could say is it a citizen of
the world if that if if the court were
to interpret it that way uh then we I
guess maybe we wouldn't have to have
this change but um I I think it's um
it's not at all clear what the word
citizen um was intended to mean um the
other thing that this bill uh does is it
um basically says that if you are
requesting
information um you you as the
requester kind of have control over the
way you want the information and as long
as and I'm I'm
I'm sort of par I'm I'm summarizing here
rather than quoting the language of the
bill but it basically says you as a
requestor have the right to to ask that
the information be provided in the
format that you want it so if you want
it electronically you can ask for that
if you want it in paper I guess you can
ask for that too um the only restriction
is that the municipality or the or the
respond the respondent governmental body
um does not have to provide it in a
format that they don't
have um or that is kind of unusual or if
the request is uh would be unduly
burdensome or wouldn't somehow uh uh
pose a threat to uh the you know the the
Integrity of the record of your
recordkeeping system so if any of those
situations exist then the municipality
can legitimately say no where you know
you've asked for in in this format but
we can't do that uh for legitimate
reasons of security or it's unduly
burdensome what or whatever but unless
they can say that then they have to
comply with your request and I think the
concern there is um
it it shouldn't be the case that a
governmental
body um can kind of discourage you
from uh
a a a request by basically saying well
if you sure you can get this information
but you have to come to the municipality
you can't ask for it electronically you
have to come to the municipality uh to
make the request or um we're only going
to you know we're only going to give it
to you in hard copy and it's going to
we're charging you whatever that you
know whatever the charge can be per page
um whereas it would be a lot less L
expensive and uh and a lot more
convenient if they could just request it
um electronically so that's where the
other thing that it's designed to
accomplish and then the third um thing
is
um and this this is at the
um uh this I included this at the
suggestion of uh my colleague who behind
me representative Edwards um to
specifically put in the sections that um
you you you'll see it in a a specific
reference to that among the documents
that have to be provided are preliminary
drafts that are circulated to a quorum
or a majority of the public body now I
should point out there that this is not
really even if we didn't have that even
if we didn't put this language in there
are there's other language in the right
to no law even at present that basically
um would require that to be provided
anyway but apparently it has um there's
been
some uh there's been some uh question
about that and so we wanted to just we
wanted to have it placed in the per in a
in a spot where it would be very obvious
that this in this is specifically
covered um and I think that makes sense
because it uh
it I mean it my my understanding of the
law is that it it it is covered but we
just want to make it absolutely clear
and so you know maybe in some sense
we're being a little repetitive but in
this in this circumstance I think it
makes sense um with that I'm we have a
busy day and I'm going to shut up and
I'll be happy to take any questions that
anyone might have thank you any
perch hit the butt thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you representative for
taking my question um actually I have
two but my first question is just to be
clear on the any person and
understanding that um under current
theory corporations or persons and and
the like there's no limitation then on
anyone worldwide anywhere um making a
request does person doesn't have to show
up could be a as much a bot Farm in
Russia could be you know somebody
anywhere there's no limitations is that
right no that's true and you know that I
I I I you're you're MIM you're you're
sort of uh touching on a discussion I
had with my colleague behind me just
before before we got started this
morning it's true I mean um
and you know I I suppose that that could
be um a concern I I guess what I would
what I would say in response to that is
this you know
if if we were to say
instead
um citizen means citizen of New
Hampshire and only a citizen of New
Hampshire or a domiciliary of New
Hampshire um I I wonder whether that
would really
be uh
much of a restriction in other words if
you had you know the bot the bot Farm in
uh uh the Bad actors in Russia or China
or the Middle East or whatever that
wanted to request some information from
some municipality in in New Hampshire um
would they really be deter I mean would
would they really not be able to find
some you know somebody some dupe in New
Hampshire to be able to uh make the
claim for them um it seems to me you
know it would that be a a real
restriction a real limitation you know a
real protection against those kind of
Bad actors I tend to think not more
importantly I think this is the the
other thing I think is really important
is even though the
only time that this issue of citizenship
was raised was as I said was in this
Rochester case I'm not aware that over
you know however many years the right to
no law has been in effect we've had that
kind of problem that you
know um Bad actors in Syria or China or
whatever have been requesting
information uh from you know
municipalities so that's that's that's
probably too long an answer yes good uh
just just a second quick question and
related to that is is the the funding
there's no limit on the cost of this
um Bill uh which I gather will be born
by municipalities and towns rather than
the state uh do you have since the
fiscal note kind
of shrugs and says we can't even
calculate how much is this is going to
cost do you have any sense of of what uh
addition
tax burden were being PL will be placed
on municipalities and towns you know I I
I guess again I come back to i
i
in given that there has never been as
again other than this Rochester case
there has never been an issue about
limiting the
requesters
um I I'm not sure that there really is
is a basis to say this is going to cost
you know either municipalities or the
state um more money in fact you know in
many in in some ways it may be that it
would be by making it more by allowing
municipalities to to respond in more
efficient ways um it may be that it
actually saves money I don't know I the
short answer is I really don't know
thank
you I I'll save it for the next
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair thank you um representative for
taking my question um my question is
around the impetus of adding on um page
one line 17 the preliminary draft
circulated um can you speak to that I
guess I guess I want to give an example
like um I'm chair of the golf sound
budget committee and we might have
circulated a draft of like the
presentation we are going to distribute
during a public hearing and we may not
want to have disclosed it right away
seeing how it might have incorrect
information or you know was a working
document um so my concern is that
it it may add to confusion for members
of the public to have these working
documents disclosed um so I'm wondering
what the impotence was behind adding
that part of into the Bild I I think
that the um and I I'll I it may be that
the that representative Edwards can give
you more detail than I can but my
understanding is and I think he's
correct on this that that
that those materials would already be
included under the existing language of
the right to no law not and I'm not
please understand I'm not saying that
there's some language that says
preliminary drafts circulated to the
major but I think there is language that
says if if there if documents that are
um provided to uh the majority of a
committee are are um are covered by the
right to no law um and so I think you
know could there be I don't s i don't
suggest that there couldn't be some
um people who might be confused with a
preliminary draft if it was later
changed but you know
that's I guess that's the burden is on
them to make sure that you know that
they're that it's a final version before
they uh if they're gonna you know take a
something any other qu
questions n seeing none thank you very
represent do you want to speak on this
bill I don't have a pink card I have one
for no I'm going to speak on 74 they're
they're so close anyways I I can talk to
74 and it'll be relevant to 66 okay
thank
you so you're speaking on 66 right now
then I'm G to sit down because I thought
you were I I thought you wanted to speak
on 66 I have just biting it the bit okay
I have other speak speakers here they
have pink cards in on 66 so I I I could
if you wanted me to answer
represent thank
Johnston thank you Mr chairman uh my
name is Cordell Johnston I'm an attorney
in private practice uh I represent a
small number of municipalities my my law
practice is limited to representing
cities and
towns um I also represent the New
Hampshire City and City and town clerks
Association although I am not here on
their behalf I am not their lobbyist
they have someone else who does that I'm
speaking only for myself
um and I
oppose uh most of what's in this bill my
concern is not so much the part about
changing every citizen to any person
although I would prefer that that stay
the way it is my concern is the part
about having to deliver govern
governmental records to anyone who asks
for them because right now um there's
been a few references to people out of
state making requests for governmental
records and and when they do it usually
has nothing to do with the purpose of
the right to no law which is open
government usually it's some business
entity that is trying to drum up
business the dog food company wants a
list of the people who have licensed
dogs or the real estate company wants a
list of real estate
transactions sometimes it's a political
thing I've seen requests from both the
Democratic and Republican parties uh
sort of on fishing
Expeditions with a law firm from
Washington asking for all kinds of
election
information um and under the current
law the response is what I tell my
clients is you are welcome to get this
information it is available at the Town
Hall and you can come and get it you
know these are our hours that almost
always puts an end to it because it
really is a fishing
Expedition uh the local residents who
are actually interested in open
government want to know what their town
is up to they have no problem coming to
town hall and getting and getting the
records and in fact in most Cas or in a
lot of cases the town will just email it
to them just as as a courtesy but they
are not required to do that the current
law says you can come to town hall and
get it and my concern is that under this
bill lines
27 to 28 on page one the I think it's
page one yeah the public body your
agency shall provide such records
electronically or by
mail so uh Mr chairman you talked about
uh making it easier because they they
can send it electronically if I'm the
the bad actor in Russia or wherever I
can say I want you to mail these to me I
want the selectman's minutes for the
last 20 years and the town clerk is
going to have to make hard copies of
those minutes box them up and send them
to me in Russia or Bina fazo or wherever
I am that's a huge burden and those
requests from out of state or even out
of country they don't come in every day
but they come in fairly often I've seen
that for all of the towns that I
represent so that that is a huge burden
and and I urge you not to do that um
as I said you know the purpose of the
right to no law and the Supreme Court
has said this on many occasions is to
enable citiz citizens to know what their
government is up to it's not to Pro be a
research arm for a business or you know
a doctoral student who's working on his
thesis and want wants to do research
about town meeting law in New Hampshire
for his PhD at the University of Oregon
um when those out of state
interests are as I say on a fishing
expedition to see oh what's the law in
New
Hampshire please don't make local
government workers don't make the town
clerk or the Town Administrator go back
into their documents and pull those out
and make copies of them and S send them
to to uh these people who have no
interest in in the town the actual town
government um
I I would Al also comment
um if I want if I'm a citizen and I want
these records and I want them
electronically I already have the right
to get them electronically if if they
exist electronically the Supreme Court
has said if they exist electronically
and it's reasonably possible to provide
them electronically and the person asks
for them electronically you have to give
them
electronically um so I I don't think
that's a problem the last thing I would
say is agree the part about preliminary
drafts I think it's very clear those are
already subject to disclosure if they
went to a quorum or a majority of the
body uh representative Alexander's
concern I understand it when when one of
my towns ask me about that I say don't
send it if you don't want to disclose it
don't give it to a majority of the body
as long as it's just a draft and it
doesn't go to a majority it's not
disclosable but if it goes to a majority
it is so I don't think you need that
doesn't really hurt to put that in there
other than I think it clutters up the
law and I I'm not in favor of adding
stuff that you don't need um it wouldn't
be the end of the world if you had that
but I just don't think it's necessary
and that's all I have and I'd be happy
to answer questions thank you questions
for yes representative
Smith thank you very much Mr chair um uh
welcome um Mr Johnson it's good to see
you again we haven't seen you for a
while since you've left the municipal
Association nice to see you those of you
who I used to know uh and um I think
you've had enough experience here to to
know that one thing we do not do is
ascribe to
others um their
motives as to why they are doing
something and uh a lot of your testimony
was based on ascribing the the motives
of others whoop excuse me
um I am particularly interested in
knowing were you still at the municipal
Association when the Rochester case
unfolded no no I was not and do you have
if could I just ask one more of course
do you have any um uh opinions on um the
uh decision of the court on the RO
case I actually did that go to the
Supreme Court okay so I so I don't know
that much about it but I my what I heard
is I think it was a newspaper maybe
based in Maine that wanted the
information and the city said you're not
a New Hampshire resident so you don't
get it um and and I may be wrong about
that people behind me may know more
about it than than I do I'll tell you if
if I had been advising them I would have
said just give it to them you know it's
it's not a big deal um and I mean I
don't have any problem at all with the
idea that the Boston Globe or the
Burlington Free Press or the main
Portland whatever it is should be
getting asking information and getting
it about um government in New Hampshire
they cover New Hampshire and that's fine
um so as I say my concern is not so much
the any person it's that you have to
deliver it to them and if I if I got one
of my towns got that request from a
newspaper in Maine I would probably say
just send it to them but if they want
I'd say tell them it's here you can come
and get it but I wouldn't deny the
request going back to motives I agree we
don't need to ascribe motives my only
point is if if if you're going to
require uh Town employees to send stuff
to anyone who asks for it anywhere in
the world that's a big that's a big
burden thank you other questions yes
representative peternell and thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for answering
my question um my concern is we have a I
live on lake wiip pasak and not on the
lake but near the lake and in a town on
the lake and we have a lot of people who
have second homes and things like that
would there be a def defition of um
someone who could request um information
from a town a
municipality that would include someone
who owns a residence or a business in
New Hampshire but is not necessarily a
citizen of New Hampshire that that's
where I'm having a hard time with this
because it certainly needs to be broader
than somebody who's just living in New
Hampshire or resident of New Hampshire
or a voter in New Hampshire because
there are other people who have property
rights in New Hampshire I I think
that may be addressed in the next bill
House Bill 74 um and
again it if you want to say anyone who
is a resident of or owns property in or
is a taxpayer in the state of New
Hampshire that's that's fine um and
again I don't even if it's even if you
don't limit it to that my concern is not
so much request from out of state but
the obligation to deliver the to deliver
the records thank you very much other
bur thank you sir thank you Mr chair I
had a question on D I believe that's
page
two okay it said the public body or
agency shall not require the to provide
records electronically if it lacks the
technological capability and I'm just
wondering is there any responsibility on
the part of that particular business to
either classify themselves or inform
somebody that they're not technically
logical technologically capable or how
does that work I I think under this bill
and and and I don't think that really
changes the law because again as I said
the the Supreme Court has said if you
have it in electronic format and can
provide it reasonably uh you have the
obligation to do so so whether under
current law or under this if a town re
receives a request and requestor wants
the information uh in electronic form
and say it's I don't know something from
the 1850s that exists only on paper and
it's a very small town they don't even
have a scanner or they're concerned
about damaging the document or something
like that they would just say we don't
have the capacity to do this or it would
it would present a risk of harm and
therefore we'll provide this in paper
form only and it would just be a
statement like that I think
think followup sir yes so at this point
um people don't have to report the fact
that they're not capable or anything of
the
such currently again if if someone
requests something in electronic form
and the town can't provide it in
electronic form for whatever reason they
they would have an obligation to say we
cannot provide this in electronic form
because we don't have the capability or
for whatever
reason you sir other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you next I'm going to call on
J's biset Mr biset welcome welcome thank
you
thank
you now red is red it's on okay there
you go thank you thank
you I've been doing this long enough you
would
think um thank you members of the
committee Mr chairman my name is yil
biset I'm the legal director of the ACLU
of New Hampshire uh we're here in
support of HB 66 and um I just kind of
want to walk through um the reason
reasons why we think this is a very uh
positive bill for transparency but also
a very modest and reasonable one and so
um those are the things I'd like to to
talk um to talk briefly about first I do
want to just address representative
Alexander's comment on the preliminary
drafts piece that is not going to be the
focus of my testimony but we are not
opposed to the language here uh mainly
because I think the language dealing
with preliminary drafts here um in the
meeting context roughly uh mirrors the
ex exemption language for documents in
91 A5 which does exempt preliminary
drafts I actually think it makes some
sense to create parody um with respect
to exemptions in the public meeting
context and in the documents um the
documents context
um and I also just want to Echo and
thank the committee and and chairman
Lynn especially for um his work on this
bill this bill does have some history we
uh this committee dealt with a similar
version of this bill last year with
respect to to 10 60 um
1069 um I do just want to kind of get a
couple things out of the way I I think
there's been some discussion of Russian
Bots you know or or foreign agents doing
document requests to our cities and
towns I am not aware of that happening
um in New Hampshire so I just do just
want to highlight that I know there are
always concerns you know with respect to
fishing
Expeditions uh with respect to
individuals and entities making requests
but of course I think one city or Town's
view of a fish of a fishing Expedition
is another
person's uh you know uh view that
they're making legitimate efforts right
to try to learn what their government is
up to and I always operate uh under the
assumption that people are engaging in
good faith requests and that has been um
my understanding and what I've witnessed
uh in the 12 years uh I've been in the
state and myself have been making uh
requests for information for government
entities first I want to get to the
question of uh citizen uh citizenship um
or that that change that's being made
here from citizen to
person this is clarifying this doesn't
actually in my view change the law at
all so it is not going to add any cost
to cities and towns that are not already
born um so I just really I think want to
make that very clear that I think the
notion that it is person not citizen uh
is already reflected in case law and how
RSA 91a has tradition been interpreted
with respect to who is eligible for
making requests and that's because you
need to look at this um Statute in its
full context so in other provisions of
91a there are phrases um with respect to
any person AG reeved there are phrases
that talk about the public or people
that's in part one article 8 our
constitutional analog to uh the right to
government transparency and so when you
look at that Statute in context until
recently it has really always been
viewed as as any person could make a
request is eligible to make a request
now until recently we've seen I think
what I view is an a Very an outlier
interpretation by one city in town that
that's not what it means and fortunately
the courts have resolved that it said
that isn't what it means um but I do
think you know I always respect and
appreciate let's clarify the law if
there's any ambiguity so any individual
can read a statute and understand what
their rights are and I think that's what
this clarifying language does but in my
view it doesn't expand 91a or really in
any way change the law and how we have
all kind of historically viewed who is
eligible to make um make make a request
um again with respect to the citizenship
question uh in this change I have heard
some comments some concerns about
burdens we we actually last year I think
um made some accommodations to address
the concerns that cities and towns had
about burdensome requests so that is the
lens that I think is the vehicle if
cities and towns have concerns where
they can have those um uh those concerns
raised and uh to be very clear about
that that bill was hb12 and what that
did was impose certain costs on uh
voluminous requests with respect to
Communications that were in excess of
250 Communications so so I think that
was very reasonable and in return
frankly I think we should be making
reasonable changes here not only with
respect to the clarifying language
concerning person and eligibility to
make a request but also with respect to
what I think has become I think an
unfortunate practice not of not all
towns but some cities and towns when
it's really easy for them to mail or
email documents to say nope you need to
come and show up um this has happened to
me and others including media Outlets we
identify in our testimony some cities
and towns that have done this so I'll
give you an example a very clear example
I you know I or anyone wants a two-page
police report it's not memorialized in
in an email file it's a document that's
electronically maintained that is or can
be converted into a PDF hey can you just
send me the police report so I don't
have to travel 50 miles or if someone
wants a disability they don't have to
you know get out of their house to get
access to it and cities and towns many
uh I don't want to say many some um are
saying nope you need to show up that is
our policy because we have legal
authority to do so I just don't think
that's fair and frankly I don't think
that's consistent with the spirit of 91a
which is a transparency statute it's not
a secrecy statute it's not a burden
statute it is a transparency statute and
so that's what I think the second part
of this bill really does frankly I think
in a very reasonable way because of
course there are going to be concerns
about burden from cities and towns but
this bill I think in many ways
accommodates that they're not required
to provide records electronically in a
format other than the format in which
the body regularly maintains that
information the bill adds that the
public body or agency sh shall not be
required to provide records
electronically it lacks the the
technological capability to do so so
there what that language is dealing with
is the capability of the public body to
produce it and if it's burden burdensome
for them to do so they're not required
to do it so if there are burdens with
respect to the dissemination they're
covered under this particular statute so
I think
um and and again as well if they're
concerned about the burden on scope and
the volume of production again hb10 102
allows for costs uh in certain
circumstances to be uh to be produced in
that particular case so I think this law
really addresses um you know many of
This concerns with respect to again
further burdens on municipalities
they're already going to have the
documents printed out right in many
instances so we're just talking about
how the documents get to the person and
if the person wants it by mail they are
oblig uh the person who is making that
request gets to pay or has to pay for
the mailing as well so again I think
this is totally fair and totally
reasonable and I think addresses a
concern that we've seen with respect to
uh some municipalities so um with that
I'll I'll kind of close my testimony but
I want to thank uh the chairman and
members of the committee for uh
considering this legislation all right
seeing none thank you very much thank
you Mr chairman next I'm going to call
Christina thank you chairman Lyn thank
you members of the committee my name is
Barrett Christina I am the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
board Association we are opposed to
House Bill 66 and just so it's on the
record I won't be testifying on the next
next bill what we do support House Bill
74 I did sign in support but I'll save
rediscussed before me previously touched
on all the Salan points that the school
boards Association has and the concerns
uh that nhba has with opening up the
right to no law to any person
potentially Nationwide um when nhba
speaks to our members and and we hear
about out of state um individuals
requesting information from local school
districts most of the time or many of
the times it's an outof State requester
it's a commercial Enterprise that is
looking for information about students
and parents to Market particular
particular items I've gotten questions
from school boards or superintendents
primarily in the past about out ofate
driver education programs out ofate
companies looking to sell software
platforms and programs to parents and
students um private tutoring companies
that are looking to sell their services
to students um and all private entities
that are assisting with with with
college recruiting they're seeking names
addresses phone numbers email addresses
of parents and students to actively
Market information and are not
necessarily asking for information about
government proceedings so that is why
nhba would have concerns with opening
this up to any person as opposed to
putting some level of restriction to an
individual who has a um a um a Nexus if
you will with um with New Hampshire
whether or not that's taxpayer status
whether or not that's a resident of New
Hampshire whatever language might come
out of this the other concern that NH
hsba has um that Mr biset talked about
as well too is is the emailing of the
records the emailing of their records
and providing them in electronic format
in and of itself is not problematic when
it's a person in your community or a
person in your state seeking actual
government records rather than
information that is maintained or held
by the government such as names and
addresses and email addresses and phone
numbers and things of that nature but um
as I believe Mr Johnson said when we
would get an out of when nsba would
receive a a a a phone call or an inquiry
from a superintendent saying I got a
right to no law request from a company
in California asking for these things
our response would be the same happy to
provide them to you they're at the
central office office is open until 4:30
come pick them up and we often would
never hear from that corporate entity
again that's looking for these looking
for these materials to Market their
their their their their Wares to to New
Hampshire citizens um likewise um you
know I'm not familiar with all the facts
um of of the Rochester matter but you
know perhaps a little bit of Common
Sense could have prevailed and and the
documents could have been provided
rather than having to go through bill
after Bill after Bill and and and many
hours in this in this in this in this
room so the emailing um themselves again
is is not the problem the problem is
when we're coupling that with out of
state entities who have no connection no
Nexus to New Hampshire don't pay taxes
here don't have any connection to the
state but are seeking not even
governmental information but rather
personal information that is being held
by held by um by the government and in
databases and student student addresses
and things of that nature so for those
reasons the school boards Association
opposes House Bill 66 we do support
House Bill 74 um and I'm happy to answer
any questions that the that the
committee may have thank you questions
for this W representative Alexander um
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Christina for being here I struggle to
see honestly what like the difference
like really what it would do to further
Define it as a citizen of New Hampshire
taxpayer because hypothetically you
could just you know find somebody you
know in New Hampshire to request the
documents so I don't I don't
understand why you'd be opposed to this
version in supportive of the other
version when they they practically do
the same thing sure thank thank thank
you for the question representative so I
mean I I I will tell you just
anecdotally from my own experiences
answering these questions from school
boards and school superintendents over
the years if that driver's education
company or that private Tutoring company
California really wanted that
information they would do that they
would contact somebody from New
Hampshire and say contact the conquered
school district and request this
information for us I have not seen that
happen when when when the advice that
I've told the superintendent has been to
tell the company we'll print them off
for you 25 cents a page they're at the
central office we usually get no further
response from the from that outof state
private company if they really wanted
the information that was that important
to them I think they would do exactly
what you're asking representative but in
my experience they have not done that
thank you other questions for this W
representative
Smith um thank you it's a minor question
is there a particular tax that you
believe someone has to be paying in
order to be eligible thank you for the
question representative representative P
I was thinking of your comments about
you have people who don't reside in New
Hampshire but may may own a home in New
Hampshire um if you were to just say a
taxpayer that might be a little bit too
Brad because my thought using
representative Pell's circumstance you
may have somebody from Anchorage Alaska
who is vacationing in wolfboro and rents
a hotel and goes to a bar and buys a
burger and beer they're paying a room
and meals tax somewhere along the way
aren't they is that a sufficient enough
Nexus to New Hampshire for us to open
them up to you know make them you know
um allow them access under their right
to no law I don't have a specific
question to that to answer to your
question repres incentive but maybe
taxpayer would not be the proper the
proper language to use and whatever
whatever comes out of these these
bills other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much sir next
please Coco welcome good morning thank
you Mr chair good morning Judiciary
Committee members I'm going to apologize
in advance this will be my longest
testimony of the day and I promise after
this it's all going to be very very
short um I represent right to know New
Hampshire which is an all volunteer
Grassroots group of individuals
concerned with transparency and
effective implementation of 91a in
keeping with the spirit of public access
to public information we've been
involved in the formation of right to no
related legislation since approximately
2012 and we have a broad base of members
and interested participants with real
world experience in nuanced applications
of the right to no law we strongly
support HB 66 which clarifies the
standard for allowing individuals to
request information under New
Hampshire's right to know law and
introduces routine 21st century business
practices notably the use of electronic
communications imagine that in the
implementation of RSA 91a we very much
appreciate uh the sponsors of this bill
bringing this back to the table this is
an issue that was discussed at length um
and last year and I'll go into a little
bit of the history on that later in my
testimony the need for this language to
now be added and clarified in statute
appears to stem largely from
applications of the law being put
forward by a particular municipality and
also the New Hampshire Municipal
Association regarding replacement of the
term citizen I will assume most of the
committee is now familiar with that
ongoing case there are multiple other
reasons that a non-citizen may be
reasonably considered to have an
interest that information and I think
representative partell hit on that U Mr
B uh Bonet hit on that as well um they
may have children in a different school
system from their community of residents
they may be a property owner they may
pay taxes in a jurisdiction but not
reside there Etc they may also have a
vested interest in issues related to
transit or
health what members of this committee
may not be familiar with and I'm going
to get a little into the Weeds on this
is the fact that under the Attorney
General's 2015 memorandum on on the
right to no law on page 39 the AG noted
that RSA 91 A4 refers to Citizens but
the right to no law does not define this
term and uses it nowhere else instead
the statute emphasizes accountability to
the people accessibility to the public
and the goals of a Democratic Society an
agency should not therefore require
persons requesting access to public
documents to demonstrate that they
citizens of either New Hampshire or the
United States that was the
interpretation of the law as it is now
currently written that language in the
reissued memorandum from the AG's office
is notably absent and it was issued just
last year however historically that is
the interpretation that we have been
using in the state of New Hampshire
until we ran into this situation with
Rochester's
interpretation since the US Supreme
Court case of MC Bernie versus young in
13 some public bodies in New Hampshire
have been applying findings also
relevant to the state of Virginia
Freedom of Information Act to bodies in
New Hampshire nhma is one of those who
recommended that approach stating in
their training materials that there is
no definition of citizen or Statute in
relevant case law but presumably should
be a New Hampshire citizen in part we
believe that is why some of these issues
are now arising verbally during that
training Council referenced mcer versus
young right to know believes this
interpretation is being used an error
and the AG's footnote from 2015 confirms
that I won't go into some of the details
about that particular case but it is
very specific to Virginia state law
which clearly defines who does and does
not have access to information and it
cannot cleanly be extrapolated to New
Hamshire statute and I'm happy to
discuss that offline with anybody that
has questions about
that despite this fact MC Bernie and the
idea that communities might deny records
based on citizenship has worked its way
into at least two right to know policies
that I aware of and been and into the
heavily used right to know training
that's given by nhma and that needs to
be
corrected this bill also allows for the
use of electronic communications to be
used to transfer records when the public
body has the technological capacity to
do so um there has been some discussion
previously about the need for this
language um in this in the case that was
previously presented to this committee
last year a right to no training that
was put forward led to the conclusion by
communities that they could not transfer
information electronically and must
require individuals to appear in order
to request that information that is not
the case they do have that option we
have also um been surprised to hear
concerns that anyone anywhere could
request records from Municipal
governments via an emailed request that
is largely already the case in addition
to 91a not being limited to New
Hampshire citizens it does not require
that a person submit a request in a
certain format an emailed request can
constitute a formal request for
information under 91a and many if not
most public bodies already accept
those uh we have also heard uh concerns
about Municipal governments being
obliged to send records electronically
most communities are doing that as well
when that is not possible electronic
transfer using a thumb drive or a data
device is fairly
routine the real need from this for this
language stems from public bodies who
have chosen to adhere to very specific
language in the statute and require that
Quest requesters show up in person and
on time it is usually and you have heard
it here in testimony prior to me used as
a deterrent and to decrease the volume
of the requests received that is not in
keeping with the spirit of the right to
know law which is the only law that
guarantees public access to public
information in many cases the use of an
electronic transfer is actually more
efficient it uses less labor than the
production of hardcopy documents and the
idea that they are more costly or
Troublesome to the public body is really
a difficult argument to
believe there also seems to be a focus
on knowing who the requesters are and
having them physically come in to the
office um the most recent uh legislative
bulletin put out by nhma states that any
individual anywhere could make a request
without ever sitting foot in the state
of New Hampshire let alone in your town
hall as if that is expected and required
right now it is not however um and to to
extrapolate on that in censabella the
New Hampshire Supreme Court stated that
it would not be unreasonable able for a
requestor to desire anonymity in the
early stages when making a right to no
law request such requests May implicate
political policy or public interest
considerations particularly when the
request is pursued by a whistleblower or
an advocacy organization we would
recommend that the New Hampshire General
Court respond in keeping with this
finding whenever the question of
identifying individual requesters and
physically having them come in does that
comes
up finally we have also heard concerns
and we heard them today about Russia AI
Bots that's been put out to the
municipalities as a
concern um as the Superior Court ruling
in the city of Rochester case States in
during the oral argument the city
identified practical concerns and
difficulties that come from lengthly
records requests from people outside the
United States of the country whatever
the merits of those concerns the court
could not and it then went on to say it
can't tailor the language the
legislature does need to do that but I
would extrapolate on that to say that
when creating law this committee should
be dealing with realistic and carefully
detailed examples rather than
hypothetical scenarios that postulate
unlikely outcomes when the right to no
law is being discussed this is what
happened last year when a version of
this bill came before this committee
passed the house passed the Senate went
to Committee of conference it was sunk
by claims of an unreasonably large right
to no request that purportedly asked for
all police records from an entire police
department in reality that request
turned out to be a specific request for
internal affairs reports for a very set
period of time I do not want to see this
committee misled by her hyperbole again
if nhma feels that AI Bots are a concern
as I've seen in their legislative
bulletin or others are concerned about
Russia I would like to see examples of
those attempts and a working group
established to come up with a solution
the same is true of the aforementioned
Bad actors and costs and I do want to
take a moment to address the issue of
large requests and costs we spent quite
a bit of time last year on HB
10002 trying to negotiate a solution
that would allow municipalities to
navigate difficult requests from
requesters like the corporate ones that
have presented to been presented to this
committee during prior
testimony communities have the ability
to say no to those requests under a
variety in a variety of different ways
they are not required to compile
information that is not already compiled
they are not required to release
personal ident personally identifiable
information such as the school board was
noting about names addresses and email
addresses um there are ways to work
around those large requests and now
there is a process in place for managing
them and potentially
charging I want this committee to be
very clear that that is something that
we put into place to try and alleviate
I will conclude my testimony thank you
thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on uh uh Sarah
Cohen
please good morning my name is Sarah
Burke Cohen I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association as you
may know the New Hampshire Municipal
Association is a member organization of
all New Hampshire
municipalities nhma opposes HB 66 for
several reasons first this bill as
you've heard will broaden the definition
of a requestor to any person anywhere in
the world no ties to New Hampshire this
seems to go counter to what is laid out
in both article 8 of the New Hampshire
Constitution stating that the government
be responsive responsive to the people
who form Med it in statutory language in
RSA 91a referencing the right of every
citizen to access governmental records
although the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has never ruled on the definition of
citizen within RSA 91a it can reasonably
be interpreted to mean the
statute gives rights only to residents
of New Hampshire which we believe
appropriate this interpretation seems to
be supported by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court repeated use of the
statement that the purpose of the right
to no law is to provide the utmost
information to the public about what is
going on what its government is up
to further the right to know on budsman
has interpreted in his capacity that a
requestor under right RSA 91a must have
ties to New Hampshire to make a request
under the statute taken together the New
Hampshire Constitution right to no
statute New Hampshire Supreme Court case
law and the right to no Ombudsman
demonstrate that a requester under RSA
91a was meant to reference citizens of
New Hampshire not residents of
California Florida or a foreign country
as those persons who have no need to
know what the government of Milford is
up to this interpretation allows
municipalities to not waste their time
and New Hampshire taxpayers money
fulfilling requests from business
political organ organizations reporters
and college students who have no
connection to New Hampshire but want a
municipality to do their academic
political or industry research SE for
them secondly HB 66 will require
municipalities to both accept record
requests by mail or electronically and
affirmatively send records by the means
elected by the requestor to include mail
or
electronically given the proposed
expansion of the definition of requestor
this bill will requir that government
agencies send records by mail or email
requesters prerogative to any person
anywhere in the world this bill would
for example require Miss municipality to
locate copy and mail thousands of pages
meeting of meeting minutes or other
government documents to a a person
outside the country or require every
town in the state of in the state to
email a Colorado Corporation information
on registered dog owners so that the
corporation could Market pet products to
them moreover this bill creates
significant privacy and safety concerns
for New Hampshire citizens it will allow
outof State entities to have unfettered
ability to demand and receive any type
of public information they can think of
from public agency although each piece
of requested information may not alone
con constit P constitute personally
identifying information a bad actor
could acquire and put together enough
pieces of public information on a
resident permits blue blueprints
registration addresses tax payments Etc
to create a so-called targeting package
on that person and with the increasing
use of the artificial artificial
intelligent artificial intelligence and
Bots these types of requests will only
become more frequent and honorous and
paid for by New Hampshire
taxpayers electronic delivery will also
mean there will be limited or no
assurance that the record is received by
the requestor with no Assurance it would
be ripe for complaints to the on budsman
or lawsuits in Superior Court alleging
that the government failed to deliver
records within the statutorily specified
time when it turns out that the
requestor email address was was wrong
the requester's handwriting was
ineligible or some other Factor outside
of the government's control prevented
the records from getting into the right
hands it will be too late as significant
amounts of taxpayer money will have been
spent electronic delivery of Records
also opens governments to security risks
by accidentally providing metadata in a
common file format and fulfilling these
requests can often take additional hours
or even days to complete which means
that the cost of sending responses to
out of state or out of country
requesters will be borne by the New
Hampshire taxpayer through expending the
resources it takes to fulfill the
request and the diversion of resources
from other possibly more urgent task
with no recoupable costs in some HB 66
will create an immense burden on
municipalities and the state it will it
will on it in which online profiles and
email addresses from entities that have
no ties excuse me no ties with New
Hampshire can be used to mislead or
misrepresent who is requesting records
and from municipalities municipalities
will be required to provide the
requesting information electronically
which may create security risks to both
the municipality and potentially
citizens of New Hampshire nhma supports
RSA 91 as it 91a as it is currently
written and that the citizens of New
Hampshire who appear in person at Town
Halls attorney licensed in the state
well-known advocacy organizations and
news organizations who report on New
Hampshire and others who allegedly act
on behalf of the people of the State of
New Hampshire are reasonably entitled to
information from its municipalities um
and HMA urges the committee to reject
this bill I'm open to questions
questions for this wit representative
Smith thank you Mr chair Mr chair before
I ask Miss con a question could um I ask
you if the um budsman is um on the list
of people to testify because since um
uh a stated position of his was was
mentioned um and it doesn't really jive
with what I understand has happened I I
just want to know if we're going to be
able to address that he is not on the
list of witnesses um I know I notice
that he's here and if he wanted to be um
uh I wonder if at the appropriate time
we could hear from him um to just make
sure um
I'm not sure if this is a a a reference
that
um maybe I'm of the wrong generation but
I don't know if Miss con if you have
ever read um about Henny peny in the sky
is falling um uh because it certainly
seems to me to be a basis of all of your
testimony I know your
predecessor was involved
over many years are really working hard
to have
91a do what we all hoped it would do and
I I guess I'm not quite speechless about
all the things that you alluded to
alluding to something about the
Ombudsman and allude to all these people
who um uh are out there to get us or to
get the municipal Association and I
wonder if you could give us just the
facts ma'am could you give me a list of
where people from other countries always
countries with uh political philosophies
that differ from ours have asked uh
local communities to give them
information could you give me a list of
all of the businesses um that have made
life difficult for municipal
associations could you in fact document
all of the claims that you have made so
that you could assure hny Penney that
falling I can certainly look into that
representative Smith I would appreciate
that because I would imagine you I don't
know what your professional training is
but whatever it is I assume your own
personal standards as such that you
would not want to say things that you
could not factually document I can
certainly contact the municipalities and
have
them you know put together a list for me
I would be ever so grateful thank you
other questions for this witness yes
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
and thank you Miss Cohen for taking my
question I wanted to know whether you're
familiar with the order that was entered
in the Superior Court in the city of
Rochester case I am familiar with that
there is an order entered yes and does
the association
disagree with the with the order and how
91a was interpreted in this particular
case I
would I would need to reread the order
right now but my understanding is that
there needs to be ties my understanding
is that there needs to be some ties to
New Hampshire for that the records were
were excuse me that the the records were
released
to the the um person requesting them
from Maine as he was reporting on New
Hampshire um
news would you um formally let us know
what the association's position is on
the
order I can thank you other questions
for this witness yes representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question for years I have
been receiving
electronic information from my school
district from the town from a lot of
places and I have never had any that I
didn't receive can you give us a list of
specific cases where electronic was sent
out and never received by the person
it I can look into
that other questions for this witness
yes representative petno thank you um if
if you have written testimony I would
appreciate thank
you other questions seeing none thank
you very much ma'am and you know before
I call on the before I call on the next
witness can I just ask um if you have
written testimony we certainly want to
receive it please do not hesitate to
give it to us but I I think it is it is
generally not helpful for someone to
come up and just read their WR written
testimony so if you have uh please give
us your written testimony and we're
happy to hear you testify orally but it
it's not particularly helpful to us if
you just sit there and read you know um
your written uh written testimony
because we can do that just as well as
as you can right with that I'm going to
on there it is there you go thank you
okay good morning I have no written
testimony so um and I want to thank the
sponsors of this bill I'm representing
um right to know New Hampshire and
myself to some extent um I'm I'm very
appreciative that this bill was brought
forward um I I listened carefully to the
last presentation and I don't think that
the situation is the problem that was
presented the way it was presented you
know NASA receives lots of rights to
know requests last year they had about
350 a certain uh number of those maybe a
dozen were from outside um the state
organization seeking records the city
has always complied and and um given
information to those requests I can tell
you that I have gone just after the UN
budsman um meeting last week that I came
up and testified on I submitted some
requests to other states to get there on
budsman and um right to know um policies
and procedures that they have in their
states and their reporting requirements
essentially I made a records request as
a New Hampshire citizen to other states
and I think that's very reasonable I
also get um requests myself in
information all the time from Foya
groups that are seeking information from
our state and I notice Foya requests
that come into NASA seeking records on
how New Hampshire handles um certain
right to know issues um to look at it
from the perspective of the country
responding to information requests and I
think that's all very reasonable um so
the concept of a person um in having to
be a citizen of New Hampshire I think
we're getting we're we're blowing that
up too much and that I I had written
down that Henny Penny sky is falling
story too because that is exactly what I
felt I heard and I I think a lot of
times you you get this presentation that
it's going to be a disaster it's going
to open Pandora's box and it doesn't and
to give you an example of that in nashwa
when I was trying to get records off of
backup tape the city said oh this is
going to be a disaster everyone's going
to flood us that was in 2021 they have
never had a request for records off of
backup tape again it was one isolated
incident of records that were moved to
back up in just a month 30 days which
was very quickly and the judge said you
can have those it never happened it
didn't open Pandora's Box it didn't
create the problem so as far as so I I
really think that I I like the way the
definition of a person is in here I
don't think you're going to create this
huge problem for municipalities NASA has
not complained at all about uh requests
coming in from other states or countries
and they do come they complain about
their citizens doing them that's their
focus not not other people so um I think
that's not as big an issue Electronic
media and taking records in electronic
format big supporter of that Nashville
really only does electronic format and
has only for 5 years uh this is the
world we live in it's far more efficient
and effective I don't think you're going
to have all these technology problems
that they're looking at you're going to
encounter some but you are able to move
the records without compiling much less
inexpensively um you know and and the
whole purpose is getting information out
as quickly as you can to the requester
and this is a way of doing it and you
know I can't imagine these uh
municipalities that are demanding you
come in face to face take their copies
that They're copying pay a fee that
that's even necessary anymore I mean so
much is in electronic format and I ask
you to consider RSA 33a for Municipal
record retention we certainly permit our
paper files stored that need to be
stored for years or forever to be put on
electronic media that's part of the the
law you you know paper doesn't last for
any ever we are the the agencies are
allowed to create Electronic media for
all of those records and they do and the
only requirement is is that they have to
update it periodically you can't leave
information on a floppy drive for 30
years and then go to retrieve it and no
one has the drive anymore so you do have
to move it to the proper um storage
format but they do that to consolidate
to minimize Vault space and to get a
handle on the records it's available
it's the world we live in today and I
think that is just perfect and I really
appreciate this Bill thank you very much
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next I'm going to call on representative
Jess
me that way I can stand up without the
seats sticking to me but uh I'm I'm a
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31 um uh that's
Auburn Chester uh Candia and
Deerfield I uh I'm I'm not speaking in
my role as a State Rep uh right now I'm
speaking uh as an
experienced um uh risk assessment risk
man manager um both in the it area uh
and also in physical defense uh with
experience in places like
Afghanistan and I I just want to speak
on defense of um the Henny Penney
comments um uh professional Risk
Managers are obligated to follow solid
risk assessment uh practices and and
that basically uh means that you're
supposed to be able to take a look at
any kind of a risk that may occur that
will damage the Integrity of your
operation or your system and do two
things you perform a probability
assessment how probable is something to
happen and uh what would be the impact
um and if you take those two factors you
can figure if it's highly probable with
a huge impact you definitely want to put
it into your risk mitigation strategy
IES and if it's not at all probable or
it's not going to have an impact then
you can ignore it with some comfort um
but um but it seems as though we're
trying to um anticipate a serious risk
assessment on what might happen if this
law gets opened up and I don't think you
should Forstall a serious professional
conversation on that um things that
maybe uh that have occurred that there
were people who said oh that'll never
happen only Henny Penney would come up
with that uh you the Titanic HD an
iceberg had people should have been
thinking might we hit an iceberg in the
winter in the North Sea uh covid came up
we hadn't had a pandemic in a 100 years
it might have been a good idea to have a
risk management strategy that was better
to deal with the pandemic
9/11 occurred that had never happened
before we probably should have had a
good plan or at least some sort of a
risk mitigation to try to prevent that
sort of thing from happening uh the
South Carolina or the excuse me the
South California fires that that had
never happened in a 100 years it
probably would have been a good thing to
have a risk management strategy to
anticipate something like that just
dismissing and demeaning the possible
real
is not a professional way of going in my
view and so when these folks come up and
like the municipal Association and and
and share with us as a legislator from
their experience the kinds of things
that they've been seeing and what their
professional instincts are I think we
should be listening to them instead of
demanding they produce data that no
other witness is being asked to produce
so I'm I'm perhaps reacting a little bit
but uh but I'm I'm I'm kind of offended
the way um Ms Cohen was was treated and
and how she was dismissed out of hand
when she was sharing with the
legislature some serious concerns in the
IT world we constantly worried about
things like denial of service attacks on
our it infrastructure what is being
described by the municipal Association
is a type of a denial of service attack
where if we open up the number of
opportunities for somebody to to present
a right to know request we should
anticipate the
possibility and of of a large number of
attacks happening to uh overwhelm our
systems as a political denial of service
attack so um I I I I like the idea
earlier of somebody saying that there
should be a working group put together
um
um so that these kinds of things can be
discussed and agreed to um that's um oh
and one other thing it's been said a
couple of times that we can just use
email or something to email a PDF I
don't know how many of you have ever
applied for a mortgage but if you apply
for a mortgage there's a a very formal
process an IT system set up so that any
electronic document they send you tons
of them every electronic doc document
that they send you comes with a docy
sign so you have proof that the transfer
took place to say oh we can just email
that you still have to then have the
obligation to maintain a record uh that
you've provided that document and it
recurrently if you're just using email
that system to assure that you've uh met
your obligation to provide the
electronic document then is done in
parallel and is is uh fraught with um
mistakes and errors so I think if we
were to go to a wholesale cross the
state effort to um do electronic
transfer of all these documents we
probably need to look at a serious
investment in something like a docky
sign system so that there's a valid
legal record that we've met Our
obligation to transfer the documents uh
that's really what I wanted to say
relative to um um HP 66 thank you
represent questions for this
witness yes representative
bur thank you Mr chair thank you
representative um I was intrigued about
your
your wish that we do predictive thinking
uh as well in in addition to simply
talking about what's been in the past so
I want to ask you whether in terms of
the new usages of algorithms the new
usages of AI right um we've heard
references to commercial aggregation of
data yep uh do you think those concerns
with respect to right to know should
just be dismissed no I think we really
need to take a serious look at well
thank you for the question but I think
we should take a serious look at uh the
rapidly changing landscape just
yesterday a half a trillion dollar deal
was announced in order to massively
develop AI capabilities now this is not
a press release we would have heard two
years ago so things are changing very
rapidly uh in the AI World there there
would be nothing to preclude under uh uh
saying that uh any person anywhere
located in any place when any person
could actually get immediately
interpreted to be a a corporation uh
which you know legally corporations are
people uh for an entity uh anywhere in
the world to be set up to use AI to
generate um um commercial requests on a
massive scale and given what we've seen
uh I think in the last few years about
uh using lawfare to slow down our
legitimate political processes I think
we could anticipate an entity
considering a massive denial of service
attacks using AI supported engines in
order to bog down government so much it
can't operate and then we start to fall
into violation of our legal obligations
to transfer um the documents so so now
is going back to the idea of probability
and impact Act is that highly probable
well not today should we be thinking 3
years from now 10 years from now how far
into the future do you want to look I
think depending on your time Horizon
it's a legitimate threat um and what's
the impact of that I think the impact
would be pretty serious because the
legislature couldn't respond to provide
the legal relief quickly and then we'd
end up in court a lot so so I don't know
if I answered your questions or I went
too far but but um depending on the time
Horizon you you give the threat the
threat becomes more
likely other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much
representative Edwards representative se
please thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee um I just
wanted to read a an email I receiv
received from our town clerk um who
expressed grave concern about this bill
based on the impact and uh before I get
into that I should just say earlier this
year um around the time of the election
in Durham our town clerk's office was
subject I believe it was to um almost a
thousand right I've lost track but it
was some obscene number of right to no
request demanding records that were not
actually legally entitled to the person
who was request trusting them um but it
was taking as you can imagine hours of
time for legal processes to occur
um yes certainly um if I could just
interrupt representative would you make
clear that we in fact knew where those
were coming from and they were all
coming from the same person who was a
resident of of New Hampshire of
Durham the the right to no requests that
were coming were in fact not from
someone who was a resident of our
community as far as I know they were
coming from um their or at least their
attorney who was submitting them was not
a member of the community and was um on
behalf of a member on behalf of of
someone who was claiming to be a member
of our community that's correct it's not
yes so but there there were it was
taking hours and hours and preventing
them from being able to do legitimate
business um during that time so
um sorry let me where was I okay so um
if passed um HB 66 would create
significant issues for the town of
Durham particularly the Durhamtown
clerk's office the clerk's office is
minimally staffed with two and a half
employees a town cler for 40 plus hours
a deputy at 35 and an assistant at 20 to
25 we are currently responsible for
multiple duties serving dual roses
clerks and collectors our D duties of
property tax collection water sewer
collection and all clerk
responsibilities like Motor Vehicle
Registration licensing and elections the
current roles are already more complex
and difficult with new laws passed in 20
24 if this law passes in 2025 staff
would could be faced with requests for
large volumes of information putting a
strain on an already busy and minimally
staffed office with no recourse except a
charge for photocopying costs and
postage after a grueling season of right
to no requests in November 2024 and a
series of trying First Amendment audits
in December 2024 the Durham town clerk
tax collector's office and the New
Hampshire City and town clerk's
Association believe these bills will con
continue a concerning Trend that targets
municipalities and local government
officials um and
further by changing this to from citizen
to person um and also mandating that
bills be sent electronically or by mail
rather than being made available allows
for electronic request with the request
or choosing the method of delivery um it
uh the organization opposes the bill
because the use of person could lead to
a flood of requests from non-residents
including administrative burdens and
cost four me municipalities um and it
could Aid in fraudulent activities and
identity theft um including but not
limited to AI Bots posing as individuals
for the purposes of har harvesting
personal information from Municipal
records so for all of those reasons I
agree with our town clerk I don't
support this bill I think that there are
way too many challenges with it and it
needs to stay more limited thank you
questions for this witness yes
representative petno can you submit that
letter as written testimony for for the
committee please so I I do know that uh
the town clerk has also sent it to
representative uh Smith so that if I
forget to do that between the two of us
we should hopefully remember but um
representative Smith most assuredly has
a copy as does representative is
representative Horan not still on this
committee oh and representative Horgan
received it as well well can you please
send so it's part of the permanent
record do my best to make sure we get
that to you yes all right thank you
other I'm sorry other questions no thank
you thank you right um I don't see I
don't have any other pink cards um I'm
wondering if I could ask the on budsman
to come up for just a moment please I
question good morning Tom care right to
know Ombudsman thank you very call me up
I guess recogniz thank you and you know
my question before uh could you repeat
it again represent Smith well um uh one
of our uh earlier testifiers uh from the
municipal Association um quoted you um
as to I believe
um the use of the word Citizen and um I
wonder if the quote accurately um
represented your views I believe we're
talking about a case 2023 RKO 2023 D if
I recall
08 it was a case in which uh can I just
interrupt I assume the case you're going
to tell us about is now
over it's over in my office at this
point I know the case was taken to the
superior court I know have no idea what
happens after a case comes out of my
office I'm not I only find out if cases
are appealed by people telling me
they've been appealed okay um I'm I'm
not going to go into details of the case
other than to say that my uh opinion in
that matter that was appealed to
Superior Court and affirmed by the
superior court is available through my
website which gives a link to which
gives a link to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court Law Library which has a
lot of my decisions there or I could
provide you with a copy of 20238 if you
would
like if you could just tell me do you
agree with what was said as to what your
position was uh the opinion was uh
specific to the facts of that case in
that case one of the main things that I
did was I deferred to the court and the
legislature in regard to some of the
definitions and in that case it in that
on the facts of that particular case I
found for the uh for the claim it thank
you very much and it was very kind of
you to agree
to all right uh and representative Lynn
I I I don't think that anything has gone
any further in that case but I don't
know that that's fine thank thank you
very
uh oh God
sure right um uh so I'm going to close
former representative Josh
Kella hello thank you for uh taking my
my testimony one of uh is going to be
very very short one of the things that I
didn't hear mentioned um about the
issues with Citizen and and clarify
making it required to be a citizen or a
taxpayer or something like that is that
a municipality could require proof of
citizenship or taxpayer status or some
other you know residence or tied to New
Hampshire or some other um thing before
they consider it a valid request under
91a and so we could get tied up in you
know is this a a you know
expired uh license or how long ago was
this lease or whatever the case is that
someone needs to to prove that they have
some tie to New Hampshire and so using
the the language of person means that
you don't need to prove that you you
know are like are a real person and not
a computer program or um something like
that uh to the municipality before they
accept your request and start that
deadline right they have a deadline to
to meet those requests and if they you
know go back and forth with you saying
that you should prove that you are you
know have this tied to New Hampshire I
think that this bill would um eliminate
that potential uh hurdle so something to
consider thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you
absolutely I have no other cards on this
bill and so I'm going to close the
all right um so yeah as is obvious we're
running quite a bit over um I guess what
I would say is as we get close to the
lunch hour if people we don't have to
have a quorum for hearing so if people
want to take a break to have lunch um
we'll make sure I mean I'm going to be
here um until people at least until
people return um but and I think we
should have you know at least a few
Representatives here at at all times but
if people want to uh take a break for
lunch that that's fine um I'm now going
to open the hearing on the next bill
which is HB 74 and I would recognize U
representative uh Edwards to um
appear uh in in uh as a prime sponsor of
that bill uh thank you Mr chair and uh
as I stated earlier I'm represenative
Jess Edwards representing Rockingham
District 31 that includes uh Auburn
Candia Deerfield and Chester um uh House
Bill
74 uh was intended over the summer
months to be uh a a a method to which we
uh between the sponsor of the prior Bill
and this bill um uh to provide the this
policy committee uh with a couple of
different ways to handle the Rochester
case uh this this bill um attempts to
address the issue of citizenship that
was brought up in the case and resolve
it I think in a a much more narrow way
um uh and uh I and I think before we get
into it um I I don't know the history
and right to know apparently it's goes
back to 2012 and earlier um it sounded
as though the the purpose of of the
right to no law is to provide uh our our
citizens our voters an opportunity for
them to have the transparency into what
we do so that they can get involved we
are a very decentralized government in
New Hampshire that would be consistent
with the idea that we want to uh be able
to decentralize all the way to the
individual in our state so that they're
able to get involved and get engaged in
the school boards the select boards all
of those things right and and and so so
if that's the intent or the purpose of
right to
know the question then gets to be is it
also the purpose of right to know to
provide support
for potentially International commercial
Enterprises trying to scrape data
together in order to figure out how to
Market or sell it and I and I think that
that fundamental determination of what
the the purpose of this law is is is
kind of fundamental to which way you may
want to go but um let's let's let's
touch Stone here on where we're at today
where we're at today is if you look at
um the definition of governmental
proceedings and current law it means the
transaction of any functions affecting
any or all citizens of the state by a
public body so in that language it it it
implies to me that the original purpose
was to uh support the citizens of the
state and and not a broader category of
all persons living anywhere in the world
or corporations that that may represent
them so so I so so I I I think if we
want to stay more narrow uh what you see
is in line six and seven of HB
74 um is uh citizen gets defined as
meaning any person having a legal status
in in relation to New Hampshire by
virtue of do of domicile now why why was
the word domicile chosen well
domicile ties uh one of the definitions
in our statutes that I think is I
understand is critical to all of our
voting laws domicile is is fundamental
so that word was chosen to to to uh to
build on and to leverage the idea that
we want an informed public uh also the
or statement connects it or any press
acting on informing the citizens well a
well-informed citizen is is important so
having press act to inform the public is
also important now I didn't Define press
I could have but I didn't because
personally I would Define it as as as
any entity that is trying to take
information and make it available to the
public so that could be a 12-year-old
writing a book report that gets
published in the local newspaper that
that that kid would be press uh in my
view of that definition but but I didn't
I didn't go that far so
so what HB 74 does it offers the
committee uh sort of a an a way to just
make a bare incremental change to the
law a small incremental change so that
the the the issue found in by the
Rochester Court can be resolved um
without opening it up to everything
everywhere at any time in the world um
so so I so I command line six and seven
as an alternative now now uh HB
66 um shares with this one the idea of
taking the preliminary the the words
preliminary draft circulated to a quorum
or a majority of the public body that
does not change the law the that is
perfectly consistent with the law what
it does is it takes from the deep bowels
of the bill B um that uh obligation to
share those kinds of
documents uh cleans up the language to
make it an affirmative instead of a
negative and brings it up and elevates
it higher in the bill so it's just
easier for the public to interpret you
know I think it's kind of interesting
that this is a transparency Bill and
what this language does is it just makes
it transparent what the purpos is now
why did I think that needed to be done
last term I had a reporter come to me a
credible I think a credible reporter and
uh she reported to me that um in her
experience some of the more
bureaucratic public bodies used this
technique where they would hide the ball
they they would keep something in a
draft status even though it was known to
have gone out out to the people of the
public body and just say no it's a draft
we don't publish drafts and then talking
to the udman about that situation um uh
three years ago at this
point um it was it was clear to the
Ombudsman that the draft after X days I
think it was 10 or something like that
becomes accessible and um and and that
the entity that was hiding the ball if a
formal complaint had been filed would
have been told to share the documents
but that sort of process slows the whole
thing down so if you have uh a a a
public body that doesn't want to be
transparent a technique that seems to be
possible is is to play dumb and say it's
a draft when uh a technical analysis of
the situation would indicate
that it's a draft whose time has come
and should be made available upon
request so this was meant to just bring
it up higher so that it would be tougher
to deny the obligations of all public
boards
um and I I said things in my previous
testimony that I would carry forward in
here you know um email email management
is a huge challenge you know that's why
mortgage companies go to a much tougher
uh system those are those cost money
maintaining uh email management records
in parallel from email and stuff is in
fact additional workload and creates
additional risk for the entity so those
the evid the testimony that said there's
no more work involved in just emailing
and it's simple that's not true uh
that's not that's not the full story
um that's it that that's my testimony I
didn't think it was going to be this
complicated Mr chairman I I just thought
this was going to lay it out pick a or
pick B like a Chinese menu but man I
learned a lot today so no I think we I
think we both did I mean I think you
know we both I I think we both had a
sense that uh that we understood the
issues and we both kind of I mean I
we're both supporters of both bills so I
I very much appreciate
that I I'd add that we're both big
supporters of public transparency that
we want an informed public engaged in
their government for sure questions for
this wi representative
HG yes I remember from my work on other
topics that there is a definition
somewhere in the rsas I apologize for
not remembering exactly where it is but
um which says a citizen of New Hampshire
is a citizen of the United States and of
course I guess we're having a nationwide
debate about definition citizen but
that's uh you introduced the bill before
that happened but um anyway it's a
citizen of the United States who's a
resident of New Hampshire so why do we
need uh a separate definition in this
bill I can mean I understand you may
want to include other people who aren't
citizens of New Hampshire but like why
redefine the word citizen when it's
already clearly defined who's a citizen
of of New
Hampshire is there a question there do
you want me to like why yes why is it
necessary giv that citizen of is already
clearly defined so I'm not a lawyer it
sounds to me like you have a good point
uh the the the point I'm I'm advocating
for is to go back to First principles
what's the purpose of this bill the purp
or this law the purpose of this law to
me seems to be we want a well-informed
public that can be engaged in their
community and so uh if if this isn't the
if redefining citizen in this context
isn't the right way to do it you it
still may be worth it to come up with a
word that we carve it out so that all of
the effort our our hardworking uh civil
servants put into feeding this bill uh
are are really going to the ultimate uh
purpose which is u a better informed
more engaged New Hampshire
population okay fair enough I apologize
I was probably doing something I
criticized a lot which is like ask
asking a question to make a point which
can always be raised at a work session
or executive session which both of which
we'll probably have shortly right uh
other questions for this witness thank
you very much representative Ed thank
you Mr chair thank you to the committee
so what I want to say is um given that
you know obviously we're going way over
I have an I have not tremendous number
but some other Witnesses who I think
have appeared previously uh to testify
in HB 66 and I would appreciate if if as
you come up to testify if you'd confine
your remarks uh specifically to uh HP 74
and also um I'm going to uh impose a
three minute uh time limit so next I
please red means
good morning again I'm going to keep my
comments very brief this time you
understand our position um we oppose HB
um 74 I did want to touch on three
points that I think the committee is may
not be um aware of the first is that
with
hb12 last year I just like to clarify
that the purpose of addressing that was
the most costly and most timec consuming
requests which are electronic
communications are now restricted to 250
of those before um Community can start
charging for those so just to be clear
when we're talking about excessively
large requests from what representative
Edwards referenced as International
commercial Enterprises they would have
to be beyond that size in order to um
they would have they would have to be
that size or bigger in order to be able
to charge from but that is the threshold
that we set for large requests um the
second is that representative Edwards
was talking about the history of right
to know and the idea that it is set up
to be be available to Citizens I'd just
like to quote article 8 of The
Constitution which says to that end the
Public's right of access to governmental
proceedings and Records shall not be
unreasonably restricted the public also
has a right to an orderly lawful and
accountable government does not
reference the word citizen it does later
use the word taxpayer which as suggested
earlier can be uh pretty much anybody
that is paying a form of tax in the
state of New Hampshire so I wanted to
clarify that as as well and finally I do
have a copy of the Superior Court ruling
from the Rochester case in front of me
and while I can't speak for the
Ombudsman I can say what the court had
to say about it um the that issue was
the fact that the uh individual who was
not a resident of the who was a resident
of the state of Maine was being refused
information and what the Ombudsman and
the Superior Court both clarified was
that that individual though a resident
of Maine was representing an entity
within the borders of New Hampshire and
so it says and I'm quoting from the
finding the Ombudsman found as a matter
of fact to the contrary identifying the
Rochester voice and not Mr Thorp as the
claimant that was the issue that was
settled there was no determination that
someone had to have a tie to the state
of New Hampshire in order to be eligible
for information they simply made that
distinction and moved forward with the
idea that the claimant was already in
New Hampshire and that claim that they
were not a citizen was not relevant
thank you great thank you very much
questions for this Witness seeing none
thank you um J Binet Mr biset
thank thank you thank you Mr chairman
jel Binet with the ACLU of New Hampshire
um I I do just want to
um say with respect to HB 74 we want to
articulate our appreciation uh for the
sponsors uh again attempt to try to
address this citizenship issue that has
percolated because of uh one one Town's
interpretation I do think that h b74 is
too narrow and our strong preference
with respect to how this should be
resolved is uh is in the language of HB
66 which again doesn't expand 91a it
just reflects the status quo that has
been the case for decades with the
exception of this one Town's
interpretation so I just want to
reiterate that because I think that is
incredibly uh important from my vantage
point but I do think HP 74 its attempt
to resolve this is uh too narrow um this
definition in H 74 would potentially
exclude for example people that have
second homes in New Hampshire may even
pay property taxes here uh but they
wouldn't be domiciled here because you
can only have one domicile but of course
they would have a significant investment
in New Hampshire as well and I think
should be able to make public records
requests I I do think that this could be
construed as potentially uh excluding
them from making requests and so I think
at its core I think what HB 74 could be
doing um in making this change uh I'm
not saying intentionally but it would
narrow 91a and that's just not something
that we can support here I think in many
ways we should be expanding our our
public records laws so I just want to to
convey that feedback and appreciate the
committee's time in trying to resolve
this issue thank you thank you questions
for Mr binette seeing none thank you
very much um next I'm going to call on
hello my name is Sarah Burke Cohen I um
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Municipal Association um new the New
Hampshire Municipal Association supports
HB 74 we believe it codifies what the
New Hampshire Constitution RSA 91a and
the New Hampshire Supreme Court have
pointed to that the transparency to
govern the transparency of government in
New Hampshire is for those who um have
ties to it or are governed by it we urge
the committee to support this bill I'm
open to questions questions for this
witness thank you thank you none is
there anyone else um who wishes to test
is there anyone else who wishes to
74 seeing none I'm going to close the
I'm now going to open the hearing on um
hb80
um and I would uh recognize the prime
sponsor representative turkot
representative turkot
welcome thank you very much good to be
here I think in
my fifth term this is the first time
I've ever testified before Judiciary I
am representative turkot I represent the
towns of barington and straford
uh straford District
4 so before I get into the actual
changes to the RSA I'm proposing I'd
like to go through just a little bit of
the history of why I'm here and what I'm
trying to do um in straford County our
delegation prec covid as long as I've
been there U no no member vote had ever
been taken by phone or video during and
post covid that became occasional issue
a continual issue actually um I see we
have a couple members of the straford
delegation on here besides myself each
time a vote has been taken since that
time I have raised objections to that
vote uh for those who are not physically
present including one of my own votes uh
where I was out of the country and I I I
voted and then I said I object to my own
vote because I don't believe uh that's
what should have have been done uh over
these past few years I've had several
back and forth with uh our previous
County attorney and the current County
attorney uh and unfortunately uh their
opinions did not um I don't believe were
correct so I'm going to give you a real
example of why I think this is
important about a year ago during a
December meeting scheduled meeting a
member of our delegation uh instead of
coming to the delegation meeting chose
to go to his girlfriend's house rather
than and rather than attend our
delegation meeting and when I made it my
objection to allowing uh the voting by
Zoom which I always do he said well if I
would have known rep turot was going to
object I would have come
there this clearly indicated that his
attendance could have been quote unquote
reason reasonably practicable as the
current irsa says he so he simply chose
a
u what was more convenient for
him so what I'm trying to do is to set a
higher standard there are a couple
things in the in in the bill what I'm
trying to change one is to set a higher
standard needed for attendance and then
voting only by those uh at the meeting
I think those who make the effort to
actually be present have taken the
responsibility for their office uh
responsibly whether they were appointed
or
elected conversely those who chose
choose to participate remotely when they
could have been present they Sher that
responsibility as I said before prior to
co this wasn't even an issue so we
should not be permitting now the
the I'll say ridiculousness rather than
Insanity that surrounded that period of
time to upend Decades of of Precedence
and to be used that arbitrary president
uh precedence going
forward here are some of the reasons um
why I believe these changes are needing
uh
needed anybody not in a meeting room
cannot have a full sense or view of all
that is going on um I can tell you
specifically as a negotiator uh I would
never hold a negotiating committee
session uh with any of my team members
not being present um I would not even
allow them to participate via Zoom
because there's so much you can gather
from watching uh the people in
meeting another thing you can't take and
and again for for me a lot of this
revolves around the sford County
delegation or a delegation but if you're
absent and you're on Zoom you can't take
part in any caucus which may preclude an
important vote um that was the case for
myself on the one time I missed a vote
and I had to uh there was a caucus taken
I couldn't be part of
that audio and video can be and at least
in straford county is very poor compared
to being in person
we've experienced very poor two-way
Communications uh the public has a lot
of times difficulty hearing delegation
members who are not physically in
attendance um I know I've had trouble
when people are absent figuring out what
also as I was researching or getting
further into this I I noticed that
what we have done in straford County uh
in delegation meetings is you have to
somehow positively confirm the
individual uh who is on
zoom
and it was interesting to me to learn
that the actual
member does not even have to be visually
confirmed only by voice and I'm not
sure that's the best thing we should be
doing the last thing I'll say is the
determination of
current reasonably available is made by
the chair of the
delegation it can be extremely
subjective and can also be in some cases
politically motivated
subjectiveness where we can has to be
removed so we can Pro provide
consistency so to the
actual to the actual bill uh two parts
the first
one I'm removing the words not
reasonably practical and inserting the
word
unavoidable and the reason for that is
it creates in my opinion a a higher
standard or a higher hurdle for that
person uh who chooses not to participate
in person uh again the example I gave
you of the individual saying oh I could
have been there is a is a great
example um the second part of the RSA
that I'm trying to
change is to disallow the
voting um by anybody who is not
physically present I know that's uh goes
a little little far for many people um
and speaking with someone
earlier um there might be a way to maybe
amend it to add uh like another part of
situation so I'll conclude by saying
that imperson participation essential
for for fully transparent communication
between the members of the body those
elected or appointed to our public
service positions must shoulder the
responsibility of their positions 100%
of the time not only when it's
convenient New Hampshire should not be
deepening hundreds of years of the way
we participate in public meetings by
gradually excluding uh excusing
ourselves from actually being there it's
the old camel's head under the uh tent
issue where you you start chipping away
a little bit by little camel head the
camel throws his head under the tent
before you know it the whole body of the
camel is in
there I say what what's next
Representatives stay home rather than
make their way to the State House
chamber on session day and don't forget
uh we actually had uh some of this being
tried uh during Co and finally I'll
leave you with a couple semi- rhetorical
questions would this committee here ever
allow somebody in executive session to
vote via
Zoom I think the answer on that is
no and one that our chairman or the
chairman of this committee might uh
appreciate would you ever allow jurors
in a trial to listen and participate in
that trial while not be being physically
in the courtroom and then vote on the
defendant's
Fate again that's a no so with that I'll
be happy to take any questions that you
might have all right uh well sorry qu
questions representative Rambo please
thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative for taking my question I
I just wondered if we have a
not reasonably practical perhaps there
was not previously either but and would
who would make that determination would
it still be the chair of the body under
current rsas yes it would still be the
chair okay thank you uh representative
Smith you had a question no my question
was the definition of my question was
the definition of unavoidable I agree
with you as you will know in principle
but I'm not I don't quite see how
unavoidable
answers the concern sure um as I said um
I think the unavoid the word
unavoidable is a a higher hurdle than
reasonably practicable and I'll and I'll
say this I I tried to find the the the
best definitions of the words I could
the one I came up with that I think best
describes unavoidable was impossible to
prevent I think that's says it pretty
clearly for
me uh whereas when I looked up
reasonable I I just couldn't
find for me something that hit the
definition of reasonably the best the
word that kept coming up was feasible so
what we're trying to what I'm trying to
do and the sponsors co-sponsors are
trying to do is just to set a higher
standard now uh I've asked uh our
attorney uh in through multiple letters
over the years give me some and even our
chairman um give me some examples of
what you would determine as
reasonably
versus um I I've never asked about
unavoidable because we haven't got there
but I to give me some examples where is
your line where is that Gray Line that
above is reasonable and below is not and
nobody wants to answer it and I
understand why because then you set a
precedent that's why I want to make it
unavoidable unavoidable is different
than reasonably
available in my opinion all right other
questions for this witness yes
representative
bur thank you for allowing me to ask
this question thank you representative I
did miss the first few minutes of your
presentation so forgive me if you cover
this I'm concerned about the definition
of public body what this includes I know
the uh right to no law has its its
definitions in the like I assume you're
bodies as I said most of this developed
because of the straford county
delegation I am not changing the
definition or intent of whatever that
means uh that's not what I looked into
the definition of public body I I'm
looking into the ability to vote and
what's deemed unavoidable can I follow
up yes to follow up then since I'm not
sure what your definition is it's
certainly not in in the legislation
let's talk about a small town zoning
board
um am I correct in
suggesting that I I come from a small
town and we have a reasonably hard time
getting people to serve on local boards
and the like so um you're suggesting
that it's the proper role of conquered
to use the generic to decide for our
town um what the attendance rules should
not under the rsas I am saying that
anybody who accepts the responsibility
or is elected to that um accepts a
position appointed a position be elected
to a position that yes indeed you you
should take the responsibility to
actually show up and I think when we get
down to it when you're talking
about local I would say the more local
you
get the easier for the individual to
actually be there I mean we could take
the let's take a delegation up in Coos
County uh U you know a meeting for that
you could be coming from I don't know
what 100 miles 80 miles your town of
conquer if that's where you're from I
guess no okay well con W land it's a
small small town where we we know how to
handle our Affairs more or less without
conquer telling us how to run our
boards then that's that would be up to
you I guess but under this change
it would require if you want to be
present right other questions for this
witness representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question it's my
understanding that this a member of the
public body May participate that's
already in the law you're not changing
that at all are you representative I am
not no okay so that is existing and this
bill does not change that at all that
does not change the participation other
than when you're changing the definition
from unavoidable
to um reasonably practical um so no it
doesn't change the attendance what it
does change is in order to vote on an
issue you must be physically present
okay thank you all other questions
representative trip and then
representative
H I know that uh
in uh the municipality of dairy Our Town
Charter defines
uh how people can participate in a
meeting without being there you know so
I assume that uh uh this would change
that uh or override that Charter
condition uh it's this the same thing
with the our zoning board uh you know
they people people will call in and uh
and uh participate in the meeting and
and in fact actually uh vote on the uh
case that's being discussed so I I think
the the change that you're suggesting is
a little more far-reaching than uh you
anticipate oh I I should have a question
right isn't isn't that true isn't that
so
uh well it would depend I've you you
talked about people calling and it does
not change the Public's participation in
anything it what it does is it
specifies the individuals I mean your
town may have rules on participation in
meetings but this is this doesn't change
that this this is an over this is
already in the rsas the only thing that
we're talking about is participation
being AO unavoidable versus not
reasonably practical that's
all representative hgan um yes well
first of all just first of all I just in
full disclosure I myself am a member of
the straford county delegation and in
fact a member of the executive committee
so the member in question um I'm not we
don't want to get too much into the
example we probably should a
hypothetical about limiting it questions
um why
that that you know we had people who
either missed meeting either zoomed into
meetings and we had some cases of
members who consistently missed meetings
alog together so why is it why is it
worse for someone to zoom into the
meeting then to not be there altogether
as at least I'm um we had problems with
some members of the delegation not
showing up for anything so like why is
it worse why is it worse for someone to
um zoom in then to not be there so I
don't get it sure thank you for your
question I covered that I thought pretty
well in my testimony what I'll be happy
to do is give you a copy of my testimony
and the answer to your questions were
would be in there right thanks other
questions for this witness yes represent
beron thank you Mr
chair my
question my wife works at home and she
works for a large Hospital in Boston so
her whole day is on Zoom so are you just
information in the uh non Zoom
preference um not really I'm I'm more
concerned with the U you're talking
about private business um this here
pertains to the
public um and 91a that's what this is
about and as I I think I said in the
testimony I see a lot of problems with
with um and again I'll give you the I'll
give you a copy of those testimony so
you can review it and see it um I'll
send that to the chair or the committee
um I I got to declassify couple things
on here because I don't want certain
names mentioned that was in my notes so
uh but yeah um I'll be happy to send
that to you all right other questions
yes representative Alexander real quick
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative um I understand the bill
is now in our hands but let me ask um
would would you be opposed to an
amendment that would remove everything
after of section two of the
bill and just update the the the bar
that's needed to be absent from a public
meeting or
electronically um I I would be opposed
to that I think there if you have issues
with that second part as I said I I
spoke with somebody
earlier and in the rsas let me see if I
um yeah what it's in the 91 A2 I believe
uh 3B and it talks about accepting an
emergency a quarin of the public body
blah blah blah I think um maybe in that
section two uh
that I'm adamant that I believe we
should not be allowing people to vote on
Zoom because of the issues that I
brought up before that maybe that
sentence could be changed to accept in
an emergency and then continue down that
I would not be opposed
to all right other question
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question would you be
concerned with was one of your concerns
possibly who would might be influencing
a vote if a person was there by by Zoom
because there's no way to say that if
I'm on a zoom that and it's an important
vote that someone's not holding a knife
out of camera to me and telling me how
to vote well I don't think that extreme
example might happen I I don't discount
what you're saying um and again u i I
mentioned in my research for this that
current rsas only require that the
person be able to be identified
basically by V voice there is no uh
visual confirmation of the purpose is
that a possibility absolutely
um yeah all right other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much guys thank you uh next I'm G to uh
call on Karen Rosenberg and um other
than the sponsor representative turkot
I'm going to ask that U people please
limit their testimony to three minutes M
Rosenberg oh I'm sorry I didn't
representative uh representative SEL um
sure and again please limit your
testimony to three minutes absolutely
thank you very much for the record I am
representative Lauren seelig and I
represent the town of Durham which is in
straford County um and I I would bring
up a few points um this is an an issue
that has been a
countywide uh debate for um a long time
um and my experience is fundamentally
that we've had a member of our Coalition
who requested an attorney provide an
answer the attorney's provided an answer
that person hasn't likeed the answer so
they've asked the the attorney to
provide a different answer except the
answer hasn't changed because it's still
the answer and so they continue to seek
different ways of of trying to get the
answer they want um I I object to this
bill for a number of reasons one I I'm
someone who had to miss County meetings
because at one point I had covid and
rather than exposing the entire County
delegation and members of the public to
my very active covid and my fever of 101
I chose to participate remotely to the
best of my ability and I was on camera
per the RSA I had to stipulate that I
was home in my room by myself that I had
covid and that's why I was not
participating um to be not allowed to
vote because I was protecting the public
from uh catching a very contagious
illness I thought was probably the more
responsible choice was to not you know
to be able to vote as best I could and
participate um this is really a bill
that that I think despite this sponsor's
intention would in fact also impact all
of the Town board's and meetings and at
Town boards and meetings um again there
are lots of different meetings that
happen people can't necessarily attend
everyone in person they may have to
travel for business they may have
personal reasons um it may be a child
care issue for them to not be able to be
there in person and as long as they're
visible on zoom and identifying or on
whatever method is being used and you
can identify who they are there is no
real justification for not allowing them
to have an active role in participating
in those duties um all of those votes
happen by roll call so that you know
exactly and the public knows exactly how
that person voted it's not different
from them being in the room
participating in a roll call vote um and
it makes it actually more accountable
than if it's in a room just by Voice
vote so I would encourage you very
strongly to uh to vote to uh in
expedient to legislate on this bill
question uh representative
Pera thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so I just want to
see if I'm summarizing your testimony
correctly so are you saying that even if
your the absence of the
um member is unavoidable and you listed
several op um several instances where
that would be unavoidable that you
should still be allowed to vote I just
want to clarify that that's I I I do
believe that and in fact um it's
currently listed as not reasonably
practical and just in terms of the
incident that the previous uh that the
sponsor mentioned that was a who had
left the state to go participate in a
family event over a holiday time when we
ended up having a a meeting and rather
than leaving a family event to get back
for the vote he was choosing to
participate remotely um it was only
because the meeting went on for six
hours that he said had he known it would
be that long he would have driven back
to be there in time for the vote but you
know a six-hour drive to be there for a
vote might not be practical for most
people or
avoidable other questions for the
representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my
question I see a Pandora's Box do you
believe that we as legislators should be
able to participate and vote remotely I
believe that for committee meetings
where our vote is advisory and not uh
definitive that that yes we should be
allowed to vote remotely if possible um
it would certainly given the fact that
we get paid so little for those of us
who are working to do so many different
things to be able to be successful here
um or in the case of when I had covid
and couldn't be here in person um would
I would be open to that however that's
not how the legislature has chosen to
move forward things it's not how we do
things here so I respect and honor the
tradition of voting in person I believe
on Full House session days we should be
here followup yes so are you saying
during executive sessions we should be
able you you
personally feel that we should be able
to participate and vote remotely if if
there were a way to ensure that we had
full video coverage so that both the
public and all the members in the room
could fully hear and see the person
participating remotely I would not
object to it I'm not saying I'm
promoting it but I would not object to
that if that was something that we as a
house voted to accept thank you any
other questions for this witness thank
you seeing none thank you very much
thank you uh now Rosenberg Karen
Rosenberg
please thank you good afternoon chairman
Lynn Representatives members of the
committee um my name is Karen Rosenberg
I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center New Hampshire's
protection and advocacy system for
people with disabilities um we oppose
this bill because we think that it's
potentially discriminatory against
people who experience disability who may
not be able to attend meetings um of
public bodies but who we want to
encourage to be full participants in our
communities and I think as
representative Edwards mentioned one of
the purposes of 91a our right to no law
is to encourage Civ Civic engagement and
public
participation and for people with
disabilities it or people caring for
people with disabilities it may be
difficult at times to be able to attend
a meeting is it completely unavoidable
well some people might need specialized
transportation to participate in person
in a meeting and maybe if they knew 6
months in advance that they were going
to be scheduled to attend a meeting they
could arrange that specialized
Transportation but perhaps they're not
going to know that and so it you know
theoretically might be unavoidable but
as a practical matter it might not be
unavoidable for someone with a
disability to be able to get to a
meeting um and then what this would do
if a person was in a situation where
they didn't reach this higher level of
um unavoidable in order to participate
remotely it would create like two
categories of individuals who are
members of public bodies members who are
able to attend meetings and maybe and
members who because of their disability
are not able to attend and make them
second class members of bodies by not
permitting them to do what public body
members need to do vote have a voice
when people participate in public bodies
whether it's at the local or county
level or it's a state why body that
meets un conquered it's to enable people
to have a voice and make recommendations
about really important issues like
education of children with disabilities
or quality of services for people who
have developmental Ser disabilities and
receive services and so um for those
reasons we think that this would be
discriminatory it would take a step
backwards in terms of encouraging Civic
engagement and and participation
particularly among people who experience
disability or care for people who
experienc disability and may not be able
to get away and I'm happy to answer any
questions oh one thing I did want to
mention representative Perez there is a
requirement in current law that if
someone participates remotely first of
all the the body has to allow that to
happen so bodies can determine that they
are not going to allow remote
participation from a disability rights
perspective of course we would hope they
would but if someone does participate
remotely our current Law requires that
they identify anyone who's in the room
with them so I I can understand it would
be awkward to say someone's holding a
knife at me but but they would have to
at least acknowledge that there's
another person in the room with
them other qu yes representative
trip uh thank you uh do you happen to
know which RSA that uh is in yes which
which one about the person announcing
that the person in the room with you uh
people being the the group the public
body being able to determine that
someone can
participate uh remotely yes it's in
91a Roman um colon 2 um Roman
three that's where it says a public body
may but is not required to allow one or
more persons
participate other representative
pno thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question if I recall correctly
we had a bill last year about the
membership of a specific um commission
or committee um and the membership of
that committee and that was a
significant concern with parental
participation that was required and we
talked about whether or not people would
be able we talked about different
options for participation for those
members um I can't remember did we agree
I think what you're remembering is that
it was a couple years ago actually and I
mean there's all these numbers floating
my head I think it was HB 308 but don't
quote me on that um but it was it it did
involve the reduction of the in-person
quarum requirement is that the one that
you're referring to it was HB 147 and
was the oh that one that is that had to
do with yeah that didn't really address
remote participation so much that
addressed um the membership of the act
and who ought to be on it and how to
encourage um participation by parents
for whom it would be difficult so
certainly allowing remote participation
does enable parents who may have
childcare responsibilities and other
responsibil Le to a 10 but it wasn't
just you spot on exactly what that was
about but it touched on it um yeah thank
you I I remember that it wasn't about
how they could participate but I
remember that being a discussion in the
hearing so thank you very much I think
your memory is correct other questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much Mr thank you next um I'm going
hello my name is Sarah bur Cohen and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association the New Hampshire Municipal
Association opposes
hb80 um currently the statute um lost my
P train of thought I'm so sorry
currently the statute um states that the
public body May participate that's what
we've been talking about so the public
body has to agree to to electronic
participation which we concur with Karen
we would hope they would do so um
unreasonably practicable right now um is
set by the chair but generally um we
find it to mean illness scheduling
issues um transportation issues and
disability um though a person wouldn't
be able to participate participate in
person they're trying their best to
participate um by electronic means so
their their voice and their voice of
their constituents can be heard
hb80 sets the standard for non inperson
attendance to unavoidable unavoidable
though undefined presumably um according
to the sponsor is a higher burden so
that um it would make it um so that it
would prevent a person from um
participating electronically who may be
very ill but feels like they can still
make it um and they do and maybe they
infect the maybe they infect the public
body if the public body allows
participation
electronically um it seems
counterintuitive as this bill um would
allow if passed to take away that
person's right to vote currently 91a
requires um roll call votes for um when
a public body has a member participating
um electronically to ensure that that
the votes are on record and the public
has access to them um likewise when a
person participates electronically that
person needs to be the public needs to
be able to hear that person as well as
whoever is clerking or taking the
minutes for that meeting to ensure that
um their um uh their voice is
heard instead HB uh 80 uh by taking away
the person's right to vote who have has
to uh participate electronically seems
to punish that member um who is trying
to balance their other obligations and
participate uh in in
person
um H so uh to conclude in essence hb8
endorses silencing votes and silencing
voices that otherwise would have been
able to participate um uh electronically
to ensure that they can be heard I'll
take any questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very
much um next uh uh
please thank you again chairman Lyn good
afternoon members of the committee
Barrett Christina New Hampshire School
Board Association I will be brief I
understand I'm probably the last thing
between many of you and a a warm bowl of
soup on a on a cold Winter's Day School
boards Association is opposed to House
Bill 20 um in our experience um the
electronic um uh uh the provisions in
the statute that allow members of a
public body to participate
electronically have been used without
issue have been used sparingly and have
been used properly um you know most of
the time it is is a is a parent at home
with a sick child or the babysitter fell
through or a board member maybe uh
called away to work they're they're
they're in California on a for for work
obligations we also think think that the
existing law um still provides um
sufficient um transparency uh for the
public for example um you know me uh the
member of the public body may only meet
when attendance is not practicable um
each part of the meeting has to be um
open to the public and shall be audible
or otherwise
discernable um should the me meetings uh
held pursuant to the terms in this
paragraph shall comply with all other
requirements relative to to RSA 91a so
we don't think that that the the
changing the language from not
reasonably practical to unavoidable is
necessary um I don't know where that
line is what makes something not
reasonably practical unavoidable but we
think um the not reasonably practical uh
language meets the needs of our our
local Schoolboard members many of whom
are parents many of whom have kids um at
at home that they're that they may have
to tend to maybe not for the full
meeting but you may need to get the kid
to bed before you can hop on the zoom
and join the meeting uh nhba would also
um uh oppose the language um that would
restrict um uh a board member
participating electronically from voting
um the language of the of the bill says
that the person is deemed present for
purposes of the meeting but not present
for except for voting purposes well if
you're present at the meeting we would
think that you should be able to allow
to vote on whatever matters come up
before the um uh before the public body
um and last um I I want to respectfully
address two points that um
representative turot uh uh made um one
was already made by by the the speaker
from the I believe was the disability
rights Center relative to the concerns
representative turkot has with how the
straford county delegation is choosing
to proceed paragraph three addresses
that as was previously stated a public
body may but is not required to allow
one or more bodies one or more members
of the body to participate in a meeting
by electronic means or other means of
communication so if there are concerns
with any County delegation that County
delegation does not have to allow a
member to participate electronically
likewise a town board does not have to
allow its members to participate
electronically a school board would not
have to allow its member to participate
electronically the school Mr ktina
you're you're kind of you run up against
your three minute limit uh if you if you
have something very briefly you want to
I do not with that the school board's
Association opposes the Bill thank you
chairman ly for allowing me to go on and
I'm happy to answer any questions
questions for this
witness seeing that whoops
representative petno if you have written
testimony could I do not thank you
representative thank you all right uh
all right uh thank you sir um so I uh
does anyone else uh wish to uh be heard
on uh
hb80 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on
um representative Alexander I'm happy
that you're that you're here to
bill I'm gonna open up the hearing on HB
164 and I will represent I will
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chair members of Judiciary I'm really
hoping to catch us up on this bill I'm
trying to be as brief as possible um for
the record my name is representative
Alexander this is my fourth term on
Judiciary I'm serving um the town of
Goffstown um this bill should be
familiar if you have served on this
Committee in the past there are some new
members of the committee but this bill
was one that um last year um we had
adopted as a non-gain amendment to
enable municipalities the option of um
transitioning their records to an
electronic version um this makes a small
small small
appropriation um that I'm hoping we can
um absorb in the budget um and and like
I said this this would this would allow
the opportunity for accessing public
records electronically provided the
municipality provides um a computer or
some way to access it for free um so
there's no additional like tax on
somebody that would like to um access
this data electronically um I think for
the appropriation that's given that the
amount of money that towns will save on
not having should they choose to do this
not having to store their data um in
paper copies and the the the printing
costs the storage costs um I think will
hopefully
um very much make up the cost of this
bill I really hope that the committee
will consider um supporting it as um
former for former Judiciary committees
have and um I have the state archist is
here to weigh in on this as is um uh the
Secretary of State's office should
needed but um I'm happy to answer
questions but there are people here to
answer questions as well so questions
questions for this
witness yes representative Perez correct
me didn't we pass last year that cities
and towns had the were able to put it in
the archives yes so this bill this bill
passed Judiciary it passed the house um
went to the Senate passed the Senate I
believe it came back to the house and
there was a funding issue with it um
because it was second year in the bium
so I'm reintroducing this so that we can
hopefully absorb this into the budget um
the very very small um appropriation
seeing none thank you very much you very
much oh I I have one other thing to add
so um the archist in the Secretary of
State's office is going to indicate that
um the appropriation is a little bit off
like a few thousand I believe it's like
over under um I have an amendment
drafted that will um fix that
appropriation section six of the bill
I'm happy to either do it during this
executive session or if the committee
would like to send it to finance um they
can also hopefully adopt that Amendment
so that's up to the committee um but I
want to let you know I have an amendment
in drafting sure you know I just
question this is going to have to go to
finance anyway isn't it I believe it's
an early bill yeah all right all right
all right thank you um next I'm gonna
Hennessy good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee nice to see everyone my
name is Aaron Hennessy I am the deputy
secretary of state and with me today is
Ashley Miller who is New Hampshire State
archist Ashley is going to tell you a
little bit about the bill and what um
our department would do with it um and
then we are happy to take any questions
have good afternoon
hi um my name is Ashley Miller I am the
New Hampshire State archist under the
Secretary of State's office I support
House Bill 164 relative to local records
retention as the Director of archives
and Records management for the state our
division is often sought out by
municipalities to answer their records
related questions as you know New
Hampshire has home to over 200
municipalities each with their own
unique
challenges a local government records
manager plays a crucial role in ensuring
efficient recordkeeping this role will
allow us to reach every municipality to
promote and Implement systematic
organization preserve the historical
records they do have train them on
digitization and metadata
standards and this not only streamlines
our recordkeeping processes Statewide
but it allows for quick retrieval of
information this bill does not create
any new positions under the Secretary of
State's office but it does fund a
position that is currently
unfunded with the funding of this
position we can better serve all of our
municipalities by providing Outreach
training best practices and a convenient
Repository where their records can be
both preserved and accessible to the
public archives are arsenals of
accountability we strive to preserve the
historical record to promote government
transparency increased access to records
for the public allows citizens to
monitor government activities and
exercise their rights as informed
citizens this bill is a step towards
access thank you to the committee for
the opportunity to speak and I'm happy
to answer any questions questions for
this witness yes representative Rono
thank thankk you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question as I am a new
member of this committee uh I apologize
that something was covered when similar
bill came through last year um it and
maybe it's better directed to
represented Alexander is the idea that
um the cost obviously of implementing
this might be offset and part by um not
needing to maintain the same paper
records in the same manner uh going
forward once they are on an electronic
format and available to the public thank
you for your question that is correct
okay thank you other question for this
either of these Witnesses seeing none
thank you very much thank you next I'm
going to call on former representative
yella and
I Mr I just ask you limit your testimony
please not a problem thank you Mr chair
uh for the record my name is uh Josh
Vella uh former representative um I
sponsored this bill last term last year
and um the bill passed this committee
and finance and it passed in the Senate
and was uh tabled by the by their
finance committee because there was
insufficient funds um the idea behind
this legislation is to provide an option
for
municipalities to
um address some of their concerns about
the overhead and their liability for for
um maintaining the records in in often
in boxes up in the basement or in the
Attic um and also uh that you know we
have the this concern earlier today
about massive voluminous requests and
the um cost that imposes on
municipalities where this potential
solution is to have a website that is
access
accessible by anyone at any time um that
if those records are uploaded to there
they no longer need to store them in the
Attic those municipalities they don't
have to maintain that and if someone
requests that information they just have
to provide them them a free way to
access that website if if that person is
unable to do so on their own um and also
the the main cost of this is for the
employment of a person at the state to
help assisting and answering questions
from M municipalities on the best ways
to move you know keep their records and
keep them uh uh accessible to people um
and uh I am happy to uh answer any
questions thank you questions yes
representative
B thank you
chair I guess I'm just curious if you
think that'll bring on any more it
expenses for companies that you know may
either need to digitalize or whatnot I
don't know I figured you might have come
across a few thank you for the question
um the in my research um of this bill I
am one of those people that requested a
lot of documents from my town I have
scanned probably 100,000 documents of my
town
records so I know what is what it takes
to put in the effort to to scan that
document and and upload it and there
there could be if the municipality
wanted to get rid of all of the
documents and the up upstairs and just
be like we're done with that there would
could be a one-time expense that maybe
would be a worn article or something at
their local town but generally the
ongoing if they if they chose not to do
that that would that that those records
could stay there and they would they
would be requested the old way and um
most records nowadays are already
created in PDF format or whatever and so
that they would be able to be uploaded
the current documents right away and so
even if they were like we're not we're
not we're going to forgo the expense of
digitizing what we already have we're
just going to move forward then um they
would at least limit their liability
going forward right over time it would
would reduce and so but you've heard I
think some municipalities they have have
gotten requests that cost them a
significant amount of money and I would
definitely pause it to my town that you
know the the5 or $10,000 that that it
cost to up uh scan all of those
documents and put them on on the website
uh is a good investment for the for the
you know the uh 70th time that that
thing that same piece of document gets
requested right and in addition to the
man hours that it requires to go get
that and and provide it so I think it's
a good investment of the state other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very
much next I'm going to call on Katherine
thank you committee members um right to
know New Hampshire supports HB 164 um I
just wanted to make a couple of points
that in many cases um the difficulty
that communities have providing
information when they feel that
something is a larger burdensome
requests stems from the the fact that
they are not able to get those records
electronically they're not already in a
format that's easily accessible um and
that makes the availability of Records
uneven um over the geography of New
Hampshire and over time um we do see
this a lot when people come to us for
assistance especially if they're looking
to research an issue that has
significant history in their Community
um this bill was created and I don't
think this has been discussed yet with a
lot of input and support initially last
year when it first came before the
committee from both the New Hampshire
Municipal Association the New Hampshire
State archives and right to know New
Hampshire this is um at a time was
supported by all of them um if it is
passed we are committed to encour in
communities to take advantage of this
option and I just wanted to share
something that hasn't come up in
discussion yet today which is New
Hampshire is unique because we do not
have an independent oversight body for
transparency issues we have no
requirement that local officials provide
record management um a record management
ENT entity and we do not require
training in RSA 91a so even for people
who are responsible for compliance with
that law and so in reviewing other state
laws regarding access to information I
am consistently struck by the fact that
most of those include a requirement that
there be a responsible party and we
don't have that in New Hampshire it's
it's so Grassroots that we need a
solution like this to at least make it
equitably available um we rely on
citizens entirely to access and question
information as the only enforcement
mechanism that we have for transparency
and so um without that kind of support
we're not surprised that public bodies
are beginning to feel overburdened so we
feel that this is a solution that will
help to navigate those issues thank you
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much next I'm
Cohen hello my name is Sarah Buren I
represent the new New Hampshire
Municipal Association as you may guess
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
support uh this legislation creation of
a publicly accessible website for the
retention of public and R I'm sorry for
the retention and public access to
electronics records would immensely um
help be helpful for municipalities as it
would allow request under RSA 91a to be
processed more effectively and
efficiently um as an individual could be
pointed to the publicly ACC accessible
website to retrieve requested records um
we continue to strongly to support the
local uh the hiring of a local
government ma records manager to help
guide municipalities um with their
record retention policies um which um
and so again um we uh support this uh
legislation and urge you to do the same
questions questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much is there
anyone else um who wishes to be heard on
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on hp1 164 and I am happy to say
that we have at least a few minutes
before we have to start the hearing on
the next bill so uh I'm gonna again I'm
going to encourage I know some of you
who are at the table have not um have
not eaten lunch and if you want to do
that go you know we don't need a quorum
so don't uh don't hesitate to go don't
don't hesitate to uh take a break if you
want to or grab something um but I just
for the people that are here I do plan
to
start um you know very shortly after one
so if you're if you're going to be here
uh don't don't go away for a long time
because I'm starting uh pretty CL pretty
thanks
e
open the uh reopen the hearings on the
uh from the Judiciary
Committee and we're now on to um HB
265 and I'm going to recognize
kab thank you chairman Lynn and members
of the committee my name is
representative Caitlyn cab I'm here to
introduce HB 265 for the prime sponsor
who couldn't be here right now I'm a
co-sponsor of the bill so this bill
simply just
requires that minutes now contain the
start time and the end time of the
meeting and the name and the signature
of the person who wrote the minutes and
the reason behind the bill is there's
been some instances
where we would have meeting minutes and
somebody would be referring to them and
would be argued well we don't know if
this is an official copy of the minutes
or or anybody could have taken it this
we don't know if it's an official record
or not because some bodies do
not vote on accepting their minutes or
not and so it's become problematic in
those scenarios happy to take any
questions all right questions for this
witness saying none thank you very much
representative uh next I'm going to call
on um
please Lori ortolano um representing
right to know New Hampshire this is a
piece of legislation we wrote and it's
pretty straightforward and simple and
thank you um representative katab for
for assisting us
um the issue we found and what I found
in nashwa is if I went into court with
um minutes which I assumed to be
certified records under Rules of
Evidence the city was challenging those
minutes because they had not been
attested to um and and and then you know
I didn't bring in witnesses to speak to
those records so putting putting in a
start and end time and putting in a
signature of those records will go a
long way to make them certified evidence
for the judges to use in court and not
get us um weighed down in trying to
bring in city employees to testify to
them and in one instance I had minutes
that I thought were done by a board that
had a recording um secretary that when I
got into my trial there was no Discovery
permitted through a series of questions
it turned out the city was acting as the
recording secretary and not even the
board itself so it it would have made it
very complex for me to even bring the
right people in to figure out who had
done the record the start and end time
is really important I think in our city
we have of course our Board of alderman
which is our main board we have standing
Boards of the board of alderman which is
10 eight or 10 boards and those meetings
are all televised so you can easily
watch a meeting and look at YouTube and
you you can see when it starts and when
it ends and how long it is but there are
approximately 30 other Committees of um
appointed largely with volunteers and
some liaison board members that are not
televised and they are some of them are
running pretty lengthy meetings and
you're getting minutes that can be all
of two sentences it it would be nice I
started wondering uh especially um
committees that are dealing with tens of
millions of dollars of money and the
records are coming out with just a
couple sentences they seemed too brief
but then again I don't have anything to
go on to say uh you know how long did
they meet if it's a 5-minute meeting for
whatever reason then okay maybe two
sentences is fine but if they met for an
hour or even 30 minutes and the meeting
and the notes are that short it's a good
indication for citizens to go to those
meetings and listen and be aware of
what's going on and follow up so I think
the start and end time would be very
beneficial we also had a have a member
of right to know New Hampshire who lives
in the North Country some of the smaller
towns are more laxed in posting their
notices for meetings that are going to
start at 7:00 but they start at like 10
of 7
they start 10 minutes early and so the
public comes in and they've already
voted on the first two agenda items and
they're just rolling so by actually
writing down the start time you will try
to get them to align with their notices
and the requirements of the law and I
think it's a pretty simple thing change
and I think it would be hugely
beneficial so I would love to see your
support thank you very much great
questions for this witness yes
representative Perez thank you thanks
for my question um I live in London
there and last year we had a yes there's
a question we had a citizens petitioned
to have all meetings recorded and yes it
was just advisory but it did put
pressure on them so they don't have to
but I don't think we have any that are
not recording literally we have someone
going in with a um their iPhone and
recording them doing being done have you
thought about doing something to that
have done it have asked I mean we have
good tele capabilities and we have the
chambers opened but some of these boards
I think don't want to be televised they
put in something that would make it the
citizens decided that it had oh you're
in a city sorry I'm in a city so we'd
have to do it via petition it's a lot of
hauling for 10% of a population but
we've asked the board to do it there's
been resistance um we could they could
be doing a lot more to televised but
they're pushing back on that so um so
the next best thing is getting us start
an end time and an attested record that
we know who we can go to should we have
a question on the record thank you all
right other questions for this witness
yes representative beron thank you so
thank you chair I just wanted to make a
comment that on another board that I'm
on we um we
definitely televise everything and we
have quite an audience I'm really
shocked by that so yeah so if you have a
good system that'll should work well for
you yeah oh I'd love to see it used more
and the television station has offered
to televise more and to have people
there to televise but these boards are
sticking in these little side rooms that
aren't hooked up and that's where
they're comfortable so yeah it's it's
just a little bit of a fight that's all
thank you other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you um I don't have any other pink
cards on HB 265 is there anyone else who
wishes to be heard on HB
265 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HP
265 and again we are fairly lucky we
have about 12 minutes before we start
our next hearing so so we'll take a
we'll take a brief recess again if you
want to you know slipped a little bit of
food or whatever that's this is the time
to do it
thanks where do you get coffee in this
really
yeah
e
it's uh now Beyond 130 so I'm going to
uh reconvene the Judiciary Committee and
um uh we'll take we'll open the hearing
on House Bill 114 FN and I will
recognize the prime sponsor
good afternoon everyone I hope you had a
quick lunch like I
did uh okay I'm introducing House Bill
114 and I know there's a lot of
controversy over it the reason I
submitted this
bill is because I represent the
citizens and the citizens when this bill
became
law many may not realize it they were
Constitution and I realize his problems
with right to know when what we need to
do and what we don't need to
do personally I think we need to keep
possible unless absolutely necessary I
fees there are people that can afford
fees when they ask for
ex much
information but then there's ordinary
citizen
s that can't afford
fees therefore they cannot ask for the
information and the question I keep
asking
myself and I'm
not trying to say anybody's guilty of
anything but some of the places
municipalities Etc
that were saying they got too many
requests they got too many big requests
etc etc my question is were they guilty
of anything and if a person cannot
obtain the information that is
theirs nobody will ever
know and I firmly
believe there is a balance
but the citizens have a right to know
government and the
employees of all public
entities work for the citizens and it's
not the other way around so I'm just
going to give you an example of
excessive
information back in
2015 that I had
an individual came to
me and said that our school
district was going into nonpublic And
discussing things and then come back out
and vote on things etc
etc me being me I started
investigating I bet in the
end I obtained and read between 10 and
1550 year uh years of minutes of
meetings now if I had had to pay for
them I mean that's 150 200 Pages if I
had had to purchase
those I would never have been able to
find out the truth of the matter and the
truth of the matter was over a period of
years our school board was going into
non-public
and they were discussing things that
they shouldn't have been and then they'd
come out and vote on
them so then this other individual and
I as Pro says once we got all our
information
took the school district to
court for
violation of right to know and
having gone into nonpublic and discussed
things that shouldn't have we went as
prosay which is I have respect anybody
that goes in the court for prosay
because we had no idea what we were
doing but we won the
case now if I had had to go again and
pay for that
information we would never have stopped
the school board from discussing things
they shouldn't have and I mean one of
the things they did if there was a
vacancy for Schoolboard member they
would go into
nonpublic and discuss all the candidates
and then they'd come out and vote on
them and that's a no
no and more recently I know that under
the current law policies need to be set
up and they haven't been so everybody's
kind of doing what they have normally
been doing and recently in my school
district
again we ran into problems so I've been
asking instead of asking for a whole big
bunch of information I ask one question
to a time so that I they won't charge me
and what I found in the
end was that we had a business
administrator that resigned but it was
never recorded in any minutes
anywhere we had a school district we
have a school district
which I don't know what's going to
happen we got too close to knowing the
truth of what was going on in our school
district when they suddenly came out
with a paper and posted it that we had a
deficit of a million dollars in our
school district at the end of June
2024 so I'm going to go back to the same
believe no fees should be charged and I
know people disagree with me and that's
okay but I stand for the citizens
and I would like to see the current law
repealed thank you all right questions
for this witness representative
bur thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
um when you speak of speaking for the
citizens I want to ask you about about
the citizen
taxpayers because none of this is
free so do you have any sense of how
much additional
taxes the taxpayers will pay if the
users don't contribute anything towards
no right other representative for
thank you thanks for taking my question
would you be
um would you consider an amendment that
said
that citizens of a town or business in
in a particular town did not have to pay
fees but entities outside of the town
would have to pay fees now I know the I
know the the thing is well then you know
they'll just get someone in town to
submit it well we can't be police a lot
of that happens but would you consider
that if we made it for your town and any
business owner in your town there were
no fees for
them yeah that would be something to
consider because many
times when people request
information it is within their town most
people don't go to another town and ask
for information and I yeah I I I think
it's something if we could come up with
the right amendment that within your own
town citizens and businesses wouldn't
have to pay but anybody outside of that
they asked for information yes they
would have to
pay other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
represent thank you next I'm going to
call on representative col please
representative col looking at col I'm
sorry thank you Mr chairman for the
record I'm r kulam from Hillsboro
District 30 um I would like to speak in
favor of this bill uh but I would like
to also suggest maybe considering a
couple of amendments such as the one
that um representative Perez
suggested except for there's a little
bit of a conflict with just being the
resident of the town because as a
representative I actually represent four
towns and there are times that I'm
asking for information from one of the
four towns uh so I have concerns over
the fact that just because I don't live
in a town you know and I'm asking for
information I'm going to now have to
maybe pay um for information from that
town so um maybe if we're a New
Hampshire Citizen and we pay taxes in
New Hampshire as most of US citizens do
um that we could be open to this one of
the problems I do see and I think is a
legitimate problem um in talking with
our police chief is that you know the
the police department in my town got
hammered with right to no requests and
he does not do anything through email
everything is paper requests uh he
fulfills only with paper so he does
incur an awful lot of money for that and
what happens is often people will send
in the request they occupy their time
and they never come and pick them up so
I do understand that there is a real
problem to this however we have a
problem on the other side as well um I
actually identified an issue with a new
Greenhouse that was put up in our town
the greenhouse actually never had an
inspection the final inspection the unit
heater on it was actually installed
incorrectly um so there were many issues
I then started to ask for some right to
know information while I was addressing
the problem with them as far as this
unit is not installed properly and what
I noticed on their right to know sheet
is that they calculated that it took
them 14 hours of time to address my
right to know request which is
absolutely absurd for the information
that I was asking and what I found out
um was that the superintendent was
holding meetings within the school
district with the person who asked for
the greenhouse with the facility
maintenance team and they were trying to
solve the problem about how did this
unit heater get turned on it was a
propane unit heater how did it get
turned on without a g somebody with a
gas license or somebody knowing that
there was not a propane retrofit into it
so anyways there's abuse at our school
district and that she put 14 hours of
time was needed to fulfill my right to
no request which was false information
so if we allow them to just build up
that time and charge us for time then we
have a problem because now I've got to
try and fight it
which I did try and they still didn't
make an adjustment but we also had the
problem on the other side with our
police chief legitimately getting
requests that are taking up time so
where's the balance between the two and
how can we make that work without
charging us taxpayers more money to ask
for the information that we have a right
to know because our tax dollars are
actually funding these things so I don't
know what the right answer is as far as
the the amendment I like the idea my
thought well I was listening was that
maybe we allow the New Hampshire
residents to request right to know
information for free and we try to
encourage them to send as much as they
can electronically and that it doesn't
have to be done on paper um or you know
we go in and we make our own copies with
our phones I mean most everybody has an
electronic device where we can scan
documents now which is often what I do
when I go to another town and they don't
email me stuff I just go in and I scan
it on my phone and then I print my own
PDF when I get home so um I like the
idea of not charging us fees don't like
the idea of our police departments and
other areas getting um you know
unreasonable requests and asking for a
lot of information and I don't like the
idea of other departments inflating the
the number that they need so that they
can meet the requirements in our law
that will allow them to
charge all right thank you questions for
this witness yes representative
kop thank you chairman lynon thank you
for taking my question rep c I wanted to
ask are you aware that in current law
that there is no charge for an amount of
time and in fact what the current law
has is that if you're requesting more
than 250 Communications meaning emails
that you could be charged up to $1 per
communication and that's not per page
that's per communication um anything
that's under one subject is all
considered one communication as well as
any attachments so that it it is a
static price for the number of records
and
not by number of hours thank you for the
question yes I'm aware uh I'm aware that
we had made this change in the bill that
was passed uh in the last session um
however it concerns me that through the
conversation and the amount of bills
that we have coming up that there may be
an attempt to try to go that direction
again and I'm hoping that there isn't so
I am aware of that um so thank you for
the question
other questions for this witness
representative Perez could we think
about what are your thoughts on if we
had it for um citizens but then because
we're we're not uh we're not um we don't
make money you know citizens but
businesses had to um be charged because
what happens like I know what happened
in London when we had our town manager
running actually for Senate a few years
ago we had newspapers and places from
all over the United States res
requesting everything about him so maybe
if we could make it so citizens weren't
charged but P but companies or
businesses that were you know for profit
as were not for profit would be charged
would that cover what you're trying to
cover as far as you know going from town
to town
thank you for the question that sounds
like that could be a reasonable um
solution as
well other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next I'm going to call on Katherine
coko
please hello again hi um
right to know New Hampshire struggled
with this bill we spent a lot of time
last year negotiating
hb12 and we felt that we came up with an
effective compromise that took number of
hours out of the equation and focused on
what we were being told were the most
burdensome types of requests which were
having to go through electronic
communications and having to perform
Reda
having this language that is now in
negotiation right to know New Hampshire
opposes HB
114 we think that strategically it can
do more harm than good to go back and
try to renegotiate um this
scenario I we will say that generally
what we have been hearing is that this
rule is not being implemented in
municipalities they are required to have
a policy in place before they are
allowed to charge anybody for records
and we are aware of only a handful of
communities who have actually done that
we also feel that by addressing this
major concern of public bodies we are
removing barriers to making progress on
other issues such as getting more timely
responses communities now have no excuse
to come back to us and say well the
request might be too long take too be
too hard and we have to have our
attorneys go through them we've removed
liability they can have it automatically
reacted we feel like we've made
significant concessions in the interest
of moving right to know forward in other
ways um and we expect that we'll be able
to do that moving forward if this stays
in statute that was not an easy decision
for our group to come to I want to make
that clear to this
committee questions representative
questions representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my questions are you
aware that what towns are doing now as
they did to representative they're
saying how many hours it took them and
they're equating the hours that it took
them to how much it's
costing cost the the um citizens which
really I mean it is it really inflates a
lot and it I don't think that's imp
passing at what people would have to pay
I mean My Town put says oh this
took so many hours and it seems to
appear and whether they want to do it or
they don't want to do it I can't prove
that but sometimes it appears that way
so to the citizens it makes it look like
this is outrageous
so I I I I am aware of that and I
appreciate that question because it
gives me the opportunity to point out
that nowhere in statute is there a
limitation on that number of hours it's
very common for communities to come back
and say we've spent x amount of time
addressing this issue they do account
for that in those ways and the City of
NASA has made claims about the expenses
associated with their requests which are
fairly outrageous but that does not come
back that's a PR issue it does not come
back to the individual who's making the
requests they are not being charged on
that
basis right other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
um Al uh
Brandon brand brandano sorry Rand please
come
up thank you everybody my name is Al
brandano and I'm from Kensington New
Hampshire and I speak in in favor of
this bill um I have three specific
points one is first to talk about the
memorandum that the Attorney General
produced on 91a in March 24th 2024 this
year A lot of people are not aware of it
it's the first rewrite in 15 years and
it's a very inclusive 254 Pages or so
the second thing I'd like to bring up
quickly is I should I feel like
sometimes when it's 91a I should be on
the Milk Carton uh for this because uh
of my experience I want to just briefly
tell you what's happened to me and three
why I'm I'm I'm supporting this bill uh
first uh New Hampshire attorney general
March 24th was the first time in years
of someone addressed
91a uh the introduction New Hampshire
Constitution provides the public the
right to access government records
proceedings and Records shall not be
reason unreasonably restricted uh part
one and uh part 8 and 38 of the New
Hampshire Constitution the basic
philosophy is underlining the statutory
process is simple openness in the
conduct of public business is essential
to a Democratic Society
91a the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
made clear that we'll resolve questions
regarding the right to no law with a
view to providing the utmost information
in order to be both best effective and
objective the second part is I'd like to
share with you a brief experience uh of
the 91a process before I get to the
other part
um it's what what an individual can
expect in New Hampshire uh I was
involved in in 2020 2 and a case that
went all the way to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court on
91a uh it it almost bankrupt my family
uh it was a bad decision we believed
that a lower court level had to appeal
and went all the way and it was horrible
horrible um the second part of it was um
I had the the pleasure and I say the
pleasure of of working with ob budsman
uh Kur and and that next process having
uh going through the first process
legally uh there was another legal
process that you provided which through
the OB budsman process um the first one
was um it's really kind of a misnomer
when you say AB budsman because it's not
the traditional thing he's an
administrative law judge so when an
individual like me goes there any
individual any citizen you have to
really almost have a law degree there is
um uh there is a full it can be a trial
uh you know Witnesses a statement of
facts all kinds of things that people
regular people would not be aware of nor
was I um I had two sessions two
different issues uh there were both one
was resolved and one was really uh we
were able to work through that allowed
for um there was hb1 154 and that that
was an uh a bill that had 22 election
law Pro uh issues brought up in it but
the the chairman of that committee used
this private email and that's the really
the problem for that is that when
someone uses their private email for
public business when they leave they
take those records with them so with the
help of the onsman we were able to
negotiate a settlement with the house
and allow all House Representatives now
to use their government email rather
than private email um and so what brings
me to the end here is why I
support uh
hb14 you recently passed hb11
uh
102 to me it was a pay toplay uh you
have further placed an unfair and unjust
tax burden on the citizens that in
essence these burdens is simply
exercising their constitutional duties
to hold exact oversight part one article
38 is very clear it says exact for
reason I don't think a lot of people
understand that word uh there the term
reasonable as defined by the Attorney
General in March 202 4 clearly speaks of
restrictions but yet it has no standing
and contrary in 1784 is the Constitution
is never been amended uh so we we're
making laws that conflict with the
constitution in my
opinion um and our inali rights give us
this right it's not a tax right it's not
something that I I believe that we have
to be taxed for or I have to adjudicate
in some way or pay something that's part
of our inable rights these are ours not
to be taken
away uh and last therefore uh this body
must find and pass legislation actions
that are unjust of the violation in the
spirit intent of the Constitution and I
think overturning uh hb12 at this point
with this bill is um is the right thing
to do I'm open for any questions
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir next I'm going to call on Alvin C
please I'm sorry representative
that thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um I'm representative
Alvin C from Lowden and I serve lden and
seven other
towns
I feel that the right to know for
citizens should be uh shouldn't be hit
with fees or taxes or whatever anybody
might want to call them uh even if
there's a
uh a uh a minimum of free request before
the fees hit in because sometimes it it
takes numerous requests to dig down to
find out the information that you're
looking for and you've already heard
people testify to that
um so you know it gives a situ u a
situation where the town or city itself
can Stonewall and you know drag things
out so you have to request more and more
things just because you're not getting
everything at once to the point where
you're hitting the minimum you've hit
the minimum and now you're getting build
for
things
um and that is something that can um
inhibit some people's ability to use the
right to know uh to understand what
their government is doing for them or to
them uh while there have been uh abuses
discussed it may be that the thing to do
is to carefully analyze what the abuses
are and take some sort of action to deal
with those specific types of issues um
maybe also uh you might be able to
consider uh charging
for out ofate research firms or law
firms when they're doing a uh working on
a case or something like that because
that is something that would be uh
buildable to their
client those are sort of things that I
think might be useful there um and I've
heard reports of people requesting lots
of stuff and then not picking up the
information that is something that
should be addressed as to why that
happened and I don't think there I don't
know what kind of penalty there should
be especially if it's just a
citizen uh also one of the other things
that I heard uh a couple people
mention uh of just being able to
research stuff in your particular town
or
city um especially for Representatives
who represent several towns I represent
eight towns um but also there's several
different school districts in the
various towns that uh I represent so
there's almost as many school districts
in my town as there are town schools so
it's it's just one of those things to to
watch out for for U um if if you were to
narrow it down to uh a person can only
get something from their own town uh for
me my school district the district
headquarters is not in my
town so that would be a
different uh thing to look at uh with
that I'll conclude and I'll take any
questions if there are any questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
good afternoon my name is Sarah Burke
Cohen I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal Association NH HMA opposes
hb14 um as you're aware hb14 eliminates
the ability of both for both
municipalities and the state to recoup
cost associated with voluminous record
requests the the bill asked public
bodies many with limited staff to use
precious resources compiling redacting
scanning or copying documents to fill a
request
that can take hours or days uh due to
the sheer volume of the request it
further tells that limited staff it
cannot attempt to negotiate a
modification with the request to help
narrow the request and finally it tells
that staff that if they forget to redact
something in the thousands of pages just
produced that they that the town or city
could be liable for that
mistake which of course will likely let
instead the C the cost of fulfilling oh
sorry the fee schedule in place prevents
this from occurring and instead allows
the public body to recoup some of the
cost of responding without the fee
schedule imagine being a small town um
in which the staff made up of one or two
people has to fulfill the voluminous
record request what gets
sacrificed um does the staff get paid
over time to allow for the response to
be completed and their other duties to
be completed probably not because there
may not be funding so what does get
sacrificed and after taking the time to
ensure every document has been redacted
but missing something then what a
lawsuit which means something else gets
sacrificed because of a simple error
perhaps the fee schedule currently in
place isn't perfect but eliminating
eliminating it before municipalities
to adopt and utilize it will require
towns to sacrifice their resources to
cover the cost of voluminous requests
made by a requestor who may not even be
a resident of that town who instead is
angry with goals to punish and with no
way to recoup the cost it will serve its
purpose and truly punish a municipality
the intent intent of RSA 91a is to allow
for transpar transparency not an allow
an individual to punish the public
body I'll I'm open to questions and
witness do you have a do you have any do
you have written statement I just have
my notes okay no no that's fine okay all
right seeing none thank you very much
thank you um next I'm going to call on
Lori orano who indicates that she
supports and opposes the bill so I we'll
be we'll be interested to hear what you
say Lori orano NASA okay so I'm wearing
my right to know New Hampshire hat as um
Catherine explained to you we had a
difficult time coming to uh agreement on
what to do with this bill uh we didn't
want to jeopardize seeing the situation
or create a situation where it could get
worse we knew when this went forward to
the Senate last year some of the
Judiciary Senators felt very strongly
about this language and even pushing
more into it so we were concerned going
forward to the um um you know the next
branch that we would encounter
difficulties trying to push this change
um we want to make Katherine just handed
me a little piece of paper we wanted to
make it clear that the $250 cost covers
a 30-day time frame so if you're trying
to not pay the fees you can just at you
know draw it out over a longer period of
time so you're not charged and also um
the group as a whole would not support
trying to distinguish between who's
eligible and not eligible to avoid fees
and the only reason is because it was
something that was negotiated when hb12
was handled last year and um it's being
addressed in 66 and 74 we kind of feel
HP so now if I speak to you as a
citizen um as a citizen of nasua uh I
like this bill um and because nashua's
been so difficult uh NASA was a a force
behind asking for these fees to be
imposed
uh they wrote letters and they had all
27 Representatives take the position
that uh a few people have cost us and
won me uh the city upwards of a million
dollars in processing the right to no
requests and then last year and this
legislation passed before it passed a
year prior I had asked the city to look
into redaction software if they really
felt that redactions were causing the
problems on emails consider doing that
and they said we will we're going to
research that and investigate and they
proceeded not to do anything for 12
months so at this year's um budget
hearing in June where there's an open
mic to ask questions I followed up and
once again they have not moved forward
on that so this legislation hb12 becomes
um active becomes uh law and the City of
NASA never wrote a policy to charge fees
so there's no policy defined there's no
redaction software and in fact they're
not charging
anything you know I feel like it was a
lot of complaining for nothing and the
concept that you pay a dollar per email
above 250 disturbs me a lot because I
just finished a request I want a supreme
court order to get emails that were on
this backup tape the city in uh October
got the Mandate from the court and was
supposed to start producing them well
they downloaded them they told me there
were 13300 emails and all of a sudden
they started batching them out and the
first batch was over 3,000 pages I I
looked and there was an attachment that
was 3,100 pages long that was a a
database on the computer a public record
so I said hey I don't want attachments
don't even give them to me these emails
are basic assessing emails they're very
simple I know I'm not going to need the
attachments a lot of it is all public
record just don't bother reviewing those
I don't want you to review and redact
and they wrote back and said we have to
review and redact them all you don't
have an option this is the way we do it
now now two years ago when I filed to
the Supreme Court the appeal had this
order been filled the legal office did
not do it that way they would give you
emails if you said I don't want the
attachments they wouldn't even bother
looking at them they just get the order
done but somewhere between two years
they implemented a new unwritten policy
not publicized only in the legal office
other departments in NASA would not give
you didn't have to give you attachments
but the legal office said you're getting
every attachment it took eight months to
finish the order there were over 7,000
attachments I ended up with you know 80
88,200 8300 records and it it just was
ridiculous and most of those emails
above the if you get charged a dollar a
page there's simple emails like a single
sentence can be three words five words
10 words
and that's femail so each one is
distinct and I have to pay a dollar for
every one of those that if you put them
on one page a hundred of them would make
one page of text it just seems absurd so
the whole process in nasua is is really
done to not be transparent and to be
very destructive to Citizens and they
were the ones really pushing to get this
legislation through and you know and
have never used it so I yeah from my
personal perspective I don't like the
way it went and um I don't think
citizens should be paying fees I think
we got to we and I would work with my
city anyway isn't that I don't pick them
up or I'm not willing to work with them
I would work with them anyway I could to
reduce the burden but they will not
permit it it is not permissible to do
that that batch of emails I received my
own personal abatement application at
least 10 times in the records across 8
months I didn't need my own 12-page
application sent back to me and reviewed
times and the way the email um costs are
done threaded emails you're not charged
for so if an email is sent and there's a
response and it there's a record of six
or seven emails that tied to one you're
going to get charged for one email the
problem in Nasha and I think in other
municipalities is when they conduct
email Ser searches these emails are
coming up as single threads it's the
same email but they're coming up over
and over again what I see in my batches
from NASA is I'll get the same email 10
times spread out out over eight months
or or 15 times I have to be paid I have
to pay for each one of those because
it's not on a Common Thread same record
over and over and over again and there's
no way to work to to to reduce the
burden on that they're not willing to
work with us so it's a painful piece of
legislation I haven't been charged I
mean if they had produced those records
quickly for the supreme court order I
could have paid upward of $900 I think
that's a lot then it would have bothered
me to pay that amount of
money thank you questions for this
witness so I you know I just want to
make sure I'm understanding the am I
correct I think I think I am but you
tell me if if you think I'm not that in
order for even for the charge of above
250 uh email
Communications the municipality can't do
that unless they've adopted a policy
correct and you're saying nasua has not
adopted a policy no policy in NASA so n
so I mean to the extent you're saying
and excuse my using the colloquial but
to the extent you're saying Nashua is
kind of out to get people that want to
want to uh file right to no requests by
charging the money Nash was not doing
that so I I guess I'm I'm a little
confused what you you know if if na if
we're to think that Nasha is this like
evil entity why aren't they doing what
they could be doing well that's a really
good question why would they disparage
citizens at the microphone in public
meetings for years years rip us apart
and then turn and write to all the
legislators all of the SI the 27 um
people supporting nasua to get up behind
this bill and send information to the
state saying we need this because our
citizens are killing us and then do
nothing and still complain that is an
evil government that's an evil
government okay what is with
that what what is with that why do our
reputations not matter and they could
implement it at any time I don't know
what they're doing honestly I don't
understand what they're doing supposedly
they're reviewing redaction software
they did two companies there's a third
one there's no update it's taken two
years how hard is it to pick a software
package okay all right other questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you right is there anyone else um
who wishes to uh be heard on hb14
FN seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on
hb14 and um it's after 2:15 so we can um
open the hearing on
HB
ah okay so um representative Alexander
is here all right representative
Alexander please um thank you Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Joe Alexander I represent the
town of gtown um I filed this bill on
behalf of a constituent who I believe
will be testifying today um this bill
will do three things um first we'll give
the public the right to attend a meeting
where they are being spoken about in
non-public it would make it would it
would make a change in non-public
sessions to give a citizen the right to
attend a meeting in which they are being
spoken about um it will give them the
right to request an open meeting and
then if the person requests an open
meeting that shall be granted so um
allowing a person to have transparency
and and how they're being spoken about
um I filed this bill um with that with
those intentions I think um doing a
little bit of more more research I think
there are some changes that I think I'd
like to make um including notifying
members of the public uh when they're
being spoken about in non-public um and
treating treating members of the public
the same way as members of government
would be treated in cases where they
have a a a non-public session where they
are being spoken about So currently
under state law um a member of for
instance the town of gtown that is being
spoken about non-public has the right to
wave that non-public um hearing to allow
the conversation about them to be done
in public um I'd like to consider that
really is an intent of this bill so um I
filed this bill I think I would like to
see some work done to it so um I'm happy
to hear feedback from other people they
testify but um because it's in our
committee hand I would request that we
would get together and hopefully uh hash
out and further details on it right all
right questions for representative
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative um just to start out with
um how do you know or how would a body
know in
advance that somebody's name is not
going to come up or is going to come up
in a non-private session so that that
person would have a right to come
in ahead of time uh let's say they're
the idea IDE is to talk about person a
and person B's name comes up um what
happens to person's B person B's right
under your bill to have attended the
hearing where his name came up or her
name well thank you representative for
that question I would say that there's
clearly outlined specific x amount of
instances in which the member of the of
the public body can go into non-public
so my anticipation is they would know
the general idea of the reason why
they're going into non-public and then
be able to notify the officials or or
members of the public that they're
speaking about um I think that adds a
little like an extra layer to it but by
saying they know ahead of time if
they're going into non-public more often
than not um because you have to State a
specific reason to go into it so at that
time they can then notify those members
of of that are involved in certain
situation and allow them to attend the
meeting follow go ahead f could follow
up so let's say you've got a nonpublic
meeting where three people are being
discussed one wants the meeting to be
public and two do not want the meeting
to be public what happens well I think
that's a good question for the committee
and I uh invite you to maybe sit on
subcommittee with me to Hash that hash
that out thank you
representative other questions for this
witness we don't spend enough time
together over there all right thank you
very much representative Alexander um
representative um I'm sorry not
coko turned it off thank you again
um right to know New Hampshire
generally supports this bill um I do
want to make a few clarifications um our
interpretation is a little bit different
um than what representative Alexander
just presented um he is talking about
the ability to participate in a
non-public session as a member of the
public when we read this bill and
discussed it with right to know we
interpreted it to mean that the
individual who is being spoken about um
has the ability to not only request that
the meeting be open which is already in
statute but to be given information that
that is about to happen and that there
be a requirement that that requests that
it be public be granted so that is a
slightly different interpretation of the
language and we would support um an
amendment to that effect right to know
New Hampshire has consistant pushed this
reputation question I can submit um some
written testimony with examples um and
and concerns that we have about how
heavily used the reputation exemption is
the one that I like to use because I
find it so shocking and came from one of
my uh local communities was the example
where they went into non-public under
reputation to discuss something and in
the course of the conversation realized
that they really did not have a basis
for using reputation as the reason for
this and so the conversation as it was
then told to me for an opinion after the
fact was
well we need to say something bad about
somebody so that we can stay within the
rules and the reason that we went into
non-public and go ahead and seal those
minutes providing somebody with prior
notice would prevent that type of abuse
that is an extreme example um but I do
think it's it's very relevant to what
representative Alexander is trying to
just see if I've covered
everything so I I think the real
question is the language now as we read
it allows allows somebody to ask for
that meeting to be available to the
public um be held publicly so they can
hear what's being said about them in
reality an individual has no ability to
exercise that right because they are not
told that that is what is going to
happen so whether we want to revise the
legislation so that it addresses an open
meeting where you're willing to have
have that reputational discussion
publicly stated or you want the
individual to be able to go into
non-public session there are ways to
work that we have worked on this issue
before and we would encourage having a
working group to address
it representative Oran um yes thank you
I missed the previous testimony but you
probably thoughts do you have any
thoughts about how if we move forward
this how we'd amend it to cover the
situation well the situation where
multiple persons are involved than
something they're discussing and even if
even if one person thinks this doesn't
adversely affect a reputation the open
discussion might have might adversely
affect the reputation of other parties
involved in whatever the matter it is
that's being discussed I do and I I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
that representative Horgan so I I agree
that most communities are well aware of
what is going to be on the agenda for a
non-public session and what that topic
will be and what it will likely touch on
in my town you have to have your
information in by Wednesday Thursday the
agendas go out on Friday and typically
the non-public sessions are planned in
advance um I don't think it's
unreasonable for a body to say this is
touching on matters that we have not
previously considered and aren't yet
ready to discuss there's no reason that
they can't postpone that discussion they
have lots of leeway for emergency
meetings if it really is that urgent
they have the ability to have special
meetings they could move forward with
something that's posted within 24 hours
so
yes representative
bir thank you Mr chair thank you I want
to follow up because I'm sure you heard
my questions uh to representative
Alexander you seem to suggest that a
um uh a board or or committee uh can
figure out in advance of the discussion
in uh um in PRI in the private session
uh everything that's going to be
discussed or every name that may come
up so
that the anybody's name who might come
up can be notified or would come up
might be notified ahead of time and then
if that doesn't work out and the name
comes up everybody can just stop and
restart again at the next scheduled
meeting and then if the next scheduled
meeting
a name comes up then presumably you
would stop and schedule it again I'm
thinking about Personnel matters and how
this would work uh because so you could
be dealing with a uh uh an incident
where somebody may have to be
reprimanded or let go or whatever and
that person says well so and so saw this
well nobody knew that in advance then
you just stop everything is that is that
the method you're you're suggesting it
it is not I think there are a couple of
things being conflated there the first
is an assumption that the session would
have to stop because it's a non-public
the person could request that it be held
openly and that wouldn't that wouldn't
be an issue but you're speaking about
employees and employees are covered
under um other exemptions under the law
that they either do or do not have a
particular right to be part of a um
discussion about them and what we are
talking about is joke you member of the
public who the board of Selectmen
decides that they are going to discuss
because um something has happened in
town or there is some suspicion or
something um we're not talking about
employees and hearings they have their
own processes and that's what my written
testimony will speak to I can submit
that to the committee as
well other questions for this witness so
I you know I I want to make sure that
I'm understanding one thing um
you you said that if I if I'm understand
I want to make sure I have your position
correctly you're saying that you would
be you believe that if that if a person
is being is going to be talked about in
some adverse way at a meeting they
should get a get notice and then B have
a right to request that uh to request
that the meeting be open and that that
request would have to be granted
we believe that the language that as we
understood it proposed would do that
what we understand is that right now an
individual already has that right says
anything that would other than a member
of the public body itself unless such
person requests an open meeting the
challenge we run into is there's no
notice there's no notice so how do you
make that practicable so I guess the
thing I want to I mean that that's one
thing and at least speaking personally
that might be something if if it
you got to give notice and the person
has the right to demand that the meeting
be public that's one thing and I might
be able to I'd want to think about it a
little bit but I might be able to
support that but are you saying that the
person also should have the right to be
notified and be present if even if the
meeting is not going to be open to the
public I think that's a separate issue
and we didn't think that's what this
legislation was addressing we have
pushed for that in the past you would
support that also we would support that
but I I think we thought that this was
taking a a simpler approach which is
enabling a right that already exists
under statute and the presumption is
that if that person asks for that
meeting to be open it will be granted
but explicitly stating that is also
helpful we weren't going down the
non-public participation in non-public
session conversation when we came into
this hearing all right other questions
for this witness saying none thank you
thank you uh next I'm going to call on
jeru and Mr Drew you've submitted
written testimony so I which uh will be
distributed to the members of the
committer have has been so I guess what
I want to say is I don't want you to
please don't just read your testimony I
want you to if you have something you
want to tell us um you know uh that's
fine but it we're we can read as well as
you can yeah no I'm not going to repeat
that I'm just going to hit the
highlights of it because from this
discussion here it sounds like this
whole thing's been twisted around now
because it almost sounds like you're
going you're talking about giving notice
regardless no matter what if you're
going to talk about a person you're
going to give notice and this is one of
my complaints because in vble versus
town of Bridgewater they stated that
Johnson versus Nash stated that
basically unless such a person requests
the meeting open that requires advanced
notice so that's how the law is right
now but in 2005 so now first off it
sounds like no matter what if the
according to the law the way the law is
written and according to Johnson versus
Nash if you were to talk about somebody
you're supposed to give them advanced
notice to give them an option to
exercise that right to keep it open
now in
2005 I was before The Supreme Court and
I was arrested and prevented from
attending a closed session which you
some of you might have remembered that
testimony in 2023 I mean I know you hear
a lot of them but I was arrested
prevented told to small town
politics okay so now you got Johnson
versus Nash that says I needed advanced
notice and now you got a court case that
says oh wait a minute no you don't have
to give anybody advance notice so it's
kind of contradicting themselves and you
could say and you could present this
argument that since the legislative fied
to amend section c when they amended
section A after the Johnson ruling that
the legislative intent was to give us
all notice before you talk about us but
then in the 2023 legislative session
under house bill
652 this committee said no we cannot
give you that because it's going to
interfere with investigations it's going
to interfere with other statutes and all
that you did not want to give regardless
Clause so now we're I'm kind of confused
because now it looks like we're still
hindering here but you still have a
statute here that says this thing and a
Court ruling that says notice must be
given all to everybody but then you got
a Court ruling which you can't use in a
court because it was a three judge
ruling but a Supreme Court says oh no
you don't have to give notice it's okay
to arrest and prevent him from attending
and you don't even have to give them
access to the minutes because that was
the one thing I was asking for unless
such person requests an open meeting
well what's the time limit on that okay
I missed the meeting I want to see the
meeting minutes I'm requesting the
meeting minutes open and that's when I
was told no you can't see those meeting
minut but that's kind of contradicting
to your statute so I'm kind of trying to
clarify the statute here and that's why
I turned around and I just put because
when you go to court and you're going to
argue this in court no matter what the
first thing the Court's going to do
which you might be able to relate to
this replin is they're going to say
first off you have a right to that
meeting because that's what happened
when I went to the federal courts and
that's what they're going to ask you
have a right to this meeting the second
thing they're going to ask is in a
defamation what harm actually took place
just because this board is talking about
a person you have to show harm also took
place to the reputation so I mean
there's two big jums here but my point
right here is if we have a right a due
process right you should be able to
notif you should be notifying this
person now in my interpretation what
I've been hearing from this statute it
seems most of the violations is because
the towns and the municipalities aren't
following the law
I mean you got people talking about
people and not you know I mean it it's
just they're not following the laws here
so I mean it's like what do you do I
feel and I know in 2023 you might recall
that argument because they were trying
to Define that word right what is a
right well I ask you at this point well
if you got people here holding closed
sessions and holding meetings why don't
they have any idea what the due process
right is because when you're talking
notification you're talking due process
rights and maybe it's a good idea for
these municipalities and these people
holding these closed sessions to stop
and think and say hey does this person
have a right maybe they should start
thinking maybe they should start talking
to the municipal
Association and saying hey what is the
person's due process right maybe they
ought to be calling the do lawyers and
talking to them and finding out before
they're holding these
meetings that's my point and that's why
I want this you know at least settled
somehow I have no objection if you want
to give a regardless Clause that's fine
with me but from your other objections
to interfering with investigations and
other statutes isn't that still in
effect here so I'm just trying to
protect my due process rights and it all
depends on the circumstances of the case
and the Supreme Court and the New
Hampshire Supreme Court I should say us
and New Hampshire Supreme Courts cannot
really Define it definitively it all
depends on the circumstances one little
change in the circumstance could change
if you have a due process right so I
mean I would say I will I'm I'm for this
bill it protects our new process rights
hopefully and it'll get these people
actually talking about what our rights
are so any question thank questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you next uh uh uh Barrett
thank you again chairman Lyn good
afternoon members of the committee Barr
school boards Association um chairman
Lynn I know I put three minutes on my
card this is a complex issue I may
require a little bit more time at at
your discretion sir no that's fine um
and second um uh I I'm passing around a
proposed amendment I did email this to
representative Alexander yesterday we
have not had an opportunity I have it I
have I have it I'll check I was going to
say I did not have you don't have it I
was going to say I did not have an
opportunity to touch base with repres
representative Alexander regarding it
second um I did check off support on my
card if if that I'm going to take no
position on the bill because I think I
may have been um uh uh misconstruing
what the purpose of the intent was and
there seems to be some confusion going
around the bill um going around relative
to the the conversation I in trying to
decipher the intent of the bill and some
of the testimony of the people before me
I think the confusion hinges on whether
or not an individual has a right to
attend a meeting in non-public session
simply by the mere fact that the public
body is going to discuss that individual
in the non-public session NH hsba does
not interpret 91 A3 paragraph 2C to mean
that just because you were talking about
somebody's reputation that that
individual has a right to attend the
non-public session where you're talking
about them um related to that it's
important to understand the context when
we're talking about school districts and
I know we have at least two Schoolboard
members on this committee when we're
talking about student matters we always
use paragraph C the reputation and that
may be a hearing it may be simply the
administration or the super intendent
having to notify the school board that a
student disciplinary matter may be
coming up and it you may not always have
time to provide notice or put that on
the agenda if the school board meeting
is is on Wednesday night January 22nd at
6 p.m. and that student did something
problematic at 300 p.m. that afternoon
and the police may have been called
there may have been you know some sort
of immediate suspension something
relative to the health safety and
Welfare of other students that
superintendent has an obligation to
inform the school board that there was
an incident at school the police were
called we caught a student doing X Y and
Z whatever it might be we always use
paragraph C for student matters doesn't
matter what the context is so there was
also some discussion um and I think nhba
interpretation that the right the the
fact that a an individual is being
discussed in a non-public session and
the fact that their reputation May being
discussed or come up does not give rise
to a right to a hearing I have um I
copied off some pertinent Provisions
from this is civil Lingham SI i v a l i
n g a m v Newton 174 New Hampshire 489
New Hampshire 202 New Hampshire Supreme
Court
2021 um so here's the pertinent
paragraph if you'll indulge me indeed we
question to what extent Johnson has any
precedential value given that it was
decided after the legislature amended
the language in RSA
91a 3 paragraph 2A that we addressed in
that opinion nevertheless the
legislature has not amended the statute
to confer the broad rights of notice to
the minority suggests that the quote
reasoning of Johnson mandates here's the
important aspect nor do we believe that
this court or the legislature for that
matter never intended to imply conferred
to impliedly confer such an expansive
right to notice upon an even broader
category of Citizen I.E any person who
might seek to prevent a public body from
entering into a non-public session upon
the assumption that the public bodies
discussions quote would likely adversely
affect her reputation RSC 91 A3
paragraph 2C so the Supreme Court has
said just because an individual's
reputation may come up in a non-public
session does not confer that right to to
that individual to attend the meeting
circling that back around to my proposed
amendment I took language from RSA
91 d a go 3 paragraph 2A which states
only the following matters shall be
discussed or acted upon a non-public
session a the dismissal promotion or
compensation of any Public Employee or
the disciplining of such employee or the
investigation of any charges against him
or her unless the employee affected one
has a right to a meeting and two
requests that the meeting be open in
which case the request shall be granted
I copied that language and put it in in
in in a proposed amendment to
representative Alexander's bill now we
have to ask the question where does the
right to a meeting come from it can come
from statute can come from Employment
contract presumably a Schoolboard policy
or perhaps administrative law so but
again circling back around
the right to attend the meeting has to
be conferred first we have to ascertain
where the source of that right is and a
student context it would be through
General due process if a student is
being disciplined we have student
discipline statutes across the across
the hall and RSA 189 Federal
requirements relative to do notice and
process and a hearing before a school
board relative to and before a student
is suspended for a certain number of
days so I think that's it I hope I was
clear I'm happy to answer any questions
that the committee may
have questions for this witness so I
guess I just have a couple so um am I
understanding that all I mean all of the
things that you talked
about contract right uh
policy um that kind of thing am I would
I be correct in understanding that most
of the time in fact I mean I guess I
would say all of the time that I could
think of and maybe if you have other
examples you know that are different
please don't the doesn't that kind of a
right let's say in a collective
bargaining agreement for
example don't they usually say that the
right to be present or to sort of
understand applies in the situation
where the board is going to take some
action correct if they're gonna if the
board is going to have a discussion but
there they're not going to take any
action I'm I'm I guess I'm not aware of
any circumstance where you know where
you would have I mean unless we decide
to grant that but I'm not aware of any
circumstance right now where you would
have the right to know that correct
exactly which is why we think that
paragraph 2A of 91 A3 unless the
affected employee has a right to a
meeting and that right to a meeting I
mean the other the other conflict is
that the the right to no law uses the
phrase
meeting we have always interpreted that
to mean the individual doesn't
necessarily have a right to a meeting
they have a right to a hearing which is
different to some degree you know I have
a right to attend a public meeting and
if it's a Schoolboard meeting I have a
right to engage in public comment
through a statute a couple years ago but
I don't have any other specific right
granted upon me to other than attending
a meeting under RSA 91a and we often con
conf we often confuse the language in
RSA 9 1 A3 it's a non-public session it
is a session of a public meeting but yet
for purposes that I don't know why this
you know this language in 9183 the
non-public session statute a right to a
meeting that predates my time at the
school boards Association so I don't
know what the legislative conversation
was when this was initially drafted
however many however many years ago um
but so you know and and the other rights
in terms of the due process this is not
necessarily pertinent for this committee
but um employee right under Collective
bargain agreement or um RSC 1891 14a a
teacher non-renewal or a teacher
dismissal there is a Department of
Education rule ed2 it's in the ed2 200s
that lays out what the specific due
process requirements are notice right to
attend documents having have a
representative cross-examine the the
typical due process
rights all right other questions for
this witness seeing none Thank you very
thank you
Colin good afternoon my name is Sarah
bur Cohen I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association uh nhma opposes hb3 313 um
I'm not going to try to reiterate um
what Mr Christina just said um or the
previous testimony um the Supreme Court
decision the Supreme Court found that uh
it does uh it RSA uh 91a colon 3 Roman
numeral 2C does not require an
individual to give notice and a right to
attend um the non-public session in
which a discussion discussion May uh
occur that may ad adversely affect the
individual's
reputation um I think that they realize
and I think um it sounds like
representative Alexander also has
realized that there are some practical
practical implications of the change
that's proposed um how does it work does
business cease um I think there was a
question about what if there's people
that are intertwined um who gets if
someone wants to go to public session
and someone doesn't what does that look
like um there's a lot of questions I
think that are are open with uh HB 313
as it is um we think it's not practical
um and um would end up actually
adversely affecting maybe someone's in
reputation um and that's not what by
virtue of I by virtue of if it's
somebody else that ends up in an open
meeting that doesn't want to be there um
so nhma we oppose this bill but um we
would urge um a work session on it it
sounds like potentially maybe there
could be some work that's done that
makes it more
palatable I'm open to questions
questions for this um witness seeing
none thank you very much um is there
anyone else here who wishes to be heard
on HB
313 seeing none I'm going to uh close
the hearing on HB 313 and lo and behold
we are actually a little ahead of his
schedule so we have about 10 minutes
before we can start Mr chair can I um
now that the hearing's closed um I know
that we have an executive session on
this bill next Thursday would the chair
be inclined on pushing that out oh a
month so that we have some time to work
on this and vote on it maybe beginning
of March yeah no I'm yeah no that's I'd
be happy to to serve on a subcommittee
if there's any other members that wish
to serve with me no I and I'm just
wondering is are there are there other
people that would be interested in
serving on a subcommittee with repres B
you will get mileage if you come and
serve on the subcommittee with me oh
representative bur and representative
trip perfect thank you no that's great
all
right
so so I'm going to make I want to make a
note to myself right now uh
representative Alexander that I make
sure
oh
e
you hello everyone good
afternoon thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee again my name is Lisa
merer and I represent Hillsboro District
44 I think this will be a pretty quick
one for you so but we'll see so HPB 376
is a very simple bill that revises one
of the exemp exemptions in our right to
no law to include but not limit to
library cards and Library membership
status you see the term quote Library
users is already mentioned as being
Exempted Exempted in section 4 of 91a
colon 5 but apparently that term needs
further
clarification this exemption Amendment
came about because of a situation that
happened in our town almost a year ago
today during our Town's local election
the wife of our select board chair
decided to file a right to know with our
gtown Public Library asking if the six
candidates running for Library Board of
trustees held library cards the library
director consulted with our town lier
lawyer whoops
lawyer I I that was just I did not mean
that
sorry oh boy it's been a long day town
lawyer who in turn directed them to not
only answer the question of whether or
not the candidates held library card
but to release the actual library cards
via email to the person who filed the
right to know after that person who
filed the right to know received the
library cards from the library director
via email she proceeded to post the
cards all over social media the cards
originally included their Patron codes
and other personal
information apparently the lawyer did
not see the right to no exemption that
says records pertaining to library user
as referencing library
cards many in our community agreed that
this was an egregious invasion of
privacy and should never happen again
some not all of the library Board of
trustee members were very unhappy this
happened and said the law needed more
clarity so this is that people with
personal vendettas shouldn't be able to
weaponize private private library cards
and children's private
information I ask you to pass this small
but important bill revision so that this
won't happen again to
anyone and I will take questions
questions for yes representative
Perez were these individuals running for
Library trustee yes all of them were all
six yes were all running for Library
trustee yes is it part of their Charter
your library trustees that you must be a
um have a library card to run for that
no okay thank
you other questions for this witness so
you know I guess I have a I have a a
question you the um you said that the
library cards and
I'm I just I I I I don't live in your
town but I just want to see what my
library card says I
don't I mean the biggest thing on it is
has the patron code on
it so it's it's a code that
identifies that's very specific to the
the person and you can actually use that
information yes so you know I guess what
what I wanted to ask you is is this
um that's that's a I mean I completely
agree that's a huge concern of that but
is the
is
the is the mere fact that you have or do
not have a library card something that
you think should be protected um yes and
there is someone else uh who will
testify as to why there are other
reasons um that library cards and
membership status should not be a public
thing that can be released just because
someone asked for it and it does set a
horrible precedent even I mentioned it
briefly at the end in regards to
Children you know what's to stop this
just what's to stop this person from
digging even more into let's say there's
a family she didn't like and she wants
to air in for like where where does
where's the line drawn so um but there's
there's going to be someone else that's
testifying as to uh right and I guess I
mean I I guess what I'm but the only
thing I'm thinking is this if you put
aside the like the the you know the
information on the card number and stuff
that like the the code and all that I
mean I'm I'm just thinking I mean if I
wouldn't it be particularly the example
that was just given if somebody is
running for Library
trustee wouldn't it be a
legitimate political question for
somebody to say well you know wait
minute this person wants to be the
library trustee but person doesn't even
have a library card well that's the
thing though
I that's up for to you to decide but
they they took that One Step Beyond that
was the original question is if um you
know I personally don't care if people
know if I have one or not um others do
though and it
just it just the membership status
situation is again um there's there's
domestic violence situations where that
could be become a real issue if you have
someone start uh a person who abuses
women his wife walking trying to find
his wife and starts walking into towns
and oo this is the first place I'm going
to go and see if they have a library
card like there's there's there's it's
no one I don't see how it would be
anyone's business regardless of whether
you're running for office or not if you
have a library card that you could have
one elsewhere you could have one in
another town um so it it that that to me
and many others in our town like I I'm I
am currently on the library Board of
Trustees now so um and we they were many
of them were not happy that that
happened so but to go back the original
question from the person that asked the
in the right to know that she requested
asked if the people running had Library
carts okay but it then all of a sudden
it became a hey not only do they have
library cards here they are how did it
go from asking the question if to and
here's all their library cards it just
it m it made no sense um and then yeah
there's and the person that did that
there's just a a lot of things like this
that happened on a regular basis and
just to stop as I mentioned the
weaponization of private information um
that that's going to prevent people from
running for stuff in the future if they
know that their privacy is going to be
infringed on um and and they're going to
you know use it to go after people I
would never vote for someone whether or
not they had a library card or not um
you know to me I want to know why
they're running and what they're running
for and that's what I vote for so um and
I don't know that if I if that person
has a library card some else good for
them it's none of my business so yes yes
representative petno thank you very much
this really isn't specific to the
library card per se but libraries are
free correct yes so it would in a
situation where somebody is running for
Library trustee in particular you might
go to the library every day but not have
a library card because you might sit and
read the magazine the periodic people do
that so yeah you could be a regular
Patron so the fact in the particular
situation where you're running for a
library trustee it might not matter
would would you agree with that might
not matter it might not matter that you
have a library card like that you're a
regular patron of the library even
exactly representative Bon and then
representative
alexand thank you chair Mr
chair my kids got a library card when
they could write and at this point they
can probably still use that card but um
let's say they were under 18 would I
have to sort of take because I always to
sort of not took control they had them
all but at one point in time are kids
identities are you suggesting that all
of that be not available to the public I
don't think someone should be able to
like let's say uh you know my sister who
has children that someone could say I I
want to see all the library cards of of
that person's children they're not my
you know that why why would you want to
do that number one um but this sets the
precedent that they could I mean the
current apparently the current law but
keep in mind the current law does make a
reference to records pertaining to
library user
so why would why would Library their
cards which is part of I would think a
person's Library
record why would that not be part of the
exemption so but
apparently that's why I did this is to
bring Clarity to the law because I was
told that the term Library user was not
good
enough followup yes please I just I just
wanted to ask about I'm not going to ask
you things about restrictions how long
does a card I just wanted to know if my
kids cards are still good but no but um
I guess if this point in
time
um I don't know I'm just trying to
protect them as well I don't know if
there's any protecting protection
measures for under 18 under 16 I don't
know what no that's all that you see in
that law and I have it you know right
here there's no age limits on anything
in the current law it just says you know
um and and these records are Exempted
from right to know record pertaining to
library user that's all it says right
now now there is an R RSA 2011 Deco in
11 which um which references
Library users and records as well and I
have a separate bill on
that um just to kind of lock this up so
that um you know people's privacy I'm
just a huge proponent of privacy and
this to me just went took it to a level
that I and many others couldn't actually
believe that person went to that
level other question representative
trip uh thank you for uh taking my
question
uh since they were since the person that
made the 91a
request uh simply ask do they have cards
M you know so uh do you know who gave
the cards numbers to that person well
when when the library cards were emailed
to the person who filed the right to
know originally like the the numbers do
you mean Patron codes they're right
there on the cards so so they were the
actual like pictures of their cards oh
were emailed so you know the uh the the
thing that I find uh uh annoying is that
uh were the
uh back in 911 they they started
researching people's Library uh history
to see if they were terrorist you know
do do you think that anything like that
happened now there are other exceptions
so so you can ask let's say that person
is under investigation for something or
a subpoena is filed that information can
be released so that fall
um you know outside of this exe this
particular section of the exemption so
there are situations where you can if
someone like I said is is under
investigation by the law or whatever if
they have a subpoena they can they can
they can access that information so
there are you know but this wasn't
that we weren't under investigation for
anything so oh you were one of the
people that had the card
emailed to the requester well I was one
of the people that didn't have a card oh
so yeah isn't that yeah and I I don't it
didn't bother me at all because I used
to have a card I let it go during a
certain period of
time you know but and that doesn't
bother me at all but it Bo but it
bothers a lot of other people it it's
when this happened um you know there are
a certain
uh Community there's a community in our
town that was really bothered by this
overreach of um privacy Invasion um and
number one no no library card releasing
and number two it's none of your
business if I have a library card or not
but I owned I owned that fact proudly
but many others don't and don't want to
so that's up to that person though that
is information and a status that belongs
to that person and it's there's no other
there's no good reason why it doesn't
matter if you're running for library or
not um and I still got elected so yeah
so it didn't obviously it didn't matter
to many people
yeah other question representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair thank you
so much um to my State Rep for taking my
question um I am wondering based on the
interpretation of how the Gown Library
interpreted um RSA 9185 specifically
Library user could I take a list of all
people in gtown that registered to vote
and voted in November 5th and then
request a 91a on their library cards see
how many people that voted in November
5th have a library card 100% thank you
that's a thank you very helpful there's
no limits to what can be done with this
right now so and that's what this is now
is just there are some things that um
and you know you can see it's probably
10 10 words that I added to the
amendment just to make it just to
clarify that Library user includes your
library card and whether or not you have
one other questions yeah yes
representative Perez and then
representative
hgan if I'm running for Budget Committee
in your town do they check and see if um
I have a bank
account I mean what what was the
rationale behind doing that just to be
nasty do is that how you feel it was and
you got elected even though you were one
who did not have a card it's interesting
because this just came up at our library
trustees that they wanted to know which
one of the trustees had a library card
and one of the trustees said that's
nobody's business so yep agre
representative Horgan um this
probably would um would a uh town be
able to make a rule that uh Library
trustee candidates as a qualification
had to be library card holders and or
make make a rule that they get a library
card if they don't already have one
because I is that was
that yeah yeah that would not be
disallowed by the current law or this
law you thinking yeah yeah yeah so I I
guess other questions so I guess I'm I
mean I just to sort of carry this
through and I I I mean I'm I am
sympathetic to the bill in the way the
issues you rais but I just to follow up
on this so if I mean if if I'm running
for Library trustee and you know I have
an
opponent do you think that it would not
be an appropriate question at a forum
for example for a voter to say hey Lynn
you're running for Library trustee do
you have a do you have a library card at
your at the library you're running for
trust VI sure they could do that but
then it's then it's up to them to answer
that question someone's not going to
answer that for I don't want anyone I I
understand but I guess the point is that
what my point would be that it is
relevant it is a relevant question if
I'm running for Library trustee whether
I have a library C it's not the end of
the issue it may not be that doesn't
mean if I don't have one I this specific
to write to no request this isn't just
I'm attending a candidates night and
someone's asking me that question this
is specific to the right to know law
that you know so someone submits a right
to know um and and you can see though
even though they asked for membership
status it they took it well beyond that
right so that's why we're we're pushing
the line further back to no actually
none of this is anyone's business um and
if they want to ask them that private
question or a public question in a
different Arena that's up to them and
it's up to that candidate whether they
want to answer that or not it shouldn't
no one should be making that decision
for them all right other questions for
this witness thank whoops representative
P do you have any written testimony for
the committee um I can email this what I
have here to you that would be wonderful
thank you the clerk would appreciate
that you better believe I can do that
thank you very much representative
you're welcome right thank you thank you
do have more question thank you all
right
um I I hope I'm Barbara Schult is it
Barbara or
you can you turn on your mic please yeah
oh yeah thank you T it yeah there you go
okay thank you I'm Barbara Schult and
I'm a voter in town in Goth toown um and
the library is very important to me I'm
not super comfortable um doing this kind
of thing um I did have written testimony
but um some of the things that were
already discussed um I'm going to jump
around and address it um I first want to
tell you that I'm not a lawyer and I
have no legal background um I did read a
lot of the documentation around the
events most of this is posted online um
and not online like on Facebook but on
the town website and the libraries
website um the events surrounding the
things that were discussed um and in
that um you will see a legal opinion
that very much explains some of the
questions that were coming up um in my
written testimony here I have there will
likely be discussion here about the
actual card being revealed um the
attorney in his response to the
library's request for legal counsel on
the the 91a request said that the it
cannot be a yes or no question the the
the library is not able to say yes this
person has a card or no this person
doesn't have a card they can only the
the uh 91a is only for actual government
records and the actual government record
is the card okay so I hopefully that
will clear up some of the questions that
came up and again this was one lawyer's
opinion and I'm not a lawyer but I um
encourage you to um read the full
communication that is posted it's a
March 12th
2024 press release um from the town of
gtown it's posted on the town website as
um uh so hopefully that clears that up I
am not clear on what I heard about um
being able to access any information
with a picture of my card um my card the
front of it just has the golf town
library logo the back of it yes it has a
number on it but um I have a pin that
goes with that so so I don't know how
any information could be accessed um
with just that code that was revealed um
I don't agree with whoever posted it on
Facebook I I don't agree with that at
all but um the library did comply with
the law and sought legal counsel for
that
um and hopefully I'm I'm not taking up
too much time but the purpose of the
right to know is to provide transparency
to the public about government agencies
and their work and the library public
libraries are kind of unique in that
they're run by a Board of Trustees
they're not run by um you know the town
so they elect um trustees and as a voter
yes that's very pertinent information to
me uh whether or not the the um person
the candidate has a library card or not
and it really should be a very simple
thing that someone uh just mentioned
like can't we just ask the candidate
well yes we can try that um but I do
want you to know that um four of the
sponsors all of the sponsors on this
bill are go from gtown and only from
gtown and I would hope that would
perhaps flag some caution on your behalf
and perhaps um do some deeper
investigation four of the sponsors of
this Bill had Direct um interactions
over the past year year and a half with
the library specifically including
requesting the resignation of the board
chair um openly and publicly stating
that the library had broken the law when
it had not and most recently um two of
the sponsors sued the library um and
that brings me to the point of asking
the question the Ros Berry and Keith
Murphy sued the gtown public library
because the library was providing a
public service that they have done
multiple times in printing a candidate
brochure the they throw out questions to
the candidates the candidates respond
they are printed oned Mr chair I'm
unsure how this testimony has to relate
to this specific bill um I can get to
that because the um the people decided
not to answer the questions they just
didn't answer the questions so going
back to shouldn't it be a simple matter
of does the trustee candidate have a
library card um they if they choose not
to answer the question there should be a
way for um the public to have that
information that I think is very
pertinent um in addition you know the
library is a public building as it was
uh addressed and and mentioned and
anybody could sit in the library and
yeah you know you might see someone
reading magazines and don't know whether
they have a card or not but um you will
see people check out at the circulation
desk and hand their card and then a
person can just sit there and keep track
of who has a card um so the the library
card itself is not a privacy issue
because you're in a public library and
it's very
public so having the card is not the
issue releasing information connected to
the card how you use the card the
materials you borrow yeah that's a whole
different matter but that was not
revealed um and so I I just caution you
that asking for an exemption under this
right to no law is is a huge ask and I I
hope that you will weigh it very
carefully and consider all the perhaps
unintended consequences that may fall
from that as well as you know a legal
thing saying that you are denying uh
government records um I'm a fierce
advocate of privacy
but I don't feel this uh releasing
whether someone has a card or not is um
a matter of privacy um it will open up
subsequent legal questions and I guess
lastly I I I and getting to how this
relates you know I find it troubling
that Lisa Meer in her candidacy for
Library trustee in our town emphasized
the need to being transparent bringing
transparency to the library and Mr Barry
I'm not I I really am not clear on how
you know s getting into the details of a
particular thing is is relevant here
okay okay I apologize um I just feel
that um they have um pursued Freedom of
Information requests feeling that there
a lot of that information is public
including who submitted the questions on
the candidate brochure but yet they're
sponsoring a bill that is trying to
limit transparency by um not allowing
people to know who has a Liber card um
and lastly I I think since Joe was
direct involved in much of the above I
think he should recuse himself from the
discussion of the vote on this bill for
the committee all right um any questions
for this yes representative alexand
thank you um chairman Lynn and thank you
for taking my question um my question is
regarding if you believe that the
library card of victims of domestic
violence such as myself should be
disclosed to the public and if that is a
safety concern is yes or
no I'm not clear on the connection as to
knowing whether you have a library card
how that could possibly connect to
domestic violence and forgive me if
I'm if I'm not going there and I don't
understand the connection thank you
other questions for this witness yes
representative Perez are you aware that
this is just a
clarification of an existing law the law
says I don't know the exact words but
the law basically says say that you
can't disclose Library users it's
clarification which is something that we
frequently do we had several bills this
morning for clarification on Citizen and
different things are you aware that
there is already a law that says this
basically should not have been done and
this is a clarification of it well I I
don't know if it's clear that it
shouldn't have been done because and
again I'm not a lawyer so I think the
committee needs that legal opinion the
actual card is a government record and
under the Freedom of Information that's
available to the public so I'm not a
lawyer I just read the legal
opinion other questions seeing none
thank you very much um next uh uh Henry
uh
cool thank you Mr chair honorable
Representatives uh for record I'm
representative Henry gason gtown
Hillsboro 29th District uh I want to
approach this from a Safety and Security
standpoint um so I recognize that the
law was applied the way the law was
interpreted and I'm not refuting
anything that has already happened I
think that the importance of this law um
which has been touched on Once by
representative Alexander once by
representative Maser is that this is the
only government agency that I know of
where I can do a right to request and I
can figure out exactly where you are I
can't walk up to the DMV and request
your driver's license I can't go to the
schools and request the names of the
children going to those schools but I
can go to the library and I can find out
whether or not you're a registered
member of that Library locally now in a
domestic violence circumstance where
partner possibly with children has
relocated and does not want to be found
by the offender an offender
could um WR to know find out whether or
not that family is registered in the
library possibly find out whether or not
the kids are involved in any programs in
that Library this is the only place
where I know other than that voting you
know voting registration is public
record but this is the only place that I
know where I can do a right to know and
I can find out exactly where a victim is
where somebody trying to find a victim
and that concerns me I believe that
people have an inherent right to
privacy and and I believe that it's the
government's job to protect the rights
of the people so from that perspective I
think that we I I I would hope that this
body would move to uh OTP this on the
grounds of protecting the citizens from
aant right to no requests
any questions I'll conclude thank you
sir uh questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Coco thank you Mr chair uh right to know
New Hampshire supports this bill um I
will say that we met as an organization
we were hard pressed to find a single
example where personally identifiable
information was of this kind was of
interest and we feel that the bill um
does is a clarifying Bill IT addresses
something that we believed was already
the case um I will also add that I took
a quick look I'm a book nerd so um I
jumped on the American Library
Association website I would encourage
committee members to go ahead and look
at their stance on privacy and libraries
um it's quite powerful and I would also
state that from a right to know
perspective I find it very interesting
that uh and I'm hearing about this for
the first time here so if I have this
incorrect I apologize but it sounds like
somebody issued a set of questions and
rather than the typical response from a
community which is under 91a we are not
required to respond to
questions somebody chose to go ahead
pull records and furnish those that is
unusual in my experience typically they
will come back and say we can't answer a
question you have to ask for a specific
docum it does not sound like that
happened in this case it sounds like
this was clearly motivated by something
else and I find that very interesting
it's unusual thank
you hang on questions for this witness
anybody have questions right thank no
questions sorry nobody does thank you
very much right um is there anyone else
uh who wishes to uh testify on House
Bill
376 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 376 and the
committee will be very happy to know we
are on to the last bill that we have
assigned for uh hearing
today which
is
um House Bill uh
uh ah
okay wa minute yeah did you
representative did you fill out a card
can I ask you to do that if you didn't
mind please do it now or
after
yeah yeah yeah no you you know what as
long as you just take a card and fill it
out after you can testify first but just
afterwards good to go good afternoon yes
you're good to go thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is Mike
Drago I represent the town of Raymond
and I am going to introduce HB 273 which
gives parents access to their child's
Library records um right off the bat if
this bill is passed it gives two real
world implications um makes it easier
for parents and I think for libraries in
general one issue I actually ran into
probably 14 months ago um I requested
while my daughter was reading um a
chapter book series on horses
and uh the next book series was the next
book in the series was out so I had
requested that book for her and at the
same time I was reading a World War II
book um basically the author int um
interviewed many different veterans
about their experience um during combat
and they put it all into one book so I I
requested that book at the same time
couple weeks went by and uh our library
and email me saying one of your two
books you requested is in I said oh
great which book is it I was excited to
start reading my book
and uh and she said well I can't tell
you that's it's against the
law I didn't realize that I had
accidentally requested both books under
my daughter's library card and because
it was under her card I had no access to
what books were requested she couldn't
tell
me I thought that was kind of odd but
under current law that is how it how the
law is written and um and so then on top
of that I started thinking
well our library charges late charges
for any book that's overdue if my
daughter happens to turn in a library
card late I mean I library book late she
has no source of income I'm the one
responsible for paying for it how does
it make sense that I am paying for a
book that I have no access to I can't be
told anything about what I am
responsible for and if you take it a
step
further if that book accidentally gets
lost I have to either find it or I have
to buy it again I'm buying a book that I
can't know anything about or two I'm
trying to find a book that I have no
idea what I'm looking for because I
can't be told what to
find I'm on a wild goose chase in my
house trying to find a
book so those are two real world
implications um but we can also talk
about the elephant in the room and that
is uh the explicit material that's
contained in books and those books are
becoming more and more prevalent in our
libraries and uh and
so I approached this subject with our
librarian and uh
the issue is well let's go with this we
all remember we're all the age where we
remember uh movie rental stores the
Blockbusters Etc and I remember my local
one when I walk in the door to the left
where the G movies the PG movies were to
the right out by the counter with the R
movies and behind the screen out back
those were the X-ray
movies we all knew the separation
between them and you know you went to
the appropriate area books don't have a
rating system so they're just
interspersed all through the library and
why this is important is because the
American Library Association gives a lot
of I would say governance or allows
libraries to follow certain rules and
one of the thing they put out was What's
called the library Bill of Rights and
part of the Bill of Rights says any
person of any age should be able to read
any
book so any person any age any book in
New Hampshire children at the age of six
get library cards sometimes at the age
of
five going by the Bill of Rights that I
would say most if not all libraries
follow gives any person in the library
the ability to look at any book and now
we know the types of books that are
being bought for our our libraries and
so I approached this with our librarian
and I brought up the book gender queer
which is kind of become famous over the
past few years and and I and I
said our job if this is going to be in
the library is to protect kids uh and
not every kid should be exposed to the
material that's in these books and this
one specifically and her response for
the most part was if a child looks at
this book and they want it I I think I'm
protecting them by giving it to
them and so I fundamentally disagree
with that I think it's up to the parents
to decide if the book is right for a
child and by giving them access to see
what the child is reading it gives them
one more tool to you know make sure that
they are seeing what they deem is
appropriate and uh you know some of the
people that
would argue against this bill will say
well it's the responsibility of the
parent to pay attention to their child
at all times and I I don't
disagree I I try as hard as I can to
always know what my kids are doing try
to take care of them the right way but I
do have five kids so when we go to the
library one kid might be downstairs in
the children's section one might be
upstairs trying to get a movie so at any
time they could technically take out a
book and I won't know anything about it
and and if I ask I can't be told
and on top of that my library and I
think probably most libraries have after
school programs which I think are great
you know they have a chess club or they
have um uh teen tween book club or um
Dungeons and Dragons well these clubs
are me you know they have a chaperon who
runs the club or maybe it's one of the
Librarians but they're meant for
peer-to-peer
interaction and the parent you know the
kids might bike there after school or
the kids will just drop them off I mean
the parents will drop them off they're
not meant for parents to be there there
it's for them to be with their friends
and enjoy the club so there's plenty of
times in libraries when kids are not
with their parents and at the end of the
day it's up to the parents to know or be
able to understand what the kids are
reading and what they're taking out of
the library and uh and this bill gives
them that ability right thank you
questions for this witness
representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question are you aware that there are
age restrictions you said on movies
games also have age restrictions games
that you can play and buy in dungeons
all those games there are also age
restrictions uh TV has age restrictions
on it and magazines have age
restrictions on them are you aware that
all those have age restrictions yet we
do not have them on books in the library
yes I am and I don't know why we don't
have them for books and libraries um I
also don't know if that would be a state
or a federal thing but yes I often
wonder that followup followup yes are
you aware that the New Hampshire State
library has withdrawn from the American
Library Association because of some of
their
unique I don't know the word I want to
say things that have gone on with them
are you aware that the America the State
library has withdrawn their membership
with then yeah thank you for the
question I am well aware uh the American
Library Association for for lack of
better words is a political action
committee funded by your taxpayer
dollars uh so last year myself and
representative who's actually sitting in
the audience met with um the direct the
commissioner over the libraries and we
addressed our concerns and yes the state
is now not part of the American Library
Association and many towns are no longer
part of it as
well that I can't answer uh it's very
hard on their website to find out who
and who isn't a part of the Ala I would
hope by seeing the State Library cut
ties towns would follow suit but that's
up to the individual Library trustee
boards and individual Librarians and
it's tough to tell what each one does
one more quick question please
sure wasn't this partially specific
partially and
specifically done for the protection of
children
I'm sorry what what wasn't what done um
approaching the American libraries uh
the state about the American Library
wasn't that one of your issues with oh
yeah so as I started looking into this I
mean I've had issues with them for quite
some time but as I started looking into
this preparing for the meeting last year
um the American Library Association has
a bunch of um subgroups I kind of call
them shell companies and one of them is
every Library uh which actually one of
the director the board of director
actually used to be on the American
Library Association board and basically
their purpose is to further um the will
of the American Library Association so
as I started looking at that group last
year I forget the bill number but it was
one representative cordelli read excerpt
from the book on the house floor uh they
opposed that bill so yes this is a way
trying to get the Ala out of the state
was a way to protect kids because they
were actively arguing against bills that
um that I would say would protect kids
by not exposing to this material all
right yes representative
Rambo thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I see the
proposed language um says that these
records would be available to the parent
or legal guardian when requested by the
parent legal garden whose address
matches that on the Minor's library
account um does this take into account
um if there's a disagreement between
parents if there's a non-custodial
parent um if there are circumstances
between um legal circumstances that
would prevent one parent from making
that decision over another parent The
Way It Was Written like that is because
of um problems in the past where
actually kind of like the last bill if
there's um violence in the family so
it's it's the parent that has the same
address the one's living with to make
sure that maybe it's not stranged spouse
or something that uh is trying to catch
up on their kids but have follow
um to the extent there's concern about
safety or security of children in a
circumstances like that which we touched
on in the prior hearing um expressing
our Our concern for physical safety
right for for folks with a library card
or Library Patron and our prioritizing
of privacy um you know many libraries
allow children to be dropped off like
you said for um after school activities
seem like that um where they're not
checking out books right that they may
not be taking them out on an account
um how does
that square with this proposal in terms
of um Librarians being expected
to share with parents the materials that
their children are consuming at the
library or monitoring their children
it's not the stuff that they're doing
while they're in there it's the books
that they're taking out what okay
checking out versus reading while in the
library yeah there's no way a librarian
could be the police of every that's in
the library it's the ones that they are
actively taking out and taking home with
them okay thank you for other question
representative
orgon yes thank you so well as we
pointed out most libraries have Open
Stacks so anyone including a child can
basically read anything that's in the
collection um unless it's in a special
part of the collection so I don't know I
guess my first question is you're not
favoring like uh eliminating having Open
Stacks at public libraries so
because you're obviously very concerned
about especially probably presumably
adolescence reading material that you
think you should you think on issues
that you don't want them to be reading
about so that so you you're not you're
not asking us to uh ban Open Stacks in
public libraries oh no that's this bill
has nothing to do with that it just
simply says that if the parent whose
address matches the child's uh requests
to see what books the child has taken
out
they're allowed to see that like just
follow yeah a related issue of common
practice in many libraries U is to make
at least some of the books they're in
the building available for people
including young people to take home for
for free there sometimes it's just books
have been cold from the collection but
sometimes it's also books on topics that
they
feel users especially even um even like
uh minor users might want to read about
this stuff but for whatever reason they
might be be reluctant to uh go up to the
uh go up to the library counter and be
recorded as checking it out so you think
should they should libraries be able to
continue those two practices of giving
away or selling cold books and um also
making certain materials available for
free without need to check them
out are they giving away for free I
don't mean ask a question but are they
giving them away for free and not
intending to get them back like free
like take them home and don't bring them
back I
think I think it's on the I think some
some of these materials are on the honor
System so they they feel um you know
probably these are not the more
expensive materials that are being put
out there but um and of
course what's the question again oh I
was just uh responding to the question
so like but um I was because I think he
so that I was just uh not sure if he his
understanding I understand the issue and
perhaps I didn't phase the issue very
clearly but um so so do you think we
should restrict libraries from allowing
miners to take anything home for free
even from those type of uh shelves that
don't actually have to be checked out
although they probably most case bring
back Andor like allowing children to
participate in you know taking home cold
books for free or buying books at at a
library book book sale which so you
think we should restrict that or not
well that really has nothing to do with
this bill but I will say if a library is
allowing people to take out books uh
without any sort of record I don't think
that's a good use of taxpayer dollars
because there's no guarantee you're
going to get back and taxpayer dollars
bought those books so there should be
some way of making sure those books come
back all right other questions for this
word yes representative
beron thank you Mr chair I know that uh
we just made we just made some changes
to things like libraries but we realize
that kids sometimes don't want their
families to know what they're reading
simply because you know like for example
you know students
that so if they if they express
different information when they're at
school we decided you know we're not
going to tell parents if it's a serious
issue like that like if they don't want
to know that if they if they don't want
to know their they don't want their
parents to know that type of thing so
I'm just wondering how that goes with
this law right here you know with
parents can just go and I guess not that
you know everything about it but that's
just my one concern for this is simply
that if the parents still go and check
out the books that their kids are having
but um I know that's a different story
but also we just went in the right
direction and just said can I is is
there I'm sorry is there a
question what yeah I asked my question
already I'm just trying to explain what
theater and what it looks like when I
would go there
they might want privacy when they go to
the airport from their I mean to the um
Library when they discuss it with their
parents so I still don't know what the
question is yeah no I I right I
representative I I guess we really
generally asked qu I mean that you made
a statement and your statement may be
you know I understand your concern but
no I yeah okay all right other questions
representative Rambo thank you Mr sh I
do have one more question um thank you
for taking my question if I understand
correctly um under RSA 2011- d11 apply
School libraries and public libraries
right this all falls under the same
umbrella correct okay um are there any
are you aware of any um conflicts that
we create with other school privacy
uh statutory rights for students in
schools versus the town
library I I don't there might be
somebody else expert in that area that
might be able to answer that okay that's
right thank you other question
representative trip uh I don't know did
you ask about the school
libraries I my quick research was
suggesting that this would apply to both
School libraries and public libraries
all right thank you but I'm seeing some
head shaking so that that that maybe up
for clarification no but uh uh would
would you be open to amendment that uh
would include School libraries in your
bill I think the intent of the bill is
for
both
so it yeah it's it's libraries and
general so the answer is yes yes okay
thank you all right other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much thank you next I'm going to call on
representative uh Katherine Harvey
please
thank you Mr chair uh good afternoon
committee um my name is representative
Katherine Harvey I'm from chesher 6 and
that means I represent Hinsdale uh
Chesterfield and West Morland um I'm
also the vice chair of uh New Hampshire
library trustees Association and I chair
its education committee um I'm here
today to speak on behalf of NHL TA in
opposition to bill um House Bill
273 we see that there's two problems
with this bill and you've touched on one
of them uh briefly and that is the the
wording that the address matches that of
the minor um that's problematic because
the person who is making that request is
going to have to somehow prove to that
uh circulation desk that they actually
live at the address that they say they
live at my driver's license does not
have my address on it because I get my
mail at a post office box um the um you
could not make a request over the phone
because the the address has to be
verified in some way if the address of
the person can be verified and that's
going to have to be decided how it can
be be verified there's there's no way
that you know that uh the children live
at that same address today's children
live with aunts they live with
grandparents they live in foster homes
they live with boyfriends they're even
homeless so it's not safe and it's not
reasonable to assume that all of today's
children live at the same address as
whatever that parent or legal guardian
is um presenting to the circulation desk
and there is no way that the staff at
that circulation desk can ascertain um
whether that information is true or not
uh the second problem with this bill is
that most of our small rural libraries
are not automated so when you check out
a book They're checked out the
oldfashioned way you probably remember
the the cards and the date stamps and
and then the cards are uh filed by the
date that the book is due
not by the person who took out the book
so if I want to request what book
someone has out a staff person is
manually going to have to go through
three to four uh weeks worth of cards as
um as well as the overdue cards to see
what books that person has taken out and
then they're they're going to have to
cross reference that number with the
address to see if it is indeed the
person that's standing in front of their
circulation desk now if a library is
automated um that process might be a
little quicker but again you don't check
books out by your name um this is my
library card it's it just has a barcode
on it so again somebody would have to
cross reference my barcode to see if it
matches the address that I'm Pres
presenting at the circulation desk
um if that can all be AC
accomplished in all of New England
libraries except for Mont um and um
history of the books that you've taken
out are
deleted when the book comes back in
Vermont deletes history after age 12 so
if if you go to the computer the only
books that it's going to show that are
out of the library are the ones that are
actually out of the library right then
it's not going to show you the history
of the usage of that person um so if you
pass this bill there are significant
costs that are going to be downshifted
to the local library and the local taxes
first if your library is not automated
then your you're going to be paying for
man hours of somebody going through
those boxes of Date cards to see who has
taken out what books um and that and
that's that's expensive um if your
library is automated you're going to
have to upgrade your systems if you can
um some of our libraries are automated
but we're automated with Antiquated
computer systems and you may not be able
to upgrade them you may have to just
purchase new computers um you're going
to have to write new policies about how
U this information is going to be shared
policies are usually um given a once
over by an attorney just to make sure
that they uh pass muster so you're going
to be paying for that as well um and the
possibility of all of this happening
within 60 days after the passage of this
bill if it should pass is is really
quite slim
um so in addition to the address the
cost and the the time that it just
cannot be done in 60 days I would ask
you to ital this bill um I would if I
could um address just one issue and I I
understand I'm talking from my personal
library but um the idea was brought up
that you might be paying for a book that
you don't know um uh that your child has
taken out
libraries issue cards to children but
those cards are linked to an adult card
up until a certain age and the reason
they're linked is just for that reason
if a 5-year-old loses a book then um it
would be up to the adult whose card is
linked to his um to be able to pay for
that book most libraries have a policy
that states something something like
that and they decide what age cards are
not going to be linked to adult cards
any
longer any questions thank you questions
for this witness uh representative Pon I
don't know I'm sorry I don't know
apologize thank you chair Lyon thank you
for taking my question um what is the
maximum age that a card would be linked
to a parents that a Minor's library card
would be linked to a parents library
card that's a policy that each and every
Library um writes separately and um with
their Board of Trustees the Board of
Trustees major job is to write policy
and that that would be their decision to
make so I don't know that there there is
no um uh
age appropriate by there's no state
level age is what I'm trying to say it's
an individual libraries
decision followup sure thank thank you
um who informs the policy of each of
these libraries or are they creating
policy of their own
accord I I'm not sure I totally
understand the question but once uh
Library trustees um write a policy and
NHL ta has a list of uh recommended
policies that every Library should have
but once a library writes a policy it is
um post if if they have a website it's
posted on their website for anyone to
see it if they don't there is certainly
a policy manual in every library that
you can see these policy manuals are
passed out I was a trustee chair and I
uh made sure that all of my um uh
members of the trustees got a manual as
well as the friends and and so
forth is that the question yeah sure go
ahead thank you uh if we have a state
Library
Association what is their job do they
inform the libraries and the
municipalities of how to create their
policy or like like for so for example
the School Board
Association informs policy for the
school boards is there an organization
like that that informs the policy of the
library the individual libraries so I'm
here representing New Hampshire library
trustees Association um and the the um
that
Association um H does not have
um a definite jurisdiction over local
libraries but we pre we prevent we
present all kinds of we have a a a
manual of things that Librarians and
trustees should know concerning like
duties and that kind of thing we also
are an education organization so we
present uh workshops our conferences
coming up May 5th
we uh have Regional workshops that local
trustees can attend to ask questions and
to um meet with other trustees but we we
don't go into a library and say this is
how you write your policy we would we do
have a list of recommended policies
suggest like circulation policy um
overdue policies that kind of thing and
I think the so I I assume the question I
I think what she was getting at is do
you among those rep recommended policies
is there one that says this is the up to
this age um parents should know no that
that the it the recommendation is simply
you should have this policy but it is up
to every individual library to set that
because nlta doesn't know your community
okay all right representative Manion
thank you Mr chair thank you for take my
question you mentioned parents are
linked cards are linked depending on
what age it's 5 6 78 the library
determines that um so if they notify the
parent that the book is missing and
that's why the card is linked do they
notify the parent what the book is yes
okay thank you other questions yes
representative
Burch thank you Mr chair thank you
representative uh leaving out the the
Practical implementation problems that
you've talked about in this leg
legislation um would it be fair to say
that your organization
believes that the purpose of libraries
is to encourage people to
read well of course it's the purpose of
um any library to encourage people to
read thank you um yes all right any
other qu yes representative
Oregon president Harvey would it be fair
to attach one of our favorite lab to
this bill based on the comments you made
about the expense of complying with it
which is unfunded mandate oh the cost is
definitely an unfound founded mandate
the the hours of of searching when you
when you take out a book by a barcode or
by a date stamp the hours of cross
referencing is is just astronomical um
not to mention if equipment has to be
upgraded and so forth yes and and to do
it in 60 days is other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
please and you know uh we have a number
of other Witnesses and given the hour
I'm going to ask if you would please Mr
fre try to limit your testimony to three
minutes if you would please thank you uh
yeah um Mr chairman committee members uh
Aubrey freeden and I live in Bridgewater
I speak in support of this bill um I
didn't even realize that how this was
kind of secretive that uh somebody's
young as five could get a card and the
parents are don't even have access to
that that to me is um
ridiculous and it's your job as a parent
to kind of know I mean when they're
older it's a little different you can
kind of let go but certainly when
they're young you kind of want to know
what information they're accessing I
mean this is a busy world there's tons
of stuff out there there's bad stuff and
as a parent that's your job to hate to
say but you're kind of a dictator of
your kids while they're young and so you
should be able to access uh what books
they're reading or maybe they've lost or
whatever you should have Total Access
and for Library Personnel to kind of
hide this from parents or well we can't
you know like you're a doctor like it's
a confidentiality with your psychiatrist
this is ridiculous we're talking kids
here so I totally support this um and
also the only thing I would say uh maybe
could be a little better in this bill is
there are no teeth in this um this is
one of the library Personnel they don't
really agree with that and they say the
car like you say somebody or you know
kids should let them learn whatever they
we want them to read we should not uh
hamstring them at all and so I'm kind of
going to ignore that and what if they do
uh just disregard the uh law so there
should be a penalty it doesn't have to
be a huge one but bills that don't have
penalties on government officials and
employees uh they're often ignored so I
think there should be a little penalty
in here if they disregard the law and
that would be my only uh suggestion for
an an amendment otherwise I agree with
it all right thank you thank you sir
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
urel thank you chair thank you members
of the committee my name is Chris sechel
and I'm an attorney with glbtq legal
Advocates and Defenders um I'm a New
Hampshire licensed attorney but I work
at a Boston um I'm going to focus in on
an narrow issue which is the reasonable
expectation of privacy that even young
people have when it comes to sexual
orientation and gender
identity um young people look to books
to uh to help with the process of
self-discovery looking to see
representations of people who have gone
through similar experiences as them who
who uh move through the world in similar
ways as them and for lgbtq young people
it can be incredibly important to have
access to novels non-fiction books that
uh reflect who they are as they're ident
as they're um coming to understand how
they identify um it can be extremely
harmful to take away from a young person
the right to decide when and how they
tell their parents about their sexual
orientation or their gender identity um
young people can be subject to Great
harm if they are not in control of that
process um and there are plenty of
examples of horrible things befalling
young people who's who had that um
Choice taken away from them um I want to
call attention to a story from the late
1990s in Pennsylvania in a small town
where uh two young men were were caught
by a police officer in a car at
night um the two young men were you know
out at night in a way that they
shouldn't have been or um and the police
officer had every right to stop them
tell them to go home and he did but
before he did he took them to the police
station and he threatened them and he
told them I'm going to talk to your
families uh that night one of the young
men Marcus Wayman took his life Mr chair
I'm I'm confused at how that story is
relevant
to the test testimony on Library
information so I I just point of
clarification I I hope that the witness
will stay to the the matter the matter
of the
bill go you may continue but I just say
I I had indicated three minutes and
you're getting you're you've got about
45 seconds left so okay so um to answer
the question the government disclosure
of private information uh is at issue in
the um in the events I was just
describing and it's at issue we talk
about uh public or School libraries
disclosing information to parents about
what books have been read by students uh
in both examples we're talking about
information that might be very personal
very private to a young person you know
say a 16-year-old and that information
uh when it's disclosed can result in
great harm and courts have found that
there's a reasonable expectation of
privacy even for um for minors when it
comes to information about sexual
orientation and gender identity right
any questions for this witness seeing
none thank you very much sir thank you
please good afternoon I'll try to make
this quick too I'm going to cut out some
of what I was going to say so I'm a
parental rights Advocate focused on
excellence and education in New
Hampshire um anytime a parent can stand
in the way of exploiting children that's
a good thing I'm so I do support this
uh I can access a book called explosives
and homemade bombs written by Joseph
staffle the book offers this the student
of police and fire science a guide to
such devices a book like this for
professionals may be necessary a book
like this in the hands of a deranged
student could be harmful or even deadly
these books are on how to there are
books on how to make fentanyl or other
harmful content I'm going to assume you
would want a parent to access their
child's Library records if they suspect
their child is reading these books if a
book like this is in the hands of a
deranged child this could be deadly what
if a child is suicidal wouldn't you want
to know if your child is accessing books
that show them how to kill themselves
this could be an indicator that their
child is in need of help uh in the in
the furpa law which is a which is a
student Privacy Law that had govern
schools uh there is a parents right to
review their child's records I I had no
idea that you couldn't even access this
I mean I didn't even know about this and
I'm thinking you got to be kidding me
what is going on why is there such a
drive to to come between a child and a
parent this is going to impact very few
people I never checked my child's
records most people don't but you know
what if I found out my kids looking at
bomb making stuff I might want to go
look
I mean it just makes sense and you know
what it could be it could be
helpful
um parents also don't have to do this
they don't have to do this most parents
are not going to do it so the relatively
few people that do that I'm going to
guess that there's probably a really
good reason my son could read Harry
Potter books his best friend couldn't
when he came to my house I didn't hand
them a Harry Potter book I respected
that parent I respected them let's show
some respect to parents and stop trying
to undermine them by trying to keep them
hidden from everything that's going on
in their child's life thank you for
listening questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much Nancy uh
be Beerman
please I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly
Perfect all right
I am just going to do bullet points um
first of all um we won't talk about how
old I am but it was the days when we
didn't have computers at the library and
the Librarians had no trouble keeping
track of what books I had taken out what
books I didn't take out and they knew
exactly how much money to charge me if I
didn't bring a book on time so
recordkeeping they could do it back in
the 80s and the 70s and we're not going
to go any further than that so did we
lose that skill in libraries I don't
know why so you don't need to have a
computer to do it because they could do
it back then and believe me they charged
fines back then um as far as your
address and not being on your license
you should have your uh physical address
on your license because you need that
when you go to vote uh because when you
register to vote you need to have your
uh your address matching otherwise you
are going to have difficulty voting
you're not going to be stopping stopped
from voting but you're going to have
some difficulty when you go to vote um
schools do not allow parents
um access to their child's library books
so I would I ask that schools be
included on this and not to assume that
people will generalize that sometimes
you need to put
specifics and um the expectation of
privacy on school property books are
school property and um and government
property are the books in the public
libraries and we already know that
student lockers are no there's no
expectation of privacy so the
expectation of privacy argument doesn't
work all right that's it thank you
question hang on questions for this
witness any question seeing none thank
please good afternoon chairman Lynn and
members of the committee my name is
Rebecca leak and I live in Andover uh I
am testifying in favor of HB
273 I believe this bill is common sense
a parent has the right and
responsibility to oversee what media
their child is consuming this is
especially important so that parents can
determine the appropriateness of that M
material for their minor child
furthermore this B bill is very narrow
only applying to the current records
kept of what media the child checks out
as someone who looks forward to someday
taking my future children to the library
I would expect to have access to the
records kept of what my child has kept
has checked out whether this is simply
so that I can find an overdue book or so
that I can ensure what my child is
reading or watching is appropriate for
their age moreover as someone who was a
minor not too long ago I fully expected
that my parents had access to the
records kept of what I had checked out
therefore I urge you to recommend that
HB 273 ought to pass thank you for
considering my testimony I welcome any
questions questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much man' um
arene
Q thank you chairman Lynn and members of
the Judiciary Committee is nice to see
familiar faces and be back here um for
the record my name is Arlene corello and
I represented ainson in the legislature
last term and I was actually the one who
introduced this bill originally um we
made some changes to address the
counterarguments that were have been
brought up about the money and about um
the the um address um most parents I
have spoken to are shocked that's the
general reaction to learn of the state
law that prohibits them from knowing
what books their kids have checked out
they weren't aware that when they took
their children to the library for that
great American right of a passage
signing up for a library card that they
were also signing away with a
that what they should consider a
parental right they didn't know that
they might someday go to the library and
be asked to pay an overdue fine on a
book but illogically that they were not
allowed to know the title of the book
who not only pays overdue fins but his
taxpayers actually pays for Library
material and provides the funds to run
school and public libraries parents in
numerous Library policies I checked I
got at numerous I just stopped looking
they were so numerous who is held
financially responsible for any loss or
damaged materials checked out by minors
their parents Library policies not state
law but most Library policies say that
according to the American Library
Association whose role this is a quote
role is to monitor his or her child's
individual reading life parents how can
parents possibly fulfill this role if
they can't find out what books their
children have checked out now to address
two counterarguments one is the money um
this is not an unfunded mandate this
will cost nothing um the
uh there is no historical component to
this it is currently checked out every
library has these records even if
they're not automated um I believe that
with all due respect that a previous uh
witness really made a very complicated
uh description of how this might work
out um uh so as another said in the' 70s
in the you know or whatever when I was a
kid you know they did just fine without
the computers um the other issue was the
driver's license um and this was to
address the safety concern involving
non-custodial
parents uh a driver's license would be
the best proof of the address um there
must be some proof of that address um a
child their account should have the
address of that they're currently at if
it's changed they should change it uh
they shouldn't have an library account
has a wrong address on it and um a a
parent usually accompanies a minor to
get a library card and at that time they
have to show a driver's license um I was
a librarian I've seen the nuts and bolts
of how this works one other counter AR
you're you're at your three minute limit
just ask okay I was I was hoping on five
but um if I can't say it in three then
then it probably doesn't need to be said
so um yes please vote OTP on HB 273 and
thank you for this opportunity thank
thank you question representative man
thank you Mr chair quick question so and
this is your opinion if more parents
knew that they were not entitled to this
information do you think more parents
would not bring their children in for
library cards I think that what they
would do is they would just check all
the books out on their own cards and
they wouldn't let their children get
library cards and that would be a shame
because getting a library card is really
it I I said it in here it's a right of
passage you know if you ever saw Arthur
and the arvar and he's saying having fun
isn't hard if you have a library card
you know and to deprive a child of that
but what a lot of parents will do and
I've spoken to some of them is they'll
just put the the books on their own card
and not have the child get a card not
expose them to that you know taking
their right away other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much man appreciate it um JS
biset uh I know Mr Binet was here
uh We've written testimony I think was
jointly written by Mr V and Mr 's here
but but he did hand in a pink card so he
responded well he if he's provided
written testimony I'm going to uh I'm
going to given the hour I'm going to
close the uh he said he he said he's on
his
all
yeah no no don't worry thank thank you
back I did no I I mean no I don't I mean
I don't have a physical copy of I have
the one online but I I think I think
it's
Mr chairman how are you good I'm so
sorry for the no no no no no problem but
just I'd ask you to please keep your
remarks to three minutes I'll keep it
less than that if that's okay and I
apologize for being late I'm um trying
to be in two places at once today um I
don't want to uh repeat the testimony of
attorney urell but just to reiterate I'm
JB I'm the legal director of the AC seu
uh of New Hampshire and we are here in
opposition as well along with glad to HB
273 with respect to the unfunded mandate
concerns that I I have heard those
certainly came up last year as well and
I also think formed the basis for then
the children and family law committee to
reject this legislation um so I I want
to just kind of uplift to those concerns
because they certainly I thought were uh
persuasive last year and continue to be
persuasive
one obvious correction to that if uh
this committee as well has those
concerns would be to limit this bill's
application to only information that is
accessible to the library at the time a
parental request is made that
potentially could alleviate the concerns
but I do agree that as written the um
shall be available language I think
could very plausibly be read to mean
libraries have to keep and retain all
that information even if it's not
information that they routinely keep
under their um document and electronic
management policy so I just just wanted
to uplift that um if if that continues
to be if that is a concern of this
committee and lastly I I just did want
to highlight
that um certainly understands the
concern that that maybe a parent would
have that they would want to have access
to this information and they can't get
access to this information one I think
solution to that right is for a parent
to not um is is for a parent to make
sure that their child when they get
books are using the parent's library
card right and that parent would then
have access to all of that information
so I think that is a much more narrowly
tailored approach that parents can take
in the home rather than um enacting a
bill like this which I do think has
privacy implications for the reasons
that attorney urel mentioned uh earlier
today question for this wit
representative Smith thank you um is
there
a a definition of the a of age what is
meant when you use the word Child
In N Hampshire
law well it's um here this would apply
to a Minor's record so my interpretation
would be that would apply to anyone
that's under the age of 18 that's my
interpretation of it but it's because of
the use of the word Min or not the use
of the word child guest representative
yeah thank you yeah the questions
representative
pno thank you chairman lynen thank you
for taking my question I believe you um
suggested that a child be allowed to use
a parents library card if they wanted if
the parent wanted to make sure that they
knew what the child was checking out um
would that not be burdensome to the
library also in that they probably would
need to receive um permission from the
parent that this child was allowed to
check out the check out books on their
card I mean what if they just walked in
and said yeah my mom says it's okay then
wouldn't they have to follow up with the
parent and determine whether or not they
were permitted to do that I I don't
think so I I think if a child has their
parents library card I think it's a
pretty safe inference to believe that
that child has permission to access
those books and of course in that
scenario when the books are given if
they are given and I hope hope they
would if they're given to that minor
that parent would then have the ability
through that account to be tracking um
the information that that minor is
obtaining representative
bur thank you Mr chair thank you like
like I was saying when my kids went to
the library they had to be able to
cursively write their name to get the
card so if you have kids going there
they'll you know that's the Manchester
one but at this point in time they were
so proud of seeing their signature every
single time so I don't see Tak my card
so I guess at this point I'm just
explaining to you that not everybody you
know as far as as the kids I don't know
if I see that parents doing that
so I I don't I'm not sure there's a
question there maybe maybe there is I
think it's a more ter ter approach but I
I mean I understand the making the kids
are like when the kids go into the
library and they don't have a card yet
but they can write their name they're
going to give them a card and they're
the kids are going to be happy about it
that's the way it works in Manchester
sure well I think you know part of my I
guess my response would be Again part of
I think the way to address this is right
continued parental involvement right and
with respect to what the child is doing
be aware and having constant and
effective Communications with one
children I mean I think it is not
unreasonable in these situations I think
when a parent does not want their
children to have access to information
without them knowing to say you were not
I'm not going to allow you to get a card
you shouldn't get a card I'm going to
tell the library you shouldn't get a
card but here's my library card which
gives the parent all degree of access
then with respect to the borrowing uh
history that would be I think my
preference rather than what I think is a
sweeping law here um that that has
privacy implications from my vantage
point all right thank you very much
thank you Mr chair sorry representative
trip uh you made you raised a
interesting point uh our minor children
allowed to get their own card without
the parents' permission
it's a great I actually don't know I
would defer to uh the librarian
Representatives uh here today um I
whether they can get a card for
themselves without parental permission
yeah I I would defer to the Librarians
question the gentleman says no all right
great thank you very much thank you Mr
chair thank you all right anyone else
who wishes to testify on HB
273 right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on HB 273 before I let
everyone go I want to raise this issue
and I I know we're late but I I also
know we have a lot of bills and um I
think executing them all is going to be
is going to be a challenge so if we can
get rid of the executive on on two which
I hope are we would all be agreeable on
um I'd like to do that so what i s what
I would suggest is and I'm going to ask
just for a show of hands initially I
would propose that we exec now House
Bill 98 that's representative tur's bill
on the assistant manager uh which is the
bill we passed last year and I would
also propose that we exact House Bill
164 FN which is representative
Alexander's bill on local records
retention which we passed last year um
which and I when I say we I mean the
house passed but both of these bills
last year um and so um you know I I I
think and I this is what I'm really
asking are I think that these should not
be controversial and that we would have
strong bipartisan support for both of
them Mr chair I I completely agree with
you I would like to actually see if the
committee would be willing to do 376 as
well um that was the library right to
know um
I it seemed to me with the public
hearing there was broad agreement on it
um but I just want to leave that for the
committee as well I'm I'm I am willing
you know what why don't we let's let's
let's sort of just let's just take let's
just take these in order can I just ask
informally this is in no way a formal
vote informally how many would be
willing to
uh uh to exec and pass HB 98 that's
representative burgon or where are you
yeah oh so I don't have 98 right here
you should
right just from today right okay yeah I
all all right so let me just let me let
me just ask is there anyone here who is
opposed to executing House Bill 98 that
is representative tur bill from last
year which we
passed all right seeing none then I'm
going to then um I would uh recognize
thank thank you I would like to move or
to pass on House Bill 98 relative to
professional limited liability company
assistant manager status right do we
have a second in
that seconded by representative Burch
but uh representative Smith would you
like to speak your briefly it we had
extensive testimony last year um
and for reasons that had nothing to do
with the merits of the bill the bill
didn't make it to
um uh the final line and um I would
suggest that it is appropriate for us
now to pass this bill and one would hope
unanimously and send it to the floor um
uh absent uh fiscal note um
to uh to send it to the floor without
having any to even debate it on the
floor because it does address a problem
that could be easily solved by this bill
and should be solved In fairness all
right anyone else wish to be heard on um
HB
98 seeing none then I will ask the uh
representative
Manion yes representative Alexander yes
Andress absent representative
Perez clerk votes
yes um representative Smith yes
representative Horan
no representative
I'm yes
okay representative Paige oh abent sorry
representative Manos
yes her is absent representative Rambo
yes can I representative Bergeron yes
and rep chairman Lynn yes and
representative uh uh org did you want to
change your vote Yes from I like change
it to from no to yes so right so thank
you so 1 2
3 that's 13 10 11 12 13 13 to zero 13 to
Z can this uh can this go on consent
anybody object to this being on
consent all right the bill will be on
consent representative Smith could I ask
you to prepare my pleasure me who
seconded that motion uh represent second
Y
and okay all right next I'd like to turn
to um again and I'm just an inform
normally first this is representative
Alexander's Bill relative to local
records retention again what number it's
uh HB 164 FN this bill was you know
passed uh by the house last year it's I
it seems to me it's a very sensible and
also very important bill that that calls
for um
uh a modernized and electronic system of
local record retention so again can I
just as for a show of hands is maybe the
best way to do that is there anybody
that would
oppose um exing HB 164 FN right
now I seeing none then I um I would
entertain call on representative
Alexander for a motion I move off to
pass on 164 there a second I second
representative Smith second the the uh
motion uh representative Alexander you
want to speak to the no Mr chair you
said it so eloquently I can't follow up
all right all right anyone else wish to
be heard on uh HP
164 all right then I would ask the clerk
to please call the
role representative
Manion yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew representative
Perez clerk votes yes representative
Smith yes representative Horgan yes
representative Burch
yes paig is absent representative Manos
yes representative Rambo yes and
representative berson yes thank
you and the chair oh and then sorry it's
all right no problem I vote Yes also
thank you all right um now this this is
a we can't we can't do this on consent
right we can't do it on consent all
right um oh wait a minute is
there there's it has a fiscal note
there's $150,000 cost to be it's this is
going to go to for finance it's going to
go to finance next but um um I think we
can't even put it on consent because
yeah we can't because spend money so
it'll go on it'll go on the regular
calendar I bet it might end up in the
budget too uh representative Alexander
can you write the report on this okay
and you know what can I both
representative Smith and representative
Alexander could I ask you please if you
could get the report to me by say
tomorrow evening by tomorrow at the end
of the day and I think probably you can
both write you can both just copy the
reports that you wrote last year
changing the
Beil
cic all right um all right so let me
turn to the last one we arguably could
could EXA exact and that is H B
376 is I don't know representative
Alexander believes that there's a
consensus on this uh um if if if there
is can I ask is anybody would anybody be
opposed to executing HB
now and I
assume I missed the hearing and so I'm a
little
behind the AIL on this one I'm apologize
understand this is the one that would
have the that that would it would
basically say you know the current law
says you Library user and this would say
that that includes the library card and
the uh Library membership Library
membership
status representative Manos I I
personally would rather refrain and
think about it particularly given that
uh representative Smith wasn't
here all right
um and representative Smith you I take
it you have you well I don't know yeah
no no no I think I yeah no listen I I
hear you and
I'm I should I should say just so
there's no misunderstanding despite the
questions that I had for the the prime
sponsor I also will support this bill
because I think it makes I think it
makes a lot of sense um but nonetheless
I think given given representative Manos
is concerned and also given the hour um
I think I'm gonna I'm going to pass on
executing that representative I I would
just agree not I think it's entirely
possible that there will be a broad
support I just think there were a lot of
questions and it might be worthwhile for
us to have some I don't want to I don't
want to I don't want to take do this if
anybody has any concerns so we'll uh
thank you everyone for a long day I very
we'll I'm I'm done yes AB um as I think
every excuse me hang on let's listen to
representative it it is my understanding
that on
Monday well now let me reword this could
you please Mr chair explain to us what
we should anticipate on Monday yes I I
will do that now that's a very so first
of all the the the
amendment is is I believe is now public
I mean it under the rules it has to be
it has to be public uh for at least 24
or 40 I don't remember which but anyway
it the the amendment should be public so
what will what I anticipate will happen
on Monday is that we will have a hearing
476 at some point when that hearing is
over we will have a hearing on the non
gerain amendment to HB
then everyone should be prepared for
executing the bill and the non gerain
Amendment at the end of that hearing
um can I absolutely guarantee that we
will do that no but everybody should be
on on board that you know that is that
is a very definite possibility that we
will do that and so you should you know
both caucuses should have all their
people present or substitutes okay
um not having seen the
amendment um could I ask you if the
amendment Begins by saying that the
amendment completely replaces the text
text of the bill it does that's exactly
what it says it completely replaces the
text of the Bill thank you and it is a
and it is a an abortion statistics
reporting
Bill okay um could I ask
um I
mean could I ask that and that me that
hearing is to begin at 9:30 that hearing
is to begin at
9 then I I believe we are believe
beginning at 9:30 yes wait a minute hang
on I got my uh 9:30 that's right yes
good um could I ask that the
Democrats meet at 9
o'l UM to go over the amendment um
course it would either be then Mr chair
or we would have to do
it you know at some point later in the
morning and I don't want to have to do
that
and I will agree to for a place for
where we can meet um so that we can
review the language of the amendment no
no no that's fine so all right so you're
so you're we'll plan that you're going
to be I won't be here where where we we
me is it in the it's in rep's hall right
in rep's Hall yes yeah okay so I'll
rrange first to meet in uh the state
house so people don't have to go back
and forth um
that the right okay I
I I as I say I my understanding is it
need under the rules it needs to be
published you know it needs to be
available I think it says in the
sergeant-at-arms office e it's either 24
or 48 hours but today's only today's
only Wednesday I believe it might not be
but I think it's Wednesday we're talking
about Monday so that gives us Thursday
and Friday I would hope that the
amendment is in fact in the calendar
that comes out tomorrow night but I
don't know that but meanwhile if you
have a copy of the amendment Mr chair
perhaps you would be so kind as to send
that um to through email to everybody on
the committee that that that's fine I
well I do have I don't have a hard copy
but I do have the don't care about a
hard copy and I'll send I will send that
out tonight when I get home because I
don't have my computer here with me but
I'll send it out
tonight okay you of course have access
to a computer as chairman it's right on
your desk but you don't have to use it
it's okay right fact and you know I
haven't used it in so long I have no
idea what the password is on that
computer I have no idea okay I
understand that I have trouble enough
with my passwords I can understand you
you do okay so I will I will notify the
um yeah and that will I will get that
out to everyone tonight okay thank you
thank you very much all right all right
um any further business all right I
think we are adjourned thank you